good morning everybody and welcome to
mid suffolk district council's
development control b meeting today 25th
of november 2020
um can i just ask all the speakers who
are here to turn off their videos please
because we don't want to lose
connections um during the proceedings so
if those who are just speakers can you
turn off your video thank you and then
when you are speaking we would like you
to turn them back on
i'd also like to welcome those who may
be watching on youtube and i'm sure
there's a lot of people who are so
welcome to you all
now first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking that you do not interrupt the
other speaker members are reminded not
to use the messaging or chat function
during the meeting unless it's to report
a pecuniary non-pecuniary interest or to
notify the chair that you wish to make a
proposal
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open i.e other skype chats and that if
you are contacted by a third party
during an application you should bring
this to the legal advisor's attention
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions please await
your turn we will not be using the hands
up function except for declarations of
interest site visits
declarations of lobbying and questions
for clarity and in the second round of
debate we can do it that way
if you're experiencing poor connection
issues in the first instance please turn
off your camera if this does not work
please turn off all incoming video these
options are under the three dots in the
main information bar
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recording
for webcasting and all training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
the introductions in dupreeh legal
advisor robert carmichael governance
officer vincent pierce case officer
daniel cameron case officer
area planning manager john payton g
and we do have the ward members john
field lavinia hadingham and julie
flatman
may i move on to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
thank you
present
present
present
present
present
present
present
present
thank you
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members and
you may use the hands up function
there are none
declarations of lobbying and again you
may use the hands up function
[Music]
i think it will probably be all of us
and certainly for me it is for the
freshing field
application does anyone have any
alternative
no so that would be for the freshing
field thank you very much
i need to take my hand down
declarations of pers excuse me personal
site visits please
there are none
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 28th of october
are any points regarding
accuracy in the minutes please
no may i have a proposal please
mark norris happy to propose thank you
councillor norris and i saw councillor
humphreys as a seconder is that correct
well your hand came up yes i'm sure i'd
like to second the proposal thank you
very much both
robert can you take a roll call please
so if members could please respond with
for against or abstain so councillor
james carsten
four
councillor peter gould
four
counts to kathy guthrie
four
council barry humphreys four councillor
andrew mellon
four councilman mike norris
four councillor andrew stringer
four
and council rhoden
four
thank you chair that is carried
unanimously
and the minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed and will be signed at the next
practicable
opportunity thank you
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
an unreceived chair
the schedule of planning applications i
will run them in the order in which they
appear in the papers and just for
information
i would suggest robert if you're happy
with this that we can advise members
that the application
dc1905956
won't be heard before eleven o'clock
does that sound reasonable
uh yes if if you want wish to advise
members um to come back for that sorry
speakers to come back for the
application at that time that's
completely reasonable providing that we
do not start business on that item prior
to that time
do i need to have a vote for this um in
dupray
if i if i can jump in before ian does i
don't believe you do chair as it's your
prerogative as chair to be able to
change the order
quite right madam chairman yes sorry not
the timing sorry apologies chair
then then i think that's reasonable
because if we are a few minutes early we
can always have a five minute break so
um for those people watching uh for that
later application they might like to do
something else if not please stay with
us
and
watch the earlier applications so thank
you for that
so we will be starting with
um land at black acre hill brantford
road and vincent pierce will introduce
the application to the committee please
if you would thank you
listeners and viewers i just need to
activate the presentation so please bear
with me for a moment
hopefully very shortly
a presentation should appear
can anyone confirm whether or not that
has happened
it hasn't yet for me
okay no not yet so since
okay
any joy
no
ah okay
okay
[Music]
yep
right
strangely
okay i'll cancel this year because it is
showing up as sharing online but
right try again
it actually shows up on my screen and
it's actually sharing but it from the
look
of your face kathy you're not seeing no
no it's not sorry
no no you're looking perfectly on the
ball it's just you're looking
disappointed not to be able to see the
i wonder if john's got it on his laptop
whether we can do it that way john
paintman g you normally have it
i don't have a copy of that particular
powerpoint it's not
of that um
i'm just wondering if
have you got a um another document open
uh vincent that you can share instead to
just test if it's sharing at all
anything
or possibly sharing
but make sure you don't show anything
private
the only other thing you can do is reset
teams
and uh
come out a bit entirely and go back in
again okay
i'm having a final throw of the dice
chair with something else
that also looks as though nothing has
happened
so apologies everyone i think i'm gonna
have to take john's advice i'm gonna
have to sign out
and then sign back in apologies
that's all right these things happen
we'll work for you to get that thank you
yeah hopefully i'll just be a minute or
two
uh the only other last ditch thing we
could try if that's not successful is i
can access um the central drive to get
the original powerpoint up and running
but if vincent's able to quickly
upload whatever current version that is
i might be able to access it and then be
able to display it from here i don't
know whether you can hear me john i can
hear we can see you as well you're still
very strange because it it's telling me
i'm leaving but it hasn't made me leave
yet so
they should all be in the p drive uh
john and i'll be the one with the latest
time i was working on them last night so
whichever one
ah
okay let me go there um
this is even stranger because
it's actually not leaving letting me
leave even
we have some weirdness going on this
morning members
robert can you um
exit vincent from your things
can you force me out
um no i can still hear
the only thing the first time ever i
i've asked people not to come back
before 11 o'clock
and i seem to have got a bit of a muddle
on it but it would still be vincent
anyway so we need to get everything
sorted
excellent
do apologize to the public these things
happen but we do our best
hmm
okay
right i've found the presentation um
if i don't know if it's gone but i might
not be able to get back in now
uh i'm just attempting to share myself
in a moment if that helps and hopefully
it'll come up
i'll do just
he could join by phone and then you
could drive the um
yeah
presentation
i got that
robert can you contact um
vince and see if he can join by phone
and um
john will just have to sort of
flick the slides forward
i'm sorry
so i've just requested mr pierce to join
through teams again um he should be able
to do that even if he can't control the
presentation i believe there is a
functionality
that mr pierce can control
the presentation but i don't want to
over complicate things
no no
c
uh
daniel cameron are you still on in the
listening to the meeting
[Music]
um in terms of presentation um
i have a fear especially as i'm getting
a new computer on friday that this thing
will run out possibly in the next couple
of hours
on behalf of vincent if that's how we
organize this
standby to also go into p drive and
present any item if we need to switch
and get you to present instead the
actual point you can just be
aware of that need thank you
robert i wonder if we should suspend the
meeting for the moment so it's not
running and then uh reconvene
uh particularly for members of the
public yes thank you chair sorry i've
just spoken to mr pierce unfortunately
what has happened is his computer has
done an automatic update so that's why
he was kicked out and so extreme
apologies on that front but he is he's
just said to me that he has just
restarted and he should be here
momentarily oh excellent excellent
apology
i'm sure he'll say that himself
okay thank you
just to save time we'll present this
item through my computer um and then
we'll when we switch to the next item we
can always try again in terms of
vincent's computer if the update has
solved the problem perhaps
good morning chair
good morning vince off you go are you
thank you okay
did um was robert aber to explain what
had happened yes indeed yeah
it does appear
i don't know whose screen is that
something that you've put on the screen
john or am i right that's john your
presentation that is on the p drive i'm
hoping i've chosen the right one it's
the most up-to-date um
the only thing to do really is to carry
forward if you just tell me to change
slides when you need me to okay i'm
sorry it's going to be a bit clumsy on
that respect or would you want me to
just have one last try now that my
system has completely updated itself can
we just go ahead on this one and then do
it again yeah of course
thank you
the item before you this morning is an
application to vary two conditions
conditions 20 and 26
on an existing
planning consent next one please john
so we are looking at uh an employment
application
in
great blakenham
known as port one
next slide
so on the screen you can actually see
i've identified the port one business
park it's very close to the
waste
energy from waste building that i've
identified
also just south to what will be the
snoasus
site
accessed via junction 51 on the a14
members will have noticed a large
industrial building going up on the site
at present that's very near to
completion and is about to be fitted out
by the new occupiers
next slide please john
so the applicants are cursing de vir who
are undertaking the whole of the port 1
development
next slide
please
so we look at each of the proposed
variations in turn next slide please
so what we have on the
screen is
an explanation of how we've gone about
this so we've had a request to vary
condition 20 and that request has come
from the applicants that has been looked
at
by
the district council the county council
and the parish council
and
generally we believe that to be
acceptable in the form of wording that
the applicant has proposed so that's
what we're putting before you this
morning in terms of condition 26
the applicant made some suggested
amendments
again we considered them and we were not
happy with the the wording
so we have discussed revised wording
with the applicant
and it is the revised wording that we
are recommending to you
this morning
so if we can go to the next slide please
john
so
the part that says no part of the
development is the original wording
the blue text is the requested wording
so the key here is that
originally or as existing
no part of the development can be
occupied until
the access
has been
constructed in its entirety
now what we have
come across
is obviously the covid crisis
and what has happened is that the
junction works have not been able to be
completed
prior to
the handover of the new unit the works
are ongoing
the works are being supervised
however
we felt it unreasonable to prevent the
new occupier from getting into the
premises to fit it out
and so what we are suggesting
or what the applicant suggested in the
highway authority have agreed is that we
have a condition
as put out within 24 months of
occupation of the first unit or earlier
before the third unit so
hopefully this will allow the new
occupier to get in fit out the unit
the works to the junction can be ongoing
and
therefore
we're happy that that flexibility will
allow the operator to move in but it
will not prejudice highway safety and on
that basis we are saying
we recommend the
amended condition
if we can go to the next slide john we
look at 20 condition 26
and this relates to off-site
or off-road cycle improvements on
branford road and again
these are required to be
constructed before a first occupation
and we have the same issue
in terms of
the unit currently under construction is
now being fitted out covid has caused a
delay in completion of the works so what
we are
suggesting is not that we put the works
off pending the submission of a
delivery
program we are actually saying along
with the highway authority no we don't
want to put it off
particularly for a long time but what we
are willing to do is suggest that prior
to the occupation of the second unit
on the development
the off-road cycle improvements along
branford road between the site axis and
its junction with edison way shall be
completed so that will allow the first
unit to be occupied fitted out
and
and start being used now you may say
well how can people get to the site if
the access is still being formed so we
can go to the next slide john please
presently
traffic would be able to use the addison
road access which
is the
dog-legged road to the the top half of
that
thank you john
so you would be able to get into there
while the orange square
junction is being formed please note
that with the outline planning
permission
so in terms of condition 20 and 26 the
orange junction on that screen was not
proposed to be
signalized
the signalization comes with the
next application when we discuss that
but ultimately as part of those
cycle improvements
the connection between addison way and
the rest of the port one site in the
orange square will be closed to hgv
traffic traffic and i know there was
some concern expressed previously that
what people didn't want was for traffic
hgv traffic to to be able to continue
using the addison road
access well that that is not going to
happen that will be controlled by
condition
26 and that will be close to hgv traffic
next slide please john
so that is a screenshot of the junction
works that are currently
underway
completely new access being formed for
port one
next slide please john
part of those works are
footwear cycleway
connections
along that frontage across that junction
they are three meter
wide that will run right into the port
one development and connect all parts of
the port one development
to this access on both sides of that
road so there will be excellent
connectivity
next slide please john
just highlighting again the
the point at which access will be closed
to hgvs
next slide please john
currently there are um
traffic management
techniques in operation in addison way
so there's
no parking bollards along both sides of
the road there is an enforcement
contractor
who monitors the situation
and uh people can get parking
enforcement notices
if they are parked
in places that they shouldn't be there
is use of anpr
that's number plate recognition and cctv
and the point here is that
by preventing people parking on the on
the road
it is possible for hgvs to maneuver
around that
clearly if people started parking let's
say on that bend it does make it
difficult for hgvs and the whole point
of the new access is that
port one can be served with
purpose-built
road that is capable of accommodating
hgv movements in a way that addison way
isn't
so there are benefits all round once
that access is in and we get the port
one development
off the ground next slide please john
just to remind members as part of the
outline planning permission originally
we did secure
a mini bus
shuttle
uh arrangement that is
still on the cards and what will happen
is the port one
minibus will take the route shown in
blue and pick up local people who are
working on the
the site the actual details have yet to
be finalized
but there is
no fear of that being withdrawn either
as part of this
variation of condition or
the following application in terms of
the expansion
next slide please john
as part of the original application as
well the applicants have agreed
i would say some a groundbreaking
emergency ride home scheme whereby
employees
are able to
get access to
effectively a taxi or cab ride home in
extenuating circumstances so although
the footway cycleway might be put off
for a little
while whilst the
access gets formed there is this other
raft of
innovative measures in terms of the
shuttle minibus and the emergency ride
home facility
that are all
encouraging people
to get to the site
without using their car
next slide please john
so on that basis members we are
recommending the uh variation of
conditions as set out in the report and
just to remind you we are perfectly
happy with the suggested wording put
forward by the applicant for condition
20 and what we're recommending to you is
the
revised wording agreed with suffolk
county council in respect of condition
26 as set out in the report thank you
chair thank you john
thank you vincent
um we now come to the point where if
members would like to have a clear or a
clarity point made um do you want to put
your hands up if anybody wants to ask
the planning officer a question that
hasn't been made clear
and we've got
councillor field please
oh can i just before you start um cancer
field can i just see if any members of
the committee
sure
sorry
councillor stringer if you would please
thank you
thank you chair i've got two two
questions uh or just pieces of clarity
so
we're
this calm this road junction hasn't been
done in line with the original
conditions because covid precluded
work on that junction
but it didn't preclude work on the
warehouses
can i just have that clarified and what
i want to know is the the original
condition said you cannot occupy a
building unless this junction is
provided
what happens if we grant this in two
years time if the junction is still not
provided
thank you
councillor stringer i'll deal with the
second point
first
if
the junction isn't provided then no more
units can be occupied the only reason
we're showing some flexibility is
because the junction works were
delayed due to
road building work ceasing during the
darkest time of the lockdown now
clearly if the highway construction work
had ceased so did
some of the construction work on the
building
however the work on the building
proceeded at a
quicker rate when people were able to
work than the
highway works because obviously with the
highway works
there also had to be
road closures
access into the highway that all took
time to
arrange and rearrange because obviously
slots for working in the highway are
limited in time so
the combination meant that the building
has proceeded quicker than the junction
but the
comfort i can give you is that once this
building is occupied if the junction
works aren't completed that holds up the
rest of the development but subject to
there being no further
complete lockdowns there is no reason
why that should happen i mean to be fair
to the applicants they have been working
hard
with both the county and ourselves to
try and progress those
those works
so we have every confidence that
we won't get to a point where another
building is ready to be occupied and the
works aren't in because actually it is
in the interest of the
developer to have those works because
that's part of the selling point of the
development
thank you
um councillor castin i think i saw your
hand up did i not
thank you very much madam chairman um
in this is the um
an inclusion of
some sort of wheel wash or um
um
street cleaning in the early stages of
this development for addison way i
assume there would have been
something in place for the access
that is is obviously
not going to be um completed first um
what have we what we got in place or is
that
our job to um
look after that
it's a
cracking point
councillor kesten what we normally have
is a condition that says
as part of the construction method
statement during construction
works
roads have to be
swept we do have the benefit of having
sam harvey with us this morning from
our
partner authority suffolk county the
highway authority
i don't know whether
sam under the section 38 or the 278 you
also have
controls over preventing mud from being
deposited on the highway during
construction work
good morning everyone yes we we do um we
have we have the powers to um instruct
the contractor to make sure that there
are we're washing and there um the
carriageway is swept so there's no
debris on the highway
thank you hopefully that announces that
one for you councillor caster yes thank
you very much
thank you and um i've got a bit of a
confused screen at the moment so unless
there are any more committee members i
believe councillor field had a question
thank you
yes i did thank you councillor stringer
has got sort of one of mine certainly
perhaps it could be uh made clear to me
why
uh 10 months of covet maybe 12 by the
time we get to the end of the current
wave has caused a 24 month delay to
highways work seems a big multiplying
effect there
second point perhaps is
if the addison y entrance is going to be
beyond capacity which is what the
highways analysis says
how is it acceptable to delay that
entrance for two years again
it's a considerable period
third point related to that is that the
point or one of the points of the new
entrance is to prevent
vehicles hgvs turning left out of
addison y which is a sort of a valid
maneuver you have to be able to access
the site from both directions for
various purposes but hgvs would then
transit
blake in them and need a market to quote
just two areas which have weight
restrictions and considerable housing
close to the road
so we seem to be
leaving them at risk for that so there's
two questions
third one and then i'll stop
i thought you shot up the three already
oh well
i could never could count
condition 26 highways
there's a new world newly worded
condition but if i look on page 44 it
says
that those
developments will not now be feasible
it will not now be feasible to complete
the construction
and i didn't notice a time limit on that
so i assumed there's something
preventing that high but way being built
so could you clarify those points thank
you yes
if we start first councillor field with
the 24 months
john if you could please go to slide
seven
i think it is
yeah it's the
the applicant there on condition 24
months within
yeah
i said what we have
built in is absolute
flexibility but the
you you're right it might take
less than the
24 months but
what we're thinking is because of
condition 26 john if we can just go to
the next slide
what we're saying there is prior to the
occupation of the second
unit
off-road cycle improvements along
brownford road
will have to be
in place
because those cycle improvements include
the um
signalization as part of the next
application we believe that they will be
in significantly quicker than the
24 months because it'll be tied to
occupation
but it is fair to say that we have built
in flexibility
to
allow the construction work to go ahead
but also to factor in any other works
that are being required as part of the
snowasis development and what we're
trying to do is avoid
branford road being closed or dug up
lots of times over the next 24
months
so we have built in that flexibility in
terms of the right turn i think if we
can go back to the junction slide john
that you had up a moment ago
that's it
the current
outline planning permission the one that
condition 20 and 26 relate to does not
include signalization of that junction
it is the following application the
expansion application that provides
signals to that junction and it is that
work
that that controls
movement
out of that
junction and prevents hgvs going back
into
great placenum as part of the outline
planning permission there is the closure
between addison way and port one so
hgvs will not be able to track back out
through addison way but actually getting
the control over the movement of hgvs
out of the access on the screen
is made absolutely foolproof by the
delivery of signals and that only comes
with the next application
so technically
if an hgv wanted to try and turn left
out of that junction
it could have a go but it probably would
have to swing out across the other lane
or nip across the curb which is
far from ideal
so it's the signalization in the next
part of the
agenda that actually delivers that final
piece of the jigsaw signalization wasn't
secured and wasn't felt necessary for
the first phase of
development
your reference to page 44
i haven't got the agenda now because
that went i don't know whether something
if somebody could
read out the page but there is nothing
that would prevent development
proceeding per se
other than
delivery of the
works associated with condition 20 and
26
and as i think i'm saying to counselor
stringer
if
the junction works are not in place that
holds up further development but if the
junction
works are in place
there is nothing preventing completion
of the
first phase of development and if
planning permission is approved for the
following item
nothing to prevent that being completed
in its entirety
so sorry that's a long answer for
the points you've raised kathy
hopefully more briefly
my concern
i thought i asked clearly was that in
the interim 24 month period
hgvs will be exiting var addison y the
next junction down
and that has bi-directional
exit by you know you may turn left or
right if i put it simply yeah um
and it was during that period i quite
accept that by the time you put lights
and things in on this new junction it
will constrain that behavior and that's
what local people require so i
understand the new junction i don't
understand
we just want clarity i'm trying to make
sure the question is clear because
obviously i have a difficulty with that
issue
and i'm quite happy to read out the
other paragraph sentence to you if you
like it comes from christopher fish
senior development management engineer
growth highways and infrastructure
if you can get someone else to read it
i'm equally no no that's fine thank you
for the absolute clarity i didn't doubt
for a minute
you understood what you meant it's
i was having trouble
digesting it you are absolutely right
until the new access is in hgvs will be
using the addison way
connection
and you're perfectly right hgvs
leaving addison way can go either left
or right
once the junction is in
and even once the signals are in and
that connection is closed obviously hgvs
serving the existing developments off
addison way will be able to come in and
out
without restriction and will also be
able to turn left when exiting that's
the existing arrangement and there is
nothing in the outline planning
permission or the
next application to prevent that
movement but i understand the point
you're making is why should local people
in great blaking them have to endure up
to a further 24 months with additional
hgvs from port 1 exiting via addison way
and turning left
that is
unfortunately the position we are in
but that will be short term because the
benefits we are securing
if the next application is improved will
enhance the situation
immeasurably
but there will be
a delay and that's been caused largely
through
delays in getting the access works
completed
thank you for that excellent manager
can i just come in just one little thing
on that obviously in the terminology of
the condition that's proposed to members
you have the
restriction here that it's first
occupation
um so we don't have any other
occupations coming forward it's so the
limit if you like in terms of what hgvs
will be allowed in the short term
limited in number by the occupation
level of the first
unit if i've got that correct um
so you have that caveat that controls it
despite the allowance to
allow the development to carry on
because of the
delays elsewhere on the road network
thank you
right
thank you very much for that
so um no further questions
so we now move on counselor phil can you
take your hand down please
um we now move on we don't have a
representative from the parish council
objector or supporter
so i will ask the applicant to speak
nick davey you have three minutes please
thank you
nick davey are you there
robert do we have the applicant
let's say sorry i'll just turn on my
other microphone to the public can hear
me as well
um actually that mr davey is in the
meeting
um
as a participant so when he puts
microphone
on
i can see mr maybe in terms of his video
although he's just come away from the
chair
um he seems to be having problems
because he's trying to fix something on
the
the video maybe a
microphone ah
okay thank you john
will you bear with it just for a couple
of minutes chair um
just see if mr davey can resolve
whatever technical issue is taking place
i think he has a plug-in mic he's trying
to plug in um but clearly that's causing
issues with whether he's mute or not
am i the only one you can see
video that he's transmitting no i can't
see it yeah i can't see it either i'm
afraid mr patrick
i can see it robert's claire i believe
mr davey is there now
you're very faint i wonder if you can go
directly from your computer rather than
a microphone
no can't really hear you
actually
he started to talk he started to go he
can get a bit closer than he
chair in the interim would it be
would it be appropriate if we had
councillor field
uh first just to move proceedings along
yes i'm quite happy with that cancer
field are you happy with that at the
moment
i can do that
thank you yes um
if you'd like to give us your
presentation please okay
fairly brief perhaps for this particular
part of the the overall procedure
i i think first of all i i would want to
emphasize that i i think i have accepted
and supported the ex this business park
since it's close to the a14
uh and it's clearly part of a series of
developments in spartan blakenham
gateway 14 and elswell
to boost the
capacity the warehouse capacity in in
suffolk in in in on the route to felix
stone or between felixstown and the
north so
whatever size i i'm certainly not just a
opposer of these
developments
and local people perhaps have a similar
somewhat pragmatic view but somewhat
more concern
about the issue of htvs
heavy numbers of hdvs which often run 24
7
passing their dwellings which as we all
know were built in victorian earlier
periods very close to roads so there is
a considerable concern
that we should control
various aspects particularly highways
aspects of these developments
and there are a series of highways
aspects
not all perhaps related to this
these two changes that we're debating
here
the one that is related to this one is
clearly
the use of addison y that that it was
cons there was a a condition that said
we built a new
or the developer built a new entrance
that entrance have uh has constrained
the transit of hgvs so that they turn
out of the site directly towards the a14
which is a short dual carriageway link
albeit it starts on a b class road which
is is somewhat constrained
so that was necessary and it's backed up
by the thought that there was
congestion at the addison way entrance
which already exists with the current
load let alone a new building let alone
a large number of new buildings but i
we the locals would completely take the
point that you're constraining this
change to just a single building
occupancy but even that is too much is
the feeling
um so that's one issue the other clear
issue is the confusion about
highways
condition 26
the footway the move towards sustainable
transport and i
totally heard everything that the
officer mentioned on that front other
actions being taken but clearly there's
wording from highways that says the
building of these new
new footways will not now be feasible
and i wish to explore that and wish to
object
to the removal of those sustainable
transport means
or what looks like the possible removal
of them
i think that sort of is restricting my
wider remarks to the ones that are
particularly concerned with this
proposed pair of changes okay
thank you for that captain field would
you mind if i responded well thank you
sorry
well funnily enough i was going to say
could yeah gone could
i've written a note here i've written
vince foot ways answer is what i've
written down on my papers
so can i can i just ask members um i'm
sure they're happy for vince to explain
that a little further for us before we
have further questioning of council of
field so uh vincent if you would like to
move
sorry for um yeah no no we're on the
same page because mr davey hasn't um
spoken yet this might give him time to
think about what i'm about to say but i
understand the point that uh
council of field has made there is a lot
of anxiety in great blaking about these
movements and i wonder if
with some subtle adjustment to the
wording
if we were to say prior to occupation of
the second unit or 12 months whichever
is the sooner
i think then councillor field that would
provide
additional comfort that the longest
local people
are expected to wait is 12 months
so that wouldn't be the 24 months
applied for by the applicant so we will
have halved that it will add some
momentum and an imperative to get those
works
sorted
so
sorry to spring that on everyone but i
i've i hear what you say councillor
fjordan
i have quickly skyped
uh sam harvey and we do think that 12
months
as the backstop would be a reasonable
limit so no matter what else happened
those works would have to be in place
within 12 months
i put that forward that isn't in
obviously in my recommendation and if
somebody if counselor field you felt
that was appropriate you might want to
suggest it as an amendment but at least
vincent
councillor field is not in the position
to recommend amendments that's apologies
of course let's just do that sorry
but but but i think that's very useful
because again i'd written sam as well so
uh thank you sam for those things there
so can we come back thank you for that
at the moment and we'll hold that one in
abundance um can i come back to members
do they have any further questions for
councillor field please
no
thank you very much
so
can we go back
to
mr davey have we got access to mr davey
please
can't hear a word you're saying i'm so
sorry mr davey
can you can you not use your computer
without that microphone
yeah but
does the computer not have a microphone
we just can't hear you
have you got your microphone turned up
on your computer we really can't hear
you mr davey um
robert is there any way he could
telephone in that we could hear it
let me just have a thing because i don't
believe that that function is available
um does does does his computer i'm not
technically know how nightmare i am with
it you have to turn the sound up on the
actual computer do you think because i
hear him very very faintly in the
background but
it could be more can someone help
with the
microphone sensitivity and the sound
settings as a possibility but i don't
know if mr david already tried that so i
don't want to
um
can i ask ian to pray legally can we go
ahead without the applicant making um
his comment
hello
i'm i'm here madam chair hopefully i
hope you can hear me um well we we have
a usual procedure whereby we invite
uh public speaking
and
we seem to have obviously in the council
chamber this wouldn't occur but we we we
have a pro a technical problem that
seems to be nobody's fault in particular
that means mr david can't be heard
uh i'm just well i like mr carmichael
i'm thinking as i go along what's the
best and
fairest way of dealing with this um
does it does mr davey have a written
presentation
forward
me or to robert carmichael
he goes to device settings on his pc
might be able to wind up the volume of
his match well that's what i was trying
to say it needs the computer to do it
sorry i didn't need to speak over
anybody i wonder if
if the committee takes a short say a
five-minute break and if somebody gets
on the phone to mr davey
i don't know who robert mr carmichael
one of my colleagues and and just sees
exactly if we can identify what the
problem is and what possible solutions
are is that what sounds
that sounds reasonable to me
um so if we take a five-minute break um
[Music]
so if you would like to suspend the
meeting for five minutes
sorry about delay we have now got mr
davey the applicant and robert if you
would like to time the three minutes
please thank you
yeah and i do apologize it's all my
fault
um thank you members um
and i hope that the port one logistics
park is a good news story
um
the first eight million pound unit
is completed to shell and was handed
over to its tenants on monday
and he's in the process of fitting the
building out with state of the art
further cost
can you just keep the phones
any better now
yeah just keep still
oh sorry right i'll carry on
i'll turn your video off though and then
just leave your voice on and we'll hear
that
all right is that okay
right start again if you would please
okay so apologies so um as i said
hopefully it's a good news story
the uh tenant has moved into the
building as on monday and is fitting it
out
and early in the new year it should be
operational and uh it will start
employing people and we reckon about
there'll be 150 people employed in that
building and we do have to apologize
we had the design of the branford road
junction the psychopath approved over
two years ago
but for circumstances largely beyond our
control it's just not been possible to
complete it at the moment
we are working very closely with your
officers in the county council
to try and resolve the outstanding
issues
and we're also looking to add a new
crossing on brantford road
at the
opposite addison way
and as uh mr pierce has said signals
uh into the junction which require a
slight adjustment of the approved design
and that's one of the things that's held
everything up
but as soon as we get a resolution to
those issues the work will be timetabled
and it will be coordinated with the
county to coincide with the other
improvements coming forward from uh
snowasis
but in the meantime secure storage has
been sorry secure cycle storage has been
provided and installed
um we submitted a travel plan to the
county we submitted details of the
planned shuttle bus service and the ride
home scheme
they're all waiting approval and
hopefully they'll all be in place when
the unit opens
but so that the unit can open we are
seeking
to amend the conditions
for a relatively short time
so that the unit can be accessed by
addison way
and the answer to counselor feels
questions
the county have checked and addison wade
does have the capacity very safely to
take this unit
it's only if we try to put the whole
scheme all nine units through it would
there be a problem not with just one
unit and yes
uh vehicles can turn left out of addison
way so they could turn left out of the
existing junction the approved junction
so there's no real difference there it's
not until we put the signals in which
will be part of the
next permission or application you're
about to look at
that uh
we'll we will be able to prohibit
all junk uh all movements out of the
junction certainly go right
so this is a fantastic employment site
we have other tenants lined up to go
and as soon as this planning permission
is sorted out the fund will release
funds and we can bring forward other
schemes
we're more than happy with all the
suggestions that have been made both in
the officer report
and have been discussed by mr pierce uh
changes to the conditions
and we hope that members can support
this scheme so those 150 jobs don't have
to be delayed they can be delivered
and we will get on and build that
junction as soon as we possibly can and
if we don't in reply to another question
we'll be in bridge conditions
we would also be in breach of the
section 106 agreement both of which you
could effectively come after us for
thank you very much indeed
stay there stay there because there
might be questions from um
the committee
so members of the committee do you have
any questions please if you'd like to
put your hands up
counsellor caston if you would like to
ask your question and hope that we keep
connection thank you
thank you very much um
i'm not sure if you'll um
you'll give me this answer but i just
wondering who the tenant was if you
can't give me that answer could you tell
me what their line of business is and
what sort of business activity will be
going on
in the first one now i can't give you
that answer because it's public
knowledge they're in there now and
you'll see signs going up in the
building next year
it's the fds corporation
they have an existing 50 000 units on
the branson's europa dip switch this is
their second facility in the area
and they're basically they sell in
portland and sell them on the internet
thank you for that and now we have
um councillor stringer please
thank you chair uh
thank you chair uh just wanted to
ask whether it's possible to employ a
strategy in the short term
of temporary signage to request that
drivers don't turn left coming out of
here from port one because we realize it
can happen and it would be really yeah
and
eventually over time it will be
precluded but it's it's how we manage
the interim and i'm sort of asking
is there is there a way you could manage
or the operator could manage to
try and help preclude that circumstance
before nick answers that can i just say
that if he is in agreement to it that
councillor stringer we could bring that
up in the debate for um
an additional recommendation once we've
heard from uh mr davey is that
appropriate for you
well
that's why i'm asking the question now
because it's unfair
mr davey if they'd be prepared to do it
and then we have to ask highways whether
that can be
conditioned and whether that's
appropriate we'll ask the
officers in the debate so mr davey
absolutely there is a condition in the
existing consent that requires signage
to go up to
advise against left turns when the new
junction onto brantford road is created
so we're quite happy to do it
temporarily for addison way as well
and my client does have control of
addison way so he can put signs up all
along that road
and if you want to add an extra
condition on if you decide to grant
permission then we'd be very happy with
that
that's helpful thank you
thank you for your question councillor
stringer very helpful councillor norris
can those take your hands down who have
spoken because of them i've got a bit of
a messy screen at the moment councillor
norris please
thank you madam chair uh well the
question has just been asked that i was
going to ask about signage at this uh
junction uh to try and
traffic htv traffic from turning left
along the b trouble one threes through
through great blake and a man need a
marker so that one's been dealt with but
you did make reference to certain
matters you refer to certain matters
coming forward in conjunction with snow
aces could you just elaborate on that
please
um
i i wish i could but um
as i understand it there are certain
uh improvements to brantford road that
have been agreed with the county highway
authority and with the
your district that this oasis
development will deliver
can i just stop you there um
can i just stop you there and ask sam to
answer that question rather than give
you um the difficulty of answering it
sam could you just comment on it please
yes thank you chair um nick is
correct there are junk there are
improvements from the snowasis on on
branford road
and in the area that we are trying to
make sure that
each
mitigation complements each other and
timing as well
is that fine right that's that's fine i
understand now thank you if you can take
your hand down and then i'll see if
there's any more left because i've got
quite busy screen here
who else or have we all finished asking
questions i've still got one hand up i
don't know who it is
is it me
councillor field
thank you pardon
only just put that up all right
the the point i'd like either nick davey
or sam harvey to answer still
is i i i accept the answers he's made so
far he is the one on i say on page 44 is
the obvious point
christopher fish comments that
it can be confirmed it does not now
appear to be feasible
to complete the construction
of the shared route along the west side
of bramford road that was required in
the original permission
i just want to be clear that that's
being delivered you know that
somewhere in this confusion
we have some certainty that the
footways and cycleways can be delivered
because that implies they can't
i think the best person would be sam
first of all please
yes thank you chair there we are working
with the developer with regard to
section 278 for the works for the
original application there are some
engineering difficulties that we've got
to overcome for where the actual
footwear is going if it is
with
which verge it's um going on
at the moment i don't have the
information in front of me what what the
latest is
but we just want to make sure that we we
will be working together with a
developer to make sure that their cycle
and
footwear pedestrian facilities are put
in place
for the original
application but it may be that it's not
on the verge that was originally
specified
that's very helpful thank you sam
and i've been told that council of war
boys you had your hand up i just can't
see it unfortunately so councillor
warboys you had a question please
thank you chairman uh yes
coming back to christopher fisher's
letter there's uh
a present i i think i'm safe and
assuming that all the construction
traffic and hgv traffic is can you just
ask question actually because we're
entering into debate here and we've been
sort of laboring quite a lot so what is
the question down addison way and alice
away does not have separate pedestrian
or cyclist facilities through to the
site
uh you've mentioned bollard's been put
up no waiting bollards are there any
other measures along addison way to
uh ensure the safety of pedestrians and
cyclists using that route into the site
especially as it's mixed with
construction traffic and
potentially
a question you don't need to embellish
it if you don't mind please i just
needed to make it clear sorry sure it's
quite clear
do you wish me to answer that uh chair
yes please
sorry there are no bollards along edison
way parking's controlled by uh ampr
cameras
and and then patrols
um and there is a scheme to upgrade
addison way and deal with some drainage
issues there which would include putting
in a new
um
cycleway but that will probably not be
they'll be probably delivered in the
same same time frame as a new junction
thank you for that
thank you councillor warboys i hope that
answers your question and with sam
giving us the earlier i hope that's
helped there excellent
right we now move on to the debate so if
we may start the first round if you
would please
um
and if we can start with councillor
caston please thank you
council warboys can you take your hand
down please
sorry one second madam chair no that's
all right it's it's been one of those it
days hasn't it or not
it's um yeah it's going quite slowly but
i'm i think i'm there so um
with this i
it does seem um
that
that
the the first way this was some
this was laid out was the right way it
it doesn't seem like the developers
tried in any way to um do things
any differently it seems like it was its
externalities that have caused this
delay um
that doesn't make any difference on
whether this is acceptable or not whose
fault it is um i do have quite large
concerns with lorries going down the b
treble one three to need a market um
which
it seems very unlikely because it's such
a straightforward
way to um go down the um onto straight
onto the a14
but um
if there was with if there's congestion
at certain times on that roundabout
going on to the a14
um
it could
pose a problem i think um
the amendment that's been talked about
the 12 months instead of 24 months
sounds like
it
would do a lot less harm than 24 months
um
the um signage the council stringer
spoke about i think is a very good idea
you've just got to manage that so it's
the people
coming off that site and it's not at the
end of addison way
it's um
it's it's a difficult one i i think this
is a really important development i
wouldn't want to hold it up or
um cause cause problems on this but i
also think at the same time we do need
to keep hgvs from traveling down that be
treble one three regularly and
the
and the nuisance that that would cause
um addison way if um
the developers said that this this
capacity on addison way it concerned me
when i thought there wasn't capacity on
edison's way but it seems like that
capacity is for
the whole site
when it's built um uh you know um that
that that will be over capacity it will
still remain under capacity with this
one
um
occupation so
i don't know i think those amendments do
make a um a big difference to um this
application if um other members
considered
they would put them on i'd i think that
would improve it
thank you
and thank you for for that uh counselor
castin
um as we move forward that might well be
something to put on so if we can now
come back to
a gold please
thank you very much madam chair um this
proposal obviously has brings huge
economic benefits uh i've been struck by
the
pragmatism of flexibility
that the applicant has shown in
discussions uh on this matter and i
think the
the proposal to reduce the 24 months to
12 months
for me
is a bit of a clincher in terms of
supporting this application and the
recommendation thank you
thank you for that councillor gould
councillor humphreys thank you
i'm sure thank you uh i also agree this
is um huge economic benefits to to the
region especially in the current climate
it's really important to get on with
this
i don't see any massive
issues with the two condition changes to
be honest with you and i agree with
council goal on the 12th month that's
the clincher really um
but it is
like say it is what it is we're caught
where we are because of kovid that's
part of the problem the conditions
aren't unreasonable i think they're fair
and generally safe and i'm minded to uh
to approve as well
thank you
thank you for that and now we will come
to councillor mellon please
thank you chair um
i think i i won't go over what other
councillors have said um i think if the
12-month limit and the temporary signage
can be conditioned i'd be minded to
approve this thank you
thank you councillor mellon
councillor norris
thank you yes um i'm just still very
concerned about this hdb traffic turning
left but if it can be put in as a
condition
then i think it serves to um
placate me somewhat so yes that was my
major concern thank you very much
thank you for that counselor norris
councillor stringer
thank you chair yeah uh say i i think
can i just have a resume where do we
have a proposal and a secondary yet no
no we're going through we don't okay
that's fine just wondering so
i'd say i'm slightly wary about
approving something that's relying on
something else we may or may not approve
at this meeting
that relies on stuff happening there
that that almost seems to be an order
thing uh but but yeah we'll take that as
as sort of we'll look at that when we
get to it
i think if we could condition the no
traffic turns left uh from this
development as it was conditioned
originally uh using a different solution
i think that would that would be most
helpful to to get this to where
a compromised position between the
developer and the communities will be
affected if traffic starts turning left
because it won't just be great blake and
it will be all along that route through
through a conservation area in need of
market as well so i think we owe that to
you to make sure as little as that
traffic turns left coming out of there
as per the original condition thank you
chair
thank you councillor stringer council of
war boys please
i think i think uh i'd just like to
support cancer stringers marx the
the signage about turning left
from madison way and also the
implementation of the 12-month
limit
otherwise i think it's important to
support this
thank you thank you thank you for your
comments councillor boys
i just have a question from sam just um
before we move on um did you not say
there were weight restrictions on
certain roads sam that
would hopefully help us as well
um
making a decision now
yes thank you uh council uh chair yes
there are weight restrictions of htvs
through um going north through needham
market and there's also weight
restrictions going through to spartan
so
these weight restrictions are
enforced by the police um so if there
are anybody if there are any hevs that
are going down those routes that they
shouldn't then obviously they can um the
police will enforce it
it is uh
but putting the additional signage in
can remind them that there is a a rate
restriction to the north and to the
south so that could be implemented as
well
so so as well as what you're saying as
well is as well as just saying no left
turn weight restriction on that sign as
well yeah we could enforce it
we could we could have eyes working
obviously with a developer
that there could be just an information
sign saying weight restrictions to the
north and south you say 14.
yeah yeah
um right well um i've i've listened to
the debate there's been a lot of um i.t
upset today and i do apologize for that
so i'm not going to be long-winded about
this i think there's been some excellent
points made by all members there
um
so if anybody would like to make a
recommendation of they will if they'd
like to put their hand up
i'd be happy to hear what their
recommendation is and any additional
mitigations
anybody going for a proposal or are we
going around again
councillor humphreys and then councillor
stringer
oh thank you ma'am chair sorry uh
councillor string i think i just got it
before you but i'd like to support what
you said really so i'd like to move for
approval on this with the condition and
council stringer come back to me because
i guess you're going to second this that
we do have the 12-month period imposed
and secondly that there is ample signage
to prevent traffic turning left um down
towards needham market and clayton
if that's in agreement counselor
stronger
lastly i think have preempted you but
hopefully you'll agree with that
so that's the proposal at the moment
councillor stringer please yep thank you
chair i i will then second second this
although i i still have that nagging
doubt because
although
we've been told that the cycle and
walking routes will be put in uh
it would be really nice to see it
timetabled and and all of that ready to
go given that we've we've seen other
other delays but
we've had that assurance and we must
take that on trust which we do i will
then be relatively comfortable in second
this application thank you chair
thank you for that i will go around
everybody and ask to speak to the motion
but can i have um either vincent or um
john to make sure that our extra
recommendation is worded correctly can
we have that put forward please to the
satisfaction of council humphreys and
stringer to start with please
thank you
so
i'm sorry i just caught up to the other
bit you just said um so instead so as
far as condition 20 is concerned
where the requested amendment is within
24 months we're changing that to within
12 months
and in terms of
all of the rest of the recommendation
that remains the same but we are
imposing an additional condition to
require temporary signage to avoid left
turn and a reminder of weight
restrictions to be agreed is that
that's how i've got it so far
and i think there was a possibility
people wanted in addition uh to use the
a14 is that feasible would that be
reasonable
john
on those signs
sorry well the signage would say don't
go left that's all right so you have to
go the other way
ham fries are you satisfied with that
edition
yeah mum sure that's that's bang on
thank you yeah councillor stringer
yeah happy with that chair
right so anybody who wants to speak to
the motion if you put your hands up i'll
try and keep up with you councillor
mellon
uh thank you chair um just an additional
point i'm not sure if this would work
but since we have ampr in the location
could that be used in any way to
help the uh help avoid traffic going
left
now it's a bit of a technical question
but i just sort of thought of it
well i don't think we can add that to a
condition but it's a point that we could
make a note of what do you think john
for the for the i think
wouldn't want to go there for various
reasons
it's going to be all sorts of problems
there as well as
how would you use it i i wouldn't
i'm sorry to say
okay
sorry about that councilman anyone else
wishing to speak to the motion please
no in that case then may we go for a
vote please and um
robert if you'd like to take the call
please thank you
thank you
do you want did anybody want that read
out in full again or are we happy with
what we've got
i think we're happy aren't we yeah go
for the go for the roll
okay thank you chair
so if members could please respond with
four against or abstain
so councillor james carsten
four
counselor peter gould
four
counts for cathy guthrie
four
that's the barry hunters four
counts of andrew mellon
four
councilman mike norris
four
councillor andrew stringer
and castle rolling wall boys
four
thank you chair that is unanimously
carried
right yes i agree carried
thank you for that
um can i suggest we take a ten minute
break
um
or five ten minutes um to get everybody
sorted and can the applicant for the
next
um application be sure that they've got
their telephone ready so that we can
deal with the application in that
fashion again i think that was more
helpful thank you
so if we take a 10-minute break thank
you
i'm back everybody
we now move on to the next application
land adjacent to port one business and
logistics park and i'll ask vincent to
once again
um
give us his presentation and i believe
he's now got everything on the it sorted
thank you very much
thank you chair can everyone hear me and
can everyone see the first slide
well i certainly can so let's hope
okay
right just to remind members this item
did come before you
on the 28th of october and was deferred
um so would i
so this is a revised presentation it
will be shorter than the previous one
what i intend to do is
simply
we know where it is because we've just
looked at all that so i just
slide through those
what we're looking at
are the following items and these are
the items that members previously asked
me to go away and report back on and
that is what i'll do so i'll do it topic
by topic
the first question that arose was
what are the indicative building heights
because we had reference to snow asus at
93 meters and um
the
energy from waste building which is also
a tall building i can confirm
that the two
blue colored
buildings on your screen
are suggested as having a ridge height
of
17.5 meters from the ground
that building 18.5 meters from the
ground
that one 14 and a half
and that one 20.5
there was reference in the previous
report to 40 meters
that 40 meters is the
is a reference to datum
the reference that you see on the screen
is absolutely ground to ridge
so apologies for any confusion that my
previous report
caused
if we compare that to existing buildings
you'll notice
absolute
i can say parity in some cases the
proposed buildings are suggested as
being lower but
broadly speaking
similar to the existing building that is
currently under construction
the one that has just been handed over
to fds
so hopefully that provides the
comfort that members were looking for
that we're not talking about super high
buildings
there is a shot of the building that's
currently under construction obviously
it's much more advanced than that image
shows the application site we're looking
at the moment is
is in that position
provided contour so you'll see there is
quite a bit of leveling to be undertaken
so that each of those buildings has a
flat floor which is
understandable
again some more shots of the
existing building and as you
know
from the road the site slopes up towards
the
plantations
so the next question was what is the
impact on the
plantations and on this screen the red
zigzag line
is the area in which the occupiers of
the property in the
white circle
they wanted to shield their views from
quarrying activity that was
at the time underway and also the
commercial activity
to the east hence the plantations
in
this area
in between the building and the red
zigzag were planted to provide
additional
screening
from unsightly views
the current proposal has been discussed
extensively with the occupier of that
that building and the extent of tree
loss has been agreed
with the owner
between kers and de vere
and the occupier
so they are fully aware and have
endorsed
not just the loss of trees but also the
replanting
here's a shot of the
site
so you can see the extent of the
plantation you can just see
what will be snowasus but presently the
disused quarry just to the top of that
image and the existing industrial sheds
within
port one
if i've i overlay the
scheme that you saw in october over the
plantation i'll just do that again so
you can see you'll notice that it's
actually the unit at the top
that eats into
the plantation
since
28th of october
we have discussed moving that building
with the applicants and they have agreed
to
move the building
eight at the top of that image
further to the east to
allow
extra
sections of the plantation to be
retained that isn't something that
members asked for
but we did pursue it in an attempt to
ensure that that planting belt remained
a good depth
so on the screen you'll see on the left
the
current latest position
for plot eight and on the right you'll
see the version that you saw
in october
not only has the building moved to the
east
but it's also been dropped
from the northern boundary so we have
ensured that we've now got
a thicker buffer
to the west and to the north and members
will recall that the public footpath
runs along the north of that left to
right blue barn lane
so again they'll be added
landscape buffer
from the public footpath
what i've done there is simply overlay
one over the other so you can see
the differences
we come to the tree survey in the moment
in terms of the cross section there you
have
at the top an existing cross section
through what would be
the building on plot eight
what you saw in october
the building in that position the
narrowest part of the buffer retained
was
11
meters
since
that meeting with the amendment we've
secured for the meeting today
we have done is
the moving of the building further to
the east has added another 10 meters to
the retained
buffer
we'll also notice if we take a long
section through the site is that the
height of the buildings would be below
the
tops of the trees in any event
so the suggested ridge heights
this whole development should be
screened by
the existing
trees to the north and the
west another series of cross sections
this one shows the relationship between
the building that's just been handed
over plot four
and the proposed building on plot nine
so whilst the ridge heights may be
similar because the land drops
in the location of plot nine the ridge
height will actually be significantly
below the ridge height of the existing
building
that's just to give members comfort that
um
ridge heights are not going to be
intrusive
and again some further
cross sections here through plot six so
the existing trees are 15
meters high they're between
10 12
in meters high places but here they're
15 meters they are still young trees
they've only been in place for
uh i think 12 years
so they will continue to grow and their
height will continue to provide added
screening but at the moment you'll
notice
ridge height is already
on a par with and in places below the
existing tops of trees
again another shot just to demonstrate
that that is true for the whole length
of this
this site
what i've done on this side is in the
royal blue
square is the new location for
plot eight and in the
the mid blue is the amount of
plantation that will be lost and we
absolutely
accept that some of the plantation will
be lost these are
coniferous trees and as i say they that
has been agreed with the occupier of the
property to the west
in terms of the quality of those trees
i'm not sure whether my cursor is
showing or not
but midway between seven and eight
you'll see some green trees on the left
they are category a trees
they are being retained
um at the bottom of that picture
in positions on plots five and six there
will be some category b trees
lost but that would have been true of
the
previous
scheme
and again
highlighting
the extent of tree loss i have another
slide that
provides a summary of that
there is extensive
new planting
throughout the
scheme
if we cut two
that's the whole of that area and the
bottom of that screen you'll notice a
new pond bottom left and that area of
lime green
is all new planting and the new water
feature
there is planting throughout the
development to actually soften the
visual impact within
the scheme but there is
extensive replanting as recompense for
the loss of the plantation to the north
west of the
site what i would say is as well that
the
trees within that lime colored area will
be
deciduous
so we will be losing
conifers
which are not as
wildlife supportive as deciduous trees
and getting a large area of deciduous
woodland
back on the
the site to complement the
mixed deciduous woodland plantation that
isn't being eaten
into
so hopefully what we're doing is
actually
enhancing the ecological value of the
site and enhancing biodiversity at the
same time
obviously when i say we i am referring
to the
the applicant but we have as officers
have
through negotiation ensured that that
adequate replanting
is in and that it's deciduous woodland
i think i do want to refer to blakenham
woodland garden
because the late
lord blakenham planted an extensive
array of trees almost
an arboretum
to the
south west and there may have been some
concern in some quarters that this
scheme would somehow adversely impact
that very special area that is open to
the public
at certain times of the year now if i
can just illustrate
blakenum woodland garden is broadly in
the area with the red arrow
the purple dot
is
the cottage it's rather fine house but
it is known as
the cottage
the application site is to the top right
hand corner of that picture
so what i can confirm is that
the scheme before you will not in any
way adversely affect the
rich mixture of trees within the
woodland garden
now turn to
the proposed access in the highway works
that is the the access arrangement that
you saw earlier but what we are looking
at is
the signals at the junction at the
moment allow this
set of movements now what i've tried to
do is animate them so those
the signals are in the positions
shown so
if you're approaching port one
that's where you will be held at the
moment
obviously in this direction you go
straight through and when you're coming
towards the a14 you can do that movement
but what would
happen is of course
you can then these are all controlled
these movements
here what this scheme will deliver that
the previous outline didn't is the
signalization of the new
access
and this has all kinds of benefits so if
you're traveling north towards port one
you will be able to just
slip into the
site through through here
coming out you would be
held at the signals
traveling north again signals traveling
south signals
now in terms of the movements you can
then do this is the point that certainly
councilor norris councillor field you
are most anxious to
see delivered is coming out
of the new access you would only be able
to turn right
there will be no left turn
that's for all traffic
so that immediately um
sends traffic towards the a14
also included is the provision of a
toucan crossing as part of the
signalization
works again that links in with the
footway cycleway improvements already
secured the three meter wide
connection and again this enhances
the benefits of that
cycle pedestrian
network we've already explored the
arrangement for access
prior to the formation of that junction
and as we've discussed a range of
movements are possible
out of addison way but with the amended
condition that now has the
temporary signage that will
hopefully
better control the
the use of that junction in the interim
which is now only 12 months as we
was previously agreed
we've already examined the
closure of edisonway.1 connection so we
won't go through that one in any more
detail but
what this demonstrates is
that's the movement we are reinforcing
as a result of
the signalization
mentioned we have already secured the
minibus shuttle service this is just an
illustration that will be
tied in
with the new permission the
if it's granted
the consent would be linked to all the
previous deeds of variation and the
original section 106.
as we looked that is the route we
explored that earlier so we're skimming
through that in terms of traffic
i think there was some concern that
perhaps highways england hadn't been
intimately involved with the
what i can confirm is that
highways england and suffolk county
council have worked very closely
together
the suffolk model has been used
additional work was required by both
highways england and suffolk county
council
local highway authority to re-run models
using the suffolk model and highways
england is entirely satisfied
with the
scheme
they're
satisfied with all the inputs to the
model and they're satisfied that the
outputs
result in managed
traffic flow and should not cause
problems i think there's some concerns
there may have been extra
uh congestion
on the junction with the a14 but that
isn't the case
as
reviewed by howie's england and suffolk
county council
let's close that because that's stopping
it moving on
so in terms of
accessing
the a14 from the clayton interchange
you come
slip off the a14 you swing right into
port one
with the signals coming out
you are directed to the a14 but if you
actually wanted to go back down south
down the brantford road that is the move
you make so everything is geared towards
taking traffic
out of branford road traveling
north we also explored with the previous
item the weight restrictions that are in
place in sprawton and
needham market so this is part of an
overall strategy to provide
need a market with relief from hgvs
again highways england to confirm that
capacity at junction 52
exists and this scheme would not
cause problems
highways england support the extensive
range of sustainable travel incorporated
with the the package
as we say the actual minibus shuttle and
the
emergency out of a hours
taxi service is something i've i've
never seen provided before so that
really is quite an innovation
and the extensive cycle network
improvements
again
have been recognized by highways england
as
a real benefit
to this scheme
suffolk county council
very happy with the proposals and as i
say they've been extensively involved in
negotiation and they have pushed the
traffic consultants working for
kersen de ville very hard to do
additional modeling and to incorporate
the suffolk model so actually that work
has been very transparent
and it has used the model that
suffolk and highways england have
developed so the inputs and the outputs
have been
shared
in terms of ecology i think there's some
concern that perhaps our colleagues at
place services
had been lent on to
provide some supportive
comments
but what i would say is they are
very happy to
accept the proposal because built into
the scheme is a an extensive
network of new wetland habitat you'll
notice some of that is off-site
in terms of the creation of the ponds
that is actually in agreement with the
landowner as part of the recompense for
some of the tree loss within the
plantation and as you'll recall
members that dealt with snow assist just
to the north
that also includes an extensive network
of
newt
reserves
and
water features for
great crested nudes this actually picks
up
the same theme in terms of providing a
corridor a wet corridor for
invertebrates
but also as i explained earlier included
is extensive new woodland planting
as a compensation for the loss of trees
within
the site
our view is that
provision of
deciduous woodland
is ecologically better than the
loss of
conifers
in terms of drainage there was some
concern expressed previously about how
will this site be drained and will it
add to
existing flooding problems
extensive work has been done behind the
scenes examples of the
work that's been submitted is on the
screen
so in terms of
what exists at the moment very little in
terms of flooding on the site you'll see
some pockets
at the um junction between
three prongs of branford
road but very little within
in fact hardly that's almost nothing
isn't it within the site
but how the system will work is that
a whole new system of swales and
drainage will be provided
so the pulsing blue is
the drainage will be
flowing to the south and a series of new
swales will connect to a new
infiltration basis shown at the bottom
of that
that screen
so surface water will be held in the
infiltration basin and will gradually
release into existing swales everything
is moving
south
suffolk county council as the surface
water authority are satisfied with that
as a design
principle but it also has the benefit of
improving biodiversity by creating these
new wetland areas
within the
the swales
so we're confident that the
applicant
is able to address
water flood
issues and as reserve matters
come in if members are minded to grant
permission that would all be
worked up in terms of the detail but the
principle
that the strategy is certainly
acceptable
there we have
some more confirmation
the data variation that we've referred
to is required to ensure that where
members to approve this
scheme
all existing commitments that includes
the footwear cycleway
the
sustainable travel
benefits would all be
linked to this scheme
we're also
controlling the signalization through
conditions and sam and the team at
suffolk county will be able to control
that as well through the section 278
so
on that basis
i am continuing to recommend that
permission be granted for this
development subject to that data
variation linking it to existing
consents
on the basis that the concerns that were
raised and the areas that needed
clarification the applicant has
satisfactorily addressed all of those
points
thank you chair
thank you for that vince
just before i asked members for
questions i do have a question for sam
um the
potential for somebody to go in the
correct direction round the roundabout
at the a14 and back down is the signage
there that says that there are weight
restrictions etc already
thank you chair i do believe there is
i'll just check for you
yeah okay thank you very much
um so do we have questions for vincent
on this please and we have first of all
councillor caston please
thank you very much chair i just um
wondered with this some new layout is
there a um security fence
um
and where does that security fence
um
lay in relation to the um the map of
this
the answer
counselor kesten is that
conditions
would control the means of enclosure
but what we would be very careful to do
is ensure that wherever there is a
boundary on the public frontage we're
not looking at
sort of
palisade fencing that it is
attractive
but that is a matter that will be
resolved at reserve matters in the event
that members are minded to
grant
outline
permission thank you
thank you any other questions for um
vincent
if there is unfortunately you can't see
oh councillor humphreys beggie pardon
councillor humphreys then councillor
norris
madam chair thank you it's just it's a
minor thing the the shuttle bus can you
confirm if that would be electric or um
or some other renewable energy source
thank you council humphreys i
can't
although i know that details have been
submitted to the
county council but have not yet been
approved
it would seem eminently sensible that if
that hasn't been agreed that we do
encourage the use of a an electric
vehicle
so i'm quite
happy
that um we take that up
with the the applicant
um
it is a matter that would be resolved
via condition and as that hasn't been
approved yet
there is nothing stopping us suggesting
it
would that be dealt with reserve matters
or no
well actually it's dealt with now
because the outline planning permission
requires the submission of those details
mr davey earlier is said that he had
provided those details but at the moment
we haven't approved them
so
taking up councillor humphreys point it
seems eminently sensible to at least
explore
the ability to use an electric vehicle
that would be perfectly in line with the
council's um philosophy
thank you madam chair
thank you that i was going to say did
you have any further questions
no i'll rose in debate thank you right
thank you very much councillor norris
thank you madam chair uh just a quick
question on page 166 suffolk fire and
rescue in red type say hydrants are
required for this development but i
don't see any mention of them in the
conditions
i suggest that this could perhaps be
added that's all thank you
perfectly um
acceptable suggestion and should have
been picked up by me so thank you for
that counselor norris
and i'm afraid i can't see who else has
got their hands up has anyone else got
their hands up i've got my hand up
if you can hang on for one more moment
um ansler field are there any other
members
yeah um
uh councillor mellon here can't we yeah
i just can't see them they're not coming
up councillor mellon if you would like
to
um yeah i think it's just a question for
vince the clarification um
in the presentation um
mr pierce you you you majored on the
fact that um one of the plots plot eight
had been adjusted
to reduce the amount of tree loss
but it seems to me that most of the
trees are being lost from
plots five and nine and there's no
particular immediate amelioration there
can you just confirm that's the case
certainly
yeah five and nine
existing trees are being lost they are
at the very best category b trees but
the new deciduous woodland in the
southwest corner
is larger than the area of coniferous
plantation being lost
in the northwest corner so that is
actually compensation not just for the
northwest corner loss but also the loss
of trees within the middle of the site
what i didn't
highlight in that scheme is that between
plots five and nine
the majority of a category trees that
are are within that group are being
retained in an open space
but the answer is
overall compensation is for
both areas not just the plantation
and yes trees are being lost within the
middle of the site
thank you no further questions chad
thank you very much um i can't see
anyone else except councillor field if
you'd like to ask your question now
thank you
thank you yes couple a couple of
questions actually um
[Music]
i'm sure i asked last time but i'll ask
again
there was a scheme to run heating pipes
from the incinerator to the greenhouses
and that seems to be coming back to life
at the moment i just wanted to be sure
that it's not being precluded by
anything in this development
so that's a simple one
the second one really around highways
england
the the presenter assured us that
highways england
and the county highways are now fully
satisfied with the traffic analysis
i just wanted to be sure that
they did question the analysis that was
applied to the clayton junction and
that's a point where i witness
uh regular congestion at the moment with
current traffic volumes not extended
traffic volumes
just be unsure where that's recorded
because i didn't see it in the papers
anywhere and an assurance that it's true
because some of the congestion seems to
be due to current um
road marking configurations
um
i wonder whether there's an estimate for
the increased hgv and other traffic from
this development because again i didn't
see that it would be somewhat normal i
would imagined
and
accepting that uh martial blake and him
is now evidently happy with the trees
um and i'll leave that with their uh the
issue about uh natural england's
concerns about this site of special
scientific interests the backed colonies
and the impact on those that doesn't
seem to progress forward although we
have a great list of um
everywhere they went to whatever a great
list of uh what was done but no no
analysis of
the results of that i wonder if we could
have some clarity on those points please
thank you councillor field in terms of
recycled heat there shouldn't be
anything in this scheme that includes
that and
in theory if there is that available
additional energy
there's probably no reason why
potentially this scheme couldn't benefit
from it
as well
um it was perfectly in line with
the council's philosophy in terms of
energy
conservation
we also know that snow oasis is is
looking to generate most of its
its own
power
as well
so i see nothing in this that will
preclude
the benefits that you've set out in
terms of the
junction i will leave that to
sam harvey to deal with but in terms of
bats
the place services are happy with the
solutions that have been come up
with it not only in terms of bats but
also
newts and other
fauna
so
that's in terms of the answer these
place services
are happy provided and there is a
proviso provided that we do secure
the additional woodland planting
and we do secure the new wetland
habitats and of course we will do that
by condition i don't know sam whether
you want to just pick up on council
fields detailed points about
the junction on the a14 and
how the modelling looked into that
yes
thank you mr pierce
the highways england responded to the
new well the additional information and
the additional
uh modeling that the developer put
forward they they
um
responded on the 15th of may where they
have no objection
to the proposal and in their comments at
the bottom they're saying that the
junction 52
they were queried
the measurements given
they note that these have now been taken
into consideration and is unlikely to
affect the outputs of the model
result the presented model appears to
show that the junction is predicted to
operate within capacity with proposed
development trips
and also they're happy with the
sustainable travel
put forward for the minibus
so that's where highways england
position is actually on on the website
so does that mean they have specifically
dealt with that issue raised by
yes to the field yes i believe so could
could i just ask a supplementary
question to that yes please do john
which which is basically that the
junction currently jams back to over
past the river not all the way to the
energy from waste plant but across the
river
so how can it be okay with increased
flow
i'm not talking about a simulation which
clearly is the best way of estimating
often but can be an error
but actual practical
current experience
thank you councillor uh the the
information that we have been given with
the uh the model
obviously shows um that the junction
will
operate within capacity i'm afraid i
haven't recently been going um anywhere
near that junction during the peak hour
so i'm able unable to give comment on
the queues but the model is showing that
the junction will operate within
parameters allowed by highways england
and ourselves
so you can ask a supplementary myself of
sam so does that mean
if it's below capacity that doesn't does
it or doesn't it mean that at times you
will be in a queue of some sort
yes yes during the during the peak hour
there will be queues
um
um
within but it's within parameters that
are allowable
uh with a um
with
how is england and ourselves
thank you
thank you for that explanation
right
um
so we've all had our questions
there
so we don't have a representative from
the parish council objector or supporter
so let's hope that nick davey can get
back in
um with his telephone and we'll hear
from the applicant if we can please oh
yes
i have been here all the time can you
hear me yes that's excellent thank you
good
thank you very much um
yeah so i'd just like to emphasize that
this looks a big sight but
30 percent of the developable area sort
of the site already has the mission
it's only 18 which is new development
the rest of it well over half
is actually existing and proposed
replacement tree planting and bio
diversity enhancement measure which
mr pierce has described
and that percentage will go up as we've
now reduced the size of the unison plot
height
and as a result of that the tree belt to
the west and the north has doubled in
size
if i could just also pick up on one
slide that mr pierce put up
um
he showed the loss of the tree planting
between unit 9 and brownford road that
is actually not being lost said it's
being retained in full
and i can confirm that all security
fences will be on the plot side so
there'll be nothing on the uh
on any road frontage
um now we have
surveyed very very extensively for bats
badgers great crested news from reptiles
and your ecology called consultants and
they've taken the advice of natural
england and their representations on
board and they were satisfied even
before the latest changes
that any adverse impact upon
protective species and habitats could be
appropriately mitigated
we've incorporated a full suite of
sustainable construction
and on-site generation uh energy
generation measures into the scheme
which meet fully council's requirements
uh mr pearce has discussed building
heights i want going to them further but
just to say majority of the land to the
west is being purchased from the
blakeland estate and lady blakenham and
she employed her own landscape
consultants to make sure that the
buildings wouldn't be seen
and would be below the trees and she
will retain all that land in her control
and it's part of the agreement with her
that the buildings can't be seen
um we've deliberately worked with uh
statutory consultees to address every
concern as you've heard
i won't go into a flood risk again
um on traffic flows the suffolk models i
understand it
doesn't include the junction it's based
on traffic flows provided by the county
and it includes all the traffic
generators from the snow oasis
development
and
both the county and highways england are
okay with it
the only additional things we've been
asked to do are to add traffic lights
onto the junction and to add an
additional crossing on bradford road
near the addison way junction
which we're doing
um a couple of other masses uh yes we
can look at the electricity or electric
uh bus to the shuttle bus
those are still to be agreed
and plot nine unit nine we are
purchasing from the uh greenhouse
developer and in that agreement is that
he can run heating pipes through plot
nine if he wants to
so in summary the society is attracting
it's a fantastic site brilliant position
and it's attracting a lot of interest
if we do get the go ahead for this
enlarged scheme my client's confident
that not only will he build out what
he's got consent for
but there'll be great demand for the
rest of the scheme and will be
delivering hundreds of jobs in the next
two to five years
um happy to answer any other questions
thank you for that
um do members have any questions for mr
davey please
mr councillor caston please
um this is a um question out of interest
more um why on these type of
developments don't we
put um solar panels over the entirety of
the roofs
um
from your point of view i'd just be
quite interested i think this does
affect this um development but
maybe not a key
point
we just stick to the planning
application before us so if we can turn
that round and say why are you not
putting
okay
why are you not putting solar panels
across the entirety of the roof
what your policy requires for 10 of
energy will be generated from uh on each
building but also these are warehouses
they're unheated
they they don't actually use a lot of
energy it's only the office um part of
it which are a very small part of the
building which means uh
heating and
uh
need power the rest of it is just to
operate the the racking systems and the
lighting
so they're largely unheated spaces
okay that's i think we've got the
question and the answer there um council
casting well done for asking that
um does anyone else have any questions
for the applicant
council of field and you're the only
other one thank you
nice to be unique
uh councillor casten i think has stolen
my question but but i was going to point
out that uh it's not a matter of heating
you know the solar farms being presented
on unheated fields it's for generating
your electricity
for profit or to supply the things you
do but
i guess that's not a question i was just
going to say what is your question
counselor here
i won't repeat
councillor casting's question okay so
it's been covered then it's been covered
thank you very much indeed right um so
you now have your slot counselor field
to tell us um your thoughts on this
application thank you
thank you
okay i've said some of it before today
um
and basically the first thing i wanted
to make is the point that you know in
general one's in favor of
development in areas that are
appropriate and that match the
current economy the issues of heart
covid the
impending hard brexit
and the increased use of digital
techniques in general so
this meets many of those criteria
certainly it's close to the a14 but i
would point
members to the
comments of both parish councils
they seem quite extensive and
considered
you may want to wonder whether the
changes that the landowner has
introduced or persuaded the developer to
introduce to tree lines actually
addresses the issues that little black
and
barish had
uh so so there are the positive things
in in a way
the concerns still really are the
uh
traffic
uh exact access uh to through um needham
market and through greg blankley itself
seems to be being controlled providing
that new junction goes in and we've
discussed that earlier today
the concerns with the
traffic
flowing to the a14 i'm afraid
i find lessons satisfying
um
we maybe have got some simulations that
say all is okay but if you actually
visit
the the site now bearing in mind current
traffic flows are substantially less
than they will be when there's 600
people employed and the large number of
hgvs on the drawings flowing in and out
of this track site regularly
so that's an issue of not perhaps that
we mustn't ever build anything here it's
an issue of there are traffic concerns
that could be and should be addressed so
that's what concerns me at that point
you've covered sustainable traffic
measures uh transport measures foot and
cycle ways and i think one's reasonably
satisfied with that now
um
the height of rural buildings has been
analyzed it seemed uh
that the the slide that was presented
was very new it wasn't in the papers
and iron other councillors had little
time to assess it but one would point
out that some of these buildings are sit
on a 30 meter
high ridge at least 30 meters high ridge
and therefore are very high in the
landscape
that most
residents will view them from the
roadside if you like not from the side
that
the blakeland establishment will view
them so there is still a concern there
snow isis i think has just been
rebranded as valley ridge and that's
been done for a purpose it sits on the
ridge of these hills
and there are still issues to my mind
with the this side of special scientific
interest the uh
some thousands of bats that live in a
tunnel down there some of them extremely
rare
uh species so i still have significant
reservations about this
but one has to admit that it is in
probably in
a good place um
in a similar way to spawn gateway 14 etc
are all in quite good places for
development
so that's the end of my
presentation but i wouldn't recommend
that you look at the
statements from the parishes
counsellors obviously live considerably
closer to the development than i do
thank you
thank you councillor field do members
have any questions for councillor field
it would appear not
so we now move on to the debate
and so we'll go round uh the first time
round and see how we get on there
councillor custom please
thank you very much madam chair
the um
so um
these heights
i'm a lot more comfortable with now
when we previously looked at previously
looked at this i was quite concerned
about the size of these buildings they
are don't get me wrong they are large
buildings but um we we
i think with the other development
around there they won't stand out
um
the um
the planting
i
i'm really glad that the developers
listened to our debate
on the last
in the last meeting and come back
um having moved the building
to um
to
stop that thinning of the um
of the boundary trees which was a big
concern of mine in the first
um in the first viewing of this
um
the
the i think the
the out of hours taxi is a great idea
it's one of the things that gets in the
way of people um cycling in they think
that something might change they might
not be able to get home so that that
gives them the ability to um solve that
issue if that comes up that that'll make
a big difference
um
the um
yeah the um
i don't see any flood issues with this
the um
the thing for me is um one of my first
jobs
was on this um site here in great
blakenham i'm emptying containers i'd
cycled in i before i drove i was
emptying containers and loading them up
by hand after that i got a job at the
the um
recycling place litter picking so it
this this has been a really important
area for me to um get a job
as a as a young teenager
you know needing the money um so
in my yeah
in my heart it's quite important to me
that we deliver this and get these jobs
i think at the moment
the
the junction issues at junction 52 i do
agree with john field i think that there
is congestion there i'm surprised that
hasn't been put up um that hasn't been
picked up on there but it is in front of
me in black and white that that is not
over capacity and that's what i have to
follow i need i've got nothing else to
go by but i do agree with john field
that it does seem to me like there are
issues with them traffic um tailing back
at times but um at the moment i think
yeah i i think this is
um
doable now i think the changes there
make me happier about it it doesn't
carve into the landscape quite so much
with that mitigation the um
planting trees 1.5 meters apart down the
far end seems like they're going to grow
very tall and very thin
but i'm i'm sure this has been done for
a reason but looking at this i'm
supportive of this application
but i'll listen to debate thank you
thank you very much councillor casten
now we'll come to councillor gould
please
thank you very much madam chair um like
councillor castin i'm
supportive of this
application for the for the economic
benefits it will provide
um and i'm i'm very pleased to see
uh
the
uh the changes that have been made
to accommodate our concerns or many of
our concerns uh when this previously
came before us
i think once again the the
flexibility the pragmatism of the
of the applicant is appreciated uh like
others i'd
you know the the
uh
the situations projected in in modeling
never seems to come in match what things
are like in reality i sometimes wonder
whether the the modeling is predicated
on urban settings rather than our our
rural settings but um
we can only go by uh what what the
highways authority advice uh so i am
pleased to support this
proposal thank you
thank you councillor gould councillor
humphreys
mom chair thank you and um yeah i'd
first like to say this was a really good
presentation because it's allowed me to
better understand the changes that have
been brought about but also to visualize
what it's going to look like in the end
and also that traffic plan so it's
really important and and thank you for
that presentation um the signalization
and traffic flow is welcomed um it
certainly satisfies much of our concerns
from the previous meeting and and i
think the flow the flow diagram for the
hcv is perfect in terms of the build up
of traffic and everything else the
signalization will slow that down and
actually aid the process in my opinion
as does the signalization at the
junction as you come off the a14 to join
that road it will slow the traffic so so
i don't think it's a major issue i think
it's a massive improvement actually and
makes it a lot safer as does the
crossing and i thank the developer
really for being proactive in that and
to to actually doing more than actually
has been requested or required so good
news
um the building uh number eight the
movement of that in my opinion is
fantastic news it widens that belt of
greenery between the quarry area and the
plantation
and that's good for everybody so it's so
fine the heights of all the buildings uh
having seen it now and visualized it all
below or level with the tree line
currently that's a good thing because
eventually they'll merge below it and
that's excellent the only thing i might
say is that if you wanted to improve
that and this is probably reserved
matters
then a slight blending camouflage scheme
such as milton keynes that would go a
long way
but that's i think that's reserved
matters just my opinion
overall this is a really important
development and it's a really important
thing that we get this through because
because of employment opportunities not
just immediately in a local environment
or a local area but also nationally this
is an ideal position as well a good link
to the a14 the arterial route basically
to the rest of the uk and via the a12
and a14 and also very close to the port
felix stone so it's the right place and
it's absolutely the right time it's
critical we we build areas for
employment that's what we're going to
get with this
the only thing i would be adding i think
if i was to go for it um in the
conditions is probably the shuttle bus
being of a um
renewable or alternative energy source i
think that's quite important and it
makes the right statement we are in that
environment where we're trying to
prevent damage to it and also um with
the
new changes to the law in 2030 will have
been a more diesel vehicle sold new
or uh or fossil fuel vehicles um when we
talk about the bats there's been a lot
said about the bats but um if i go back
to page 103
it talks about the bats from ecology no
objections subjects occurring
biodiversity mitigation which i think is
in there and enhancements which i also
think is in there and it talks about the
um survey they did a recent survey found
no evidence of bat usage and no sign of
bats were found in any of the features
explored um
says to me that's not really an issue in
this particular site within the the red
lines of the boundary we talked about
the tunnel and the quarry that's not
this site so we need to stay away from
that one i think however maybe a
condition could go in that on the
lighting which i think is point 12 in
the in the recommendation and that
should be wildlife sensitive in those
areas where it's required i don't think
sufficient detail in the condition and
that's what i would seek to add
but all in all i think this is a really
good development an important
development and and i'll be supportive
of it thank you
thank you councillor humphreys
councillor mellon
uh yeah thank you madam chair um i'll
just be brief
um i do have some reservations about
this development um i'm concerned that
it will
contribute to traffic on the a14 and you
know the simulations and the modeling
are all very well but we know the
reality
um and a large number of vehicle
movements will
increase the amount of traffic
uh some people would argue that
warehousing and distribution as a sector
is an inherently unsustainable
sector uh you know you could argue that
point and i have some sympathy with that
um
it it's
you the the fact of moving large
quantities of of goods around the
country
is part of an inherently unsustainable
economy
but that's a bigger argument than we're
detailing just now
um there are things in this application
i welcome the clarification on the
heights i think
that has sort of um
has been very useful
um i welcome the changes to the
plantings
although i i do regret the tree
the trees lost i mean even conifers
have
a wildlife value
um but um overall
i am very minded to
to approve this and particularly welcome
councillor humphreys um
conversion to an eco warrior thank you
thank you for that councillor norris
thank you madam chair uh
i agree with the comment earlier very
helpful presentation this morning
um i don't wish to repeat everything
that's already been said uh the only
comment i would make would be to make
sure that this condition about the
hydrants was included
otherwise i'm
inclined to support this application
thank you
thank you councillor norris councillor
stringer
thank you chair yeah just like to sort
of say what difference a month makes uh
we
the the added clarity and the added
value we've put into this application i
think by the deferral uh has been marked
uh and i think it would for me change my
uh the way i would possibly vote on it
i think
it's good that the applicant has amended
to to save some more trees and actually
the tree thing is quite important not
just for tree huggers like myself but
but
also from that mitigation from a
wildlife point of view the the more
screening you get between the buildings
and the other areas that surround it
obviously the more wildlife that can
exist and use those corridors
uh
gladly like to see a non-fossil fuel
minibus
for the shuttle bus that seems to be a
very logical step
and a small way of mitigating uh
emissions uh from the thousands of
lorries that will be using it probably
using diesel engines but of course that
will probably change in the next decade
anyway uh the or the important thing for
me also about the it was mentioned about
wild solar panels on all the roofs well
of course some of the roofs face out of
the sun so you you're unlikely to
completely cover a roof
having said that uh our policy demands a
certain level but it's up to the
applicant if if they are going to
forecast the future as being electric
transport they may choose to cover more
of that route with solar panels uh
therefore it makes it more marketable
when when we we go into that modal shift
uh so for me i think
uh locationally it's in the right place
it's been planned for to be here
the only little bell going off in my
head uh is obviously that issue of
stacking and and
cues that roundabout
and you can do all the modeling you like
but the reality of your own eyes in your
own experience sometimes tells you
otherwise i get one of the junctions is
traffic lit control but one of them
isn't and that's the one that's often
stacking up back into a village so
that's my only miners about it i can't
see that
that not having data for anecdotal
evidence is a way i could support
refusal it just isn't so i i will i will
be i think
voting to approve this but i would say
but i do have reservations about how
some of this modelling has been done
because my own eyes tell me there is an
issue that needs to be sorted out thank
you chair
thank you councillor stringer council of
war boys
thank you chairman
uh
yes i think i welcome the the changes to
the um
to the the plan uh particular sort of
sensitive and sophisticated changes
uh by moving the
the building back to double the width of
the green corridor
uh it is important i think to note that
it's the connectivity of these
planted
areas that that is is really important
and i really welcome the
um
inclusion of a water corridor which i
think is is quite an interesting
idea
i do have concerns about the traffic
projections especially as
there is going to be further development
involving the clayton junction but
suffolk highways have modeled it and
say that it's within
an acceptable level
um so i don't mind that to support it is
very important to
to create
job opportunities
um so it's
it's good
thank you very much for that council of
war boys um well i'm not going to repeat
what everybody said
the improvement um excellent the
presentation excellent
uh councillor humphreys refers to
blending of milton keynes he knows well
of my photographs that i took when i
went there um and it's interesting to
note i think on site they already are
putting panels in and i hope they don't
do what they did at woolpit which was
green at the bottom and blue at the top
but there we are
i think um the developer has listened to
many of the issues and i'd like to thank
all the members of our committee
for putting all those points forward in
the earlier meeting
so um
i now look to see if anybody would like
to make a proposal and there were a few
additional recommendations
for example the electric car and
lighting for wildlife and i wonder if
there's anybody who's prepared to make a
proposal sorry there was also hydrants
oh yes hydrants i've got them on my
third one yeah
could i
just come in there chair if i may cancel
oh yes john yes please do right
um
just to just clarify the discussion um
fire hydrants to be conditioned we
certainly would add that um from from
the uh planning officer point of view if
not by member um
ultimately uh yes there was a discussion
about electric uh
shuttle bus just in respect of the
lighting uh in your papers lighting is
to be agreed um so
it
is a matter of it's already effectively
there we would obviously
in that agreement look at the
biodiversity side of any agreement that
should be made
i'm sure councillor humphreys would be
satisfied with that
so is anybody um going to make a
proposal or do we want to go around for
a further discussion
councillor humphreys
joe yes i'd like to make a proposal
please nut proposal is for approval with
the additional condition uh that the
shuttle bus be of a um
renewable energy source and i get your
point about the lighting
so therefore that's just a note really
that we would want to see some wildlife
sensitive lighting in the areas where
that's applicable but not as a condition
thank you do i have a second of that
then please
hang on i saw two peter counter gould
please
yes
i'd be very pleased to uh second the
proposal thank you
thank you very much indeed does anyone
wish to speak to the um
motion councillor stringer
yeah just uh just a uh a comment on the
uh the shuttle bus uh a non
a a renewable energy source could be
biodiesel
so uh
i think we might need to just you know
clarify the wording on that thank you
john do you want to make any comment on
that whether we need to alter it should
we just say electric unless otherwise
agreed
modern sheriff if amazed proposal
electric would be fine but also hydrogen
is now a new technology and that is also
non-fossil fuel
mice to make this easier i think perhaps
we should say
why do we just we'd be better off doing
the reverse which is to say this shall
be electric unless otherwise agreed in
writing with the local planning
authority and that just allows us to uh
to look at other options
yeah
councillor humphreys would you be happy
with that
one happy thank you madam chair
councillor gould would you be happy with
that
it's very happy thank you
and speaking to the motion i see that oh
counselor custom did you put your hand
up and then take it down again i think
have we resolved your
your point
counselor thank you madam chair i was
going to suggest zero carbon um but i
think um we came to a conclusion on that
one okay so
i decided i wouldn't um i put my hand
down thank you
thank you councillor casten right um
does anyone else wish to speak to the
motion
no
in that case we've got a proposer and
the seconders so robert can you take a
roll call vote please
thank you chair
so if members could please respond
with for against or abstain
counselor james carsten
four
captain mike norris
four
castle andrew stringer
four
and cast the revlon war boys
four
thank you chair i've just confirm mr
prey that is unanimously carried yes
this is the legal advisor i agree
unanimously carried thank you
thank you very much indeed and thank you
to everyone um because we've had such a
delay this morning um my view would be
to um carry on and keep going um
it's only 20 past 12 and we've had a lot
of public waiting
um so
if that's all agreeable with you unless
i see any hands up of dissent
um unless anybody wants a five minute
quick break um can we carry on and i
will ask
cheers
vincent's vincent yes i think it would
be useful from my point of view if i
could have five minutes just to make
sure that because of all the technical
activities at least the next
presentation is working smoothly so for
five minutes then if we if we have just
a very quick five minutes and then we'll
move on if we would please thank you
very much
to good afternoon everyone and i'm sorry
there's been so much of a delay um to
enable us to present the next
application
but with the it problems we've had
um it's really caused a delay so i do
apologize to you all
can i now ask the um officer to do a
roll call to make um sure that all the
members of the committee
thank you chair
so councillor james carsten present
that's the peter gould president how's
cathy guthrie yeah present counselor
barry humphries
come back to counselor barry humphreys
uh councillor andrew mellen
president councilman mike norris
come back to council and norris as well
what's this
okay counselor ball boys
president
okay so i'll just ask again chair so
councillor barry humphries
[Music]
yeah
thank you very much uh councillor norris
i think we need to wait a few minutes
and
contact them to remind them
we wait until our past chair and i will
then ask again
thank you
okay
so i will just
um
check so council humphreys are you
present
or counselor norris
president
okay thank you chair um i would just ask
claire would you mind please just giving
casler humphreys a ring just to check
that there are no issues
yes rob i will do
so
very unusual because he's usually pretty
prompt
if you're waiting for me i'm here i did
so i was here
we didn't oh we didn't hear you yeah
yeah yeah sorry
you were muted
[Laughter]
i did say it's not like you right okay
so um i think um robert are you happy
that we are all here now
yes chair thank you
thank you for that so in that case then
vincent um as i say with apologies for
those that have had to wait vincent
would you now like to present the case
thank you thank you
here members we're looking at an outline
planning application for up to
18 dwellings as chair said postmail lane
freshing field
i just want to check
has the screen now changed to threshing
field is a primary village
yes thank you
this of course was the um
previous
iteration of the
core strategy and threshing field was
identified as a primary village because
it had a shop in the number of other
facilities however
in the joint local plan
threshing field has been downgraded in
terms of the
settlement
hierarchy and now sits at a rung below
what was previously
primary village and is now
core village
so within hinterland villages we are
looking at
small-scale development
within settlement boundaries
largely for a local
need
of course as i explained in the updated
papers we do have the benefit now of the
november 2020 version of the joint local
plan the pre-submission
document at the time of writing the
report that hadn't been published so
where relevant i will refer to the
november
version of the joint local plan
just to be absolutely clear freshing
field neighborhood development plan is
made and adopted
it does form part of the
development plan
and as such
is a significant material consideration
indeed it is part of your development
plan in terms of the village
can i just stop you for a minute yes of
course i do beg your pardon i've got
somebody i don't know who nw is
and saying that
she can't
hear anything or something but i think
that's her
um that's madam chair that's nicole
wright i believe saying that
so so
she's a guest isn't she yeah nicole is
the agent for this application chair
i suspect she also wants to speak at
well yes indeed representation time
yeah exactly um
i'm not sure how to come
robert carl michael here i believe um
just to confirm that the live stream
is going out so it's not in terms of
that so if it's
possible if i could ask nicole to just
check her settings because if we if
nicole is in the meeting should be able
to hear the audio from mr pierce
and from all of us if you could just
confirm nicole if you can hear us now
or not
can you put something in the chat yes
sorry that i just realized that would
have been
i haven't logged in yes
now there we are
so vince would you like to start that
that section again i do apologize
yeah
just this section on the um just the
slide three here
is that correct slide three yes yes
what i was saying uh nicole and everyone
is that the
threatening field does benefit from a
made and adopted
neighborhood plan
it is part of the development plan and
is therefore
a significant material planning
consideration
in terms of the village referendum as
you can see
86.6 of those voting
uh supported adoption
of the neighborhood plan so there was
widespread support for its
adoption
in the report i have set out
extensive discussion around each of the
relevant policies within
the neighborhood plan and i will go on
to elaborate as we go through the
presentation
just to make absolutely clear there is
the reference on the council's website
to the fact that it is now an adopted
neighborhood development plan
and is part of our own development plan
so it is an up-to-date
document
in fact it is probably one of the most
up-to-date documents we currently have
as part of our suite of
development plan documents
in terms of the
parish profile what i want to make clear
is i'm happy to do this is that the
figures quoted in the
report
are figures for the parish in terms of
population and dwelling numbers and i'm
perfectly
happy to accept the
figure
provided by safe on its website and in
separate correspondence with me that the
number of dwellings within the central
part of the village ie the built up part
of freshing field
is
350.
and this is important because
clearly when you're considering what
percentage 18 new dwellings is of the
overall total
clearly it's a higher number
if you take 350 then if you were to take
the number for the entire parish which
is 444 and i do correct that on the
updated papers
the application site
shown here in red
the applicant controls land
edged blue
within the blue land there is no built
development proposed
but what is
being offered
is for the area in blue
to be used in perpetuity as a wildlife
area thereby ensuring that
built development
is never promoted
on that site
so here we have those those two
boundaries shown on top of an aerial
photograph and as you can see the area
in red
is now largely
a grassed
field it isn't farmed
and the little finger of red that pokes
into the site is where the existing
pumping station is located
so in terms of
adjoining sites everything that appears
in yellow there is a recently
constructed
dwelling
so that is what is now post mill lane
and the properties within it
we have the
gp
practice the medical center
we have the rear of properties these are
older properties in new street
we have the access road that is in place
and is constructed to that degree
that serve
the properties
in post mill lane
what i've shown here is there is
what appears to be consideration
for perhaps a future phase but clearly
that is only dependent on planning
permission
being granted
terms of
key local facilities this diagram
highlights those i draw your attention
in particular to the
light blue the almost
in the center of the screen which is the
village shop
which is on new street
the members familiar with wrestlingfield
will know that much or even most of new
street doesn't have the benefit of a
footway you are required to walk in the
carriageway
and so
anyone
within the development in the red area
if it were approved to get to the shop
would be walking in the
in the road
in terms of other key features they're
all set out on that
that screen
we'll come back to the
highway safety implications of no
footwear in new street as we go through
the presentation
in terms of constraints
the site is shown in the cross-hatched
move in the top left hand corner
we have conservation area
the end the western extent of the
conservation era just i'll make that
flash a bit so that we can see
to the east and we have two listed
buildings unpleasant lady mead cottage
those flesh just you can see those
previously
um
the refused
development for 24 units
in the field behind
lady mead cottage was a key area
of debate not only at committee but also
as part of the inquiry
or the appeal rather and we'll go
through that in more detail
in a moment
so there we see an older shot of lady
mead
scottish very hard to see it because
it's mostly behind them
trees on the frontage but that is the
the
dwelling we have had
objections from fretting field parish
council and i have explored
those in detail
not only in the report but also in the
table papers and the table papers
represent freshing field parish
council's latest
updated comments
the updated papers fully sets out an
analysis of local objections received
since
my initial report was produced and again
we've broken those down into categories
i also need to explain that safe
supporters against freshing field
expansion have provided an updated
objection
to the proposal
following re-consultation
and
they draw out errors
in
my report
so one of those is the reference to the
number of dwellings in fretting field
which i corrected in the earlier slide
there is also
dispute about the number of
properties that have permission
i will deal with that in a following
slide but i am absolutely happy to
accept
the
figures
offered by safe as representing the most
up-to-date position
that will result in some change to my
updated papers but i will explain that
in greater detail as we go through
the point that safer
wishing to make clear in their view that
the application is not compliant with
the
neighborhood development plan and there
are points throughout
my report and the updated papers where i
accept that is the case
there is continued very strong objection
to the proposal on
drainage grounds and members who will
recall
debates in thressing field in recent
years with the combination of
major developments the issue is that
there is a problem in the lowest part of
the village particularly around low
street and crapfeld road
in terms of
during periods of high rainfall
the fowl
sewage system
overflows the manholes in those low
points of the street pop open
and diluted sewage
is um
egresses onto the
not just the street but also into the
back and potentially into
parts of
of gardens
the issue here has been that anglia
water previously described this as a
closed system for foul sewage but over
the
generations unauthorized connections
have been made to that foul sewer to put
surface water into the foul water system
and so when there's heavy rainfall
the fowl sewage system cannot cope with
the amount of water in it and the
pressure causes the manholes to pop
at the low point in the village and
that's what causes the
diluted raw sewage to empty into the
street
and we'll go into a lot more detail of
the issue as we go through the
presentation and the reasons why
we believe the current proposal will not
exacerbate
the existing problem
safe point to infrastructure deficits
within the village to cope with
additional population
there's a debate around
windfall sites which i'll pick up
it builds on the point made earlier
about
my comments in the
updated papers
they feel that the
references i've made to the previous
appeal decision i have put too much
emphasis on
some of the points the
inspector made and i think safe would
want to
suggest that the previous appeal is not
as important a material consideration as
i have suggested in the report
particularly in view of the fact that
since the appeal
we have seen the adoption of the
neighborhood plan
and we can deal with that as we go
through the
presentation
still continued very strong objection to
traffic
issues arising from a further 18
dwellings particularly the issue of
pedestrian safety
particularly in terms of the
problems perceived as being caused at
jubilee corner and i'll highlight that
as we go through the presentation we've
discussed the sewage egress
there's also
some concern that in reporting console t
comments i haven't necessarily
highlighted
areas where consultees aren't entirely
happy we can we can go through those in
detail as we go through
and there's a feeling that the
cumulative impact not just of this
proposal but others in the pipeline i
have three other planning applications
in freshing field currently on the books
that have yet to be
determined so we've got the reserve
matters at red barn farm
we've got an outline application at john
shepard road and i've got an outline
application on stream
road and i believe we've also got an
application that i'm not dealing with in
land off school
school road
so safe's conclusion is that the
application is not ready to go to
committee
and the committee is not ready to
consider it for the reasons that
are set out above
so in terms of policy
and this is one of the first points that
safe have picked up on
in the november 2020 version
of the joint local plan
the number of homes required the
identified need in thressing field
is set out as
56.
now there is debate around how many of
those already have the benefit of
planning permission and we'll pick that
up as we go through
the fretting field neighborhood
development plan
which deals with the whole area shown in
green but essentially we're looking at
the impact on the
built up part of the village of
wrestlingfield which i've shown here in
flashing
green
the neighborhood plan identifies
two sites for additional housing and
that actually allocates them
so
that is the northern edge of the
village boundary as appears in the
neighborhood plan that coincides with
the local plan boundary
that's the application site so i'll make
it flash clearly it is outside but
adjacent to the village boundary
the two sites between them
are expected to generate 18
houses on the land of school road that
has outline planning permission
and the red farm barn site
28 outline
planning permission for 28. i currently
have the reserved matters for
red van burner 28 and there are 28 units
within that reserve matters submission
one of my colleagues has the land of
school road reserve matters application
currently there are 12
dwellings proposed on that
site
in terms of the figures that i've quoted
i have
suggested that there are 51 dwellings in
thressing field benefiting from
planning permission
the neighborhood plan identifies a
requirement of around
60 dwellings
which generated a shortfall
of
nine dwellings
what i did then is
if the reserve matters for land of
school road
if it ends up as being 12 units rather
than 18 units that would bring the
gap between
those with permission and those
identified in the neighborhood plan as
15.
now
quite rightly what safe have
pointed out is that the permission is
for 18. and until and unless
12 are approved
i should be using the figure of 18 not
the figure of
12.
furthermore since
that
and this is the point i'm happy to
accept
a further three dwellings have been
given permission in
thressing field
the combined impact of all of that is
that there are now 54 dwellings if we
count the 18 on the
school road site
there are 54 dwellings with the benefit
of planning permission which makes the
deficit
six
in terms of
what is cited in the neighborhood plan
the application before you is for 18.
so clearly that is three times as many
units
as
would appear to be necessary to meet the
target of 60 in the
neighborhood plan
i put it in for reference
purposes if we end up with only 12 on
the school road site rather than the 18
then we have a deficit of 12
which is still
less than
the 18 being proposed
in terms of layout
this is the revised
layout
in the center you have a an area of open
space with the attenuation pond and you
have a cluster of dwellings arranged
around that central
space
we have now a bungalow in the top right
hand corner
and we have a mix of largely two and
three bedroom
dwellings within that proposal
everything that's shown in the pale gray
to the south and the west is is existing
modern development
if we compare the
scheme that was refused
and
dismissed at appeal there we have the
scheme with 24 dwellings
the site is larger than
the site now before members
because of the the finger of land in the
bottom right hand corner that has now
been excluded so immediately that takes
out six dwellings
that's how we get to the 18.
if i superimpose the current layout
over the refused layout
what we see is that the land outside of
that blue is now
the suggested area
of wildlife area the proposed wildlife
area
terms of heritage
there is the
significant difference between the
previously refused scheme and the scheme
now before you
the a field immediately which is a
self-contained field in that field
immediately behind lady mead is no
longer
included within the application site and
is not proposed for built development
that does have a significant impact on
the setting
of lady mead and we're going to
we'll explore that in a moment
the benefit is of course that the
setting of lady mead remains open
and uncluttered by built development
that change is significant
so significant that our own highway
our own heritage sorry forgive me
heritage
officer
has now formally responded to say
as a result of this the proposed scheme
for 18 dwellings on the reduced site
will have no harm
on the setting of lady mead cottage so
we're not in the area of substantial
harm we're not in the area of less than
substantial harm which is where we were
at with the
24 dwelling scheme we are now at no harm
so in terms of
would it be reasonable to add
adverse impact on lady mead cottage as a
reason for refusal i suggest it would
not and that would not be supported by
our own
heritage team
members who've read the
appeal statement will recognize that the
impact on lady mead cottage was a
significant factor not necessarily the
only factor but it was a significant
factor
in the mind of the inspector
for
dismissing
the appeal
in terms of heritage
as i mentioned earlier the conservation
area that we got yeah shown purple here
is to the east
what impact would the development on the
crosshatched
move area have on the character of the
conservation era
and our opinion is it would have no
harm
at all it certainly wouldn't have an
adverse impact
the
conservation air appraisal for freshing
field is of the old type as are all of
our conservation area appraisals
and it was designed as a guide to those
undertaking development management and
doesn't follow the current requirements
for conservationary appraisals but it
does briefly touch on
what is the character of thressing field
conservation area and it's it's a
strange reference i'll just read part of
it because it says very few parts of
fretting field have buildings close to
the road so the village remains fairly
spread out without any urban feel to it
driving through around any corner
you expect to find the elusive center of
the village but you remain disappointed
as along any route the countryside
soon reappears
the small size of the village means the
countryside is in fact never far away
from you
so in terms of trying to distill what is
the character of the
conservation era it would appear that
the authors of the appraisal at the time
had some difficulty in trying to
identify
a sort of consistent and uniform
character that you could say
was fretting field
in terms of
this proposal here we have the
application site in yellow
this is all
development
so there is already a between the
application site and the edge of the
conservation area significant
built you'd say urban even though it's
in a rural area development
the distance between the closest corners
is 146 meters but
what i would want to draw your attention
to is the amount of new development that
has occurred within that maroon colored
area
so that where we've got the vertical
line is all
recent development
our view is that there is no adverse
impact on the character of the
conservation area for the reasons set
out and the fact that the field behind
lady mead cottage is now
suggested as a wildlife area and will
not be built upon
is
in a sense a further buffer between this
development and the conservation area
because it's an enclosed field the trees
will will dominate so there is still a
sense of that separation between the two
in terms of access
the access already exists post mill lane
is an
adopted
section of highway built to current
highway standards
you access it from
new street
in terms of the footways at the moment
shown in yellow are the sections of
existing
footwear so that that phase of
development
was provided with good
footway
connections
they do connect with the short sections
of footwear that do exist in new street
and they are associated with more modern
developments in terms of
that connection this is a view into
post mill lane and on the right hand
side you see new streets so the existing
footwear
comes around the corner stops just as it
gets into new street but that enables
you then to cross to the other side of
the road where you can see
footway
on the opposite side of the
the road and that's important when we
look at connectivity to other parts of
the village
what it doesn't do is provide you with a
pedestrian friendly connection to the
shop
and jubilee corner for the reason that i
stated earlier is that
once you get past that car in the
distance footwears don't exist on new
street
so again here's a shot inside the site
and you can just see the application
site between the
central
two cottages in the building on the
right behind
the wall if we go right around the
corner there you'll see the sections of
purpose built footway on the left is the
application site you can see the pumping
station in the middle of the picture
to the left is the existing
hedgerows and trees that will be
retained and in the far distance
uh boundary fence
so
in terms of
footwear connections to the existing
post postman lane what i've shown here
in blue
is connectivity to the existing
footpaths of the as part of this current
proposal
in terms of
how you then access other parts of the
village without having to use new street
what i've shown here is the
the fact that there is a section of
footwear on the south side of new street
does allow you to
access um
prairie road
prairie way that
enables you to get to the school through
the school's playing field
so
you aren't necessarily required to go
along new
street
work your way through the jubilee corner
junction and then back up straight road
and into school
road there is a
shortcut but obviously that doesn't help
you get to other parts of the village
such as the shop and the other features
that i showed on this slide earlier
so i'm not suggesting for one minute
that this is the answer to pedestrian
safety problems in new street
but i will go on to say is that the
inspector in the previous appeal did not
accept
that the
fact that people walk in the street
in new street is an overriding safety
issue
so
the inspector previously didn't support
the highway reason for refusal and that
in part accounts for
the county council's latest
reaction to this proposal
previously they opposed development
for this application
they are no longer objecting
so there's the application site there's
another shot of it looking so as you
look towards the top of that
picture you're looking eastwards towards
jubilee corner at the top
the school in green the application site
in red
the section of
new street that is shown in the blue
dotted line is the section without
footpaths
so it is a sizeable length of
hugh street
in terms of the accident record
if we look at the last five year
accident record on
crash map
you will see that within the village
itself of the heart of the village there
has been one
slight accident recorded and what i want
to be sure
i make clear to members is that of
course this is
crash map data
it relies on that incident being
reported and as we've said in the past
not every accident near miss
slight bump is reported so in a way it
under reports incidents but what it does
suggest is that
within the actual centre of the village
slight one slight
incident has occurred
and you can see the
just to the right on lex field road
there has been a more serious
incident
but that instant record is not
sufficient to warrant
intervention from the highway authority
in terms of
mitigation new mitigation measures and
improvements
so there's a closer view of that same
image focusing on so where the it says
sophie's dog school not advertising any
particular provider
that is jubilee
corner
nothing on new street between the
application site
and jubilee corner
included in the
package of measures being promoted by
the applicant is a 20 mile an hour zone
between jubilee corner and a point on
new street just to the east of post mill
lane
so between those points
purpose being to at least slow traffic
down
there we have an exploded view of
jubilee corner so you've got new street
running to the the north west trek road
which provides access to the primary
school
laxton road and then harleston road that
goes further on to harston hill the
point to make here is that there is
almost no footwear
connectivity around that junction save
for a short section between new street
and streadbrook road but it's not really
wide enough for two people to walk along
that section of footway side by side and
of course that is a way to go to the
school and use the way for people in
stradbroke road to go around to the shop
and other facilities
you do get farm traffic going through
the village you do get heavier lorries
usually related to
chicken processing
activity
also trembling through that section of
pressing field through jubilee corner
the proposed wildlife area here we've
got a suggested illustrative
layout so this is the area in blue
behind
lady mead cottage so it'll be a mixture
of the existing woodland and scrub a
proposed wetland area
some new native tree and hedge planting
the idea would be at the moment not to
necessarily make it available for
day-to-day public use but to set it
aside to allow
habitat creation and wildlife to really
establish itself there
the issue then would be is it opened at
certain times of the year to allow the
public access and that would be matters
that would be resolved through a
management plan were members to be
minded to
approve the application
but so this is an illustrative example
of what could be achieved on that
site
in terms of this slide the
white dotted line shows the area of
potential wildlife
benefit and then we have the application
site wrapping around the pumping station
to the right hand side of that picture
all inside of the existing hedgerows
they would be retained
landscape the existing trees and
hedgerow both to the north and the east
would be
retained
there you see that hedgerow pumping
station in the center of the
plan that is cut grass perhaps not very
regularly
but it isn't farmland and doesn't appear
to read as part of the countryside and
the inspector in the previous
appeal accepted that land now reads part
of post mill lane as perhaps open space
for that
estate although technically it is not
public open space
it is private land
owned by the
applicant
just quickly superimpose the proposed
layout over that and there you can see
that the hedgerows are kept intact
additional
landscaping would be provided and this
is purely illustrative to provide a
greener frontage to
the north side of
mill road
some suggestions here of how that open
space beside the pond
could be landscaped because it's quite
clear that the pumping station itself is
not entirely well that's
to say not entirely it isn't an
attractive feature in the street scene
but it does have the benefit of being
behind a brick wall
you will find a lot of pumping stations
are behind close boarded
fences so it does have some
enhancement
but new planting would certainly help
but that in itself isn't justification
for 18 houses i would perfectly accept
that
in terms of residential amenity the
illustrative layout
has regard to the
amenity of neighbouring properties and
in the report and on this side i've set
out why that
should ensure that we don't have adverse
impacts on
amenity
drainage and i've got some quite a bit
of detail in here because we have
received additional
uh commentary following the publication
of the report and the
updated papers so
what i want to make clear and i'm
grateful to
dr castron and pam castro for making
this absolutely clear to me i have
double checked in my
commentary i say that the pumping
station is controlled by telemetry and
the release rates can be
controlled that is not presently the
case
and it's important that i make that
clear because i would not want to
mislead
the committee so
fell water from the proposed development
will go through this pumping station
but that contr that won't be controlled
in terms of when it is released to join
the existing foul sewage system
in thressing field
now the applicants have advised me that
they did explore
having the 18 dwellings off of its own
private
treatment work
that was resisted by the drainage
authorities because
they prefer not to have
private sewage systems in locations
where there is adequate capacity in an
existing adopted foul
sewage system
that is anglian waters position here
that there is capacity in thressing
field to accept
additional foul
water
so
the applicant has not been required to
provide extra capacity within the
pumping station and has not been
required to modify the pumps to enable
controlled release
now you'll see from the reports that
everyone is incredulous that
anglia water
say that there is capacity in the
existing system
but the issue here is that
in normal conditions there is capacity
for foul sewage in the valve sewage
system
the issue is that a number of or a
significant number of unauthorized
connections over decades
that mean that in periods of high
rainfall
excess surface water is ending up into
the foul sewage system
and it's important that i
make that clear because
the proposed 18 dwellings will not be
adding any additional surface water
to the foul
system in thressing field
it will be adding some additional foul
water but it won't be adding surface
water
so here we have a a document from
dr castro in which he highlights
existing issues
at the low point in the village
in some of those you'll see toilet paper
and other bits and pieces
actually coming up through the the
manhole and you can see some significant
uh examples of
flooding so not only does
the foul system
pop the manholes but also the back which
sits behind that postum rail white
poster rail fence that over tops
as well
dr castro is quite right this is a
matter that's gone on for
years and years and years there doesn't
appear to be a remedy
at hand
so
occupiers of properties on that low
point in the village are being
effectively told that is the system
that's what happens
not much can be done about it
in terms of the surface water
system for the proposed 18 dwellings
what would happen is surface water would
go into a an attenuation pond
which is shown in the
dark blue
that would then be released into the
existing ditch system
through a series of controls which would
control the outflow
to greenfield rates
so despite the fact that there would be
18 dwellings
on that
side if it were approved
the amount of water ending up in that
pitch where the light blue
dot is moving
would be no more than if this site had
not been developed and remained a
green field
we'll explore how that's achieved in in
a moment
but the point then to
accentuate after we've seen how that
piece of the system works
is here we have the attenuation pond
there would be
two entry points into it
each would have a pipe in a in a head
wall and that's taking surface water
from the development
so the
attenuation pond
would be expected to have
0.2 of a meter
20 centimeters permanently
water
within it
there will be capacity then to take an
additional
half a meter
giving you
0.7 of a meter depth at
particularly rainy periods but then on
top of that there is
what's known as
freeboard an additional 0.3 before it
gets to
being able to over top
that attenuation pond that is considered
a an acceptable suds solution for
dealing with
surface water
now how it is controlled two options are
proposed there's
it's a manufacturer's title but the ac
0q brake flow so what you can see there
is
what that actually does is throttle down
the amount of water that can pass
through the system so it goes from a
bigger opening down to that small
opening
that's then fed through a series of
storage
areas
so it can be cleaned as well so release
is controlled to greenfield rates and
that's how it's achieved by throttling
the amount of water that can
can leave the system an alternative very
similar idea is
and this is a control flow system is
here you can see there are three inlets
but only one outlet
and that's that unit actually provides
storage capacity so again what that's
doing is throttling the amount of water
that can be released into the ditch
system
so in terms of what happens is at the
moment the light blue is the existing
ditch system and that would take clean
water surface water
from this development once it had been
through the attenuation pond and the
brake
system
but shown in dark blue is the existing
stream on the right it's the back
through the village
but the direction the flow is as
suggested in the the arrows
so that surface excess surface water
would be going into a stream and away
from the village
it wouldn't be entering the surface
water system in the village at a point
above the low points
so on that basis the surface water
outflow cannot be adding to the issues
within the village and particularly the
the back
so there is no prospect of this surface
water adding to the problems
in the heart of the
village
and i'll just accentuate that point in
that
slide
in terms of foul water here we see the
existing
foul water from the existing development
going to the pumping station
shown in the move is the extra
foul sewage
in a new pipe system with under the
highway also going to the pumping
station
and as i corrected earlier
that then is released into
the existing foul sewage
its release is not controlled
if we see all that working together
you'll see that the existing and
proposed
all ending up into the pump station
and there is the pumping station
angry water were
insistent
that any development is kept at least 15
meters away from the edge of the
pumping station
and that is what that layout achieves
there is no part of that illustrative
layout within 15 meters of the
pumping station
on that basis
our recommendation is that
subject to completion of 106 to secure
the items set out in the report that
planning permission
is granted
for this development for the reasons set
out in the report thank you chair
thank you very much vince that was very
comprehensive
um now do members have questions for
further clarity
on the presentation we've received today
so
i see councillor stringer please
thank you chair he said in your
presentation
that the housing numbers in thressing
field
could maybe and was in you use the word
deficit
but looking at the freshing field
neighborhood plan
it has quite a percentage of windfall
some some of that has already come
forward
and certainly
you know rural villages like this
have have a number of class q
applications so uh i just wonder if you
could clarify
whether using the word deficit is is is
the right word to use here
thank you uh councillor stringer
i'm more than happy to say if it's not
the right word
the what i was trying to
highlight is
there is a present
a small number of units between
those with planning permission
and the 60 identified in the
neighborhood plan
now whether that's a deficit you might
say well that's
between now and the end of the plan
period
that's
a small amount
doesn't necessarily represent a deficit
because as you say that could be taken
up with windfall sites within the
village envelope certainly that's what
policy
for s1 fres1
suggests is that that
gap
can be made up
over the plan period
with windfall sites inside the
settlement boundary
so i would accept that point
thank you and of course the just to
clarify that that the neighborhood plan
also has a review
built into it as well so it it wouldn't
necessarily be over the planned period
it would be when it hits the next review
correct thank you for that uh counselor
melon please
uh thank you chair um
mr fish you you mentioned the fact um
that uh
there are there have been a number of
unauthorized
connections for surface water to enter
the foul system
now i understand that anglian water
actually collects charges from
householders for the surface water
so
how how can that be described as
unauthorized
it i'm not i'm not
a spokesperson for anglian water however
what i would say is
those connections have been
made
who knows
50 60 years ago up to modern times it
would appear that anglia water are now
accepting that that is the situation and
they are now just charging people for
the fact that those unauthorized
connections have been made i also
know that and this is something that if
uh safe or the parish council or dr
castro are speaking that is something
that is at the heart of a dispute
between
the village
and anglian water
certainly there are a number of
complaints
uh
formally being considered i i remember
previously from discussion that there is
indignation within the village that
anglian water are making this charge
when
one there is this flooding problem that
seemingly can't be resolved and two if
they are unauthorized and illegal
connections why are people then being
asked to pay for
for that that is something i can't solve
it is a conundrum and it's probably
something that um speakers will
will talk about
but what i'm saying here is that this
development will not add
surface water flow to the present foul
system
in thressing field
and a third
sorry sorry councilor mellon carry on
yes sorry
thank you chair um
in your presentation you mentioned a 20
mile an hour
zone for the heart of the village
can you just sort of tell me what the
status of that is is it a proposal is it
linked to this application or other
applications
yeah thank you for that
question councillor
it is
an offer that has been made by the
applicant
suffolk county councillors local highway
authority feel there is some merit in it
what the developer is being asked to do
is to provide the funding to implement
that
and that would be a matter for suffolk
county council to pursue under the
relevant traffic regulation orders
but
as officers we are not saying that the
18 unit scheme is dependent upon
those works going in
and whether or not
sam harvey i'm just looking to see if
sam's still about i i think she should
be would wish to comment either now or
during the discussion
but we're not saying they're a necessary
prerequisite
but the developer will provide the
funding so that suffolk county council
can pursue it
if it's if it's achievable
thank you and chair marlowe to another
question
yes yes if it's for clarity yes please
yeah um you didn't specifically mention
this in your presentation but it's there
in the papers
um you seem to place quite a lot of
store on the fact that um the the
application site is not isolated
as uh mentioned in um in the mppf
um and i'm struggling to understand that
the
the sort of um how that point um
impacts on the application okay yeah
now happy to explain that one councilor
mellon
paragraph 79 of the mppf is what
replaced paragraph 55 so this was
dwellings out in the middle of nowhere
how on earth do you get approval for
exceptional dwellings in the countryside
this is not an isolated
location it is on the edge of thressing
field adjacent to the
settlement boundary
now i think what
fretting field are saying in their own
policy is not necessarily that they are
following the strict
requirement of paragraph 79 but they are
using the exceptional factors that are
set out
in paragraph
79 so for example
were this site to be proposed for an
essential agricultural workers cottage
they might consider
it favorably
but i don't think anyone is accepting
that this is an isolated
site in terms of its physical geography
it is not remote from any other
dwelling
that is that's the issue around
isolation because members will recall
that a lot of
recent appeal decisions
inspectors are are acknowledging that
development adjacent to a settlement
boundary is not isolated
and that if that settlement
is sustainable
in terms of the mppf
development on the edge adjacent to an
existing settlement boundary can in
certain
circumstances be considered
sustainable
even though it's outside of the
settlement boundary and can therefore be
supported
under the more general uh
direction of
promoting sustainable development in the
mppf and the presumption in favor of
sustainable development of course what
you have here in thressing field is a
situation where there is an adopted
neighborhood plan
that identifies closely where
development go should go and this isn't
one of the sites that's been identified
for development
so we have that perennial issue of it's
not in the neighborhood
plan
it is on the edge of a settlement our
own local plan is out of date
to some extent we have to have regard to
the mppf
but in terms of the hierarchy
as the neighborhood plan is now part of
our development plan
it is
a significant material
consideration
so we have that perennial dilemma
on this occasion well uh perhaps i'm
straying yeah i think
i'll stop rather long here yeah and i'll
stop
but that's my instant answer to your
question counselor
thank you
thank you councilman before i move on
can i just ask
ian to pray please
quite clearly the flooding that
currently occurs in in pressing field is
a real problem
um but it
and people will bring it up
but how much of that needs to be in the
debate for
this application site if it is proven
that
it won't add to it i i just wanted your
legal advice on that because i don't
want to stop people having their views
on everything
well i think yes i mean
vincent mr pierce has it has explained
his advice very clearly and i
it goes without saying that
a
discussion of the planning merits of a
proposal has to be
confined to those matters that are
relevant and to take into account the
technical advice that's been given but i
don't know if
that answers the the question
well i don't want to stop debate but i
was just wondering if people
uh veer off it seems that this this
dreadful problem that they've got has
been ongoing for years
um and um
it's just been explained possibly that
this site may not
uh attribute to it however
i think i think your point madam chair
is a good one that if
members are considering the um
the planning merits and the planning
balance the um
the benefits and disadvantages of this
proposal and the fact that the the fact
that there is a problem in thressing
field that's been explained very very in
detail
if if this if it is the case in some
this
this application granted will not add
surface water
to the flow as vince has explained that
that of course needs indeed needs to be
noted by all the decision makers or
decision makers
okay thank you thank you for that as i
said i want to
stop debate um before i come to
councillor stringer who's already spoken
and the ward member um councillor gould
has asked to have a question clarified
thank you councillor gould
thank you very much i'm chair in fact
i've got
two questions uh one relates to the
point just been discussed that
whilst um this development
uh it's asserted that this development
won't add to the surface water into the
system uh presumably the the sewage that
will be added
to to the system
will that pass through the low point
where we have uh whether
where the problem is uh is seen that's
question one my second question
uh
is to understand the
reasons that the highways authority have
uh for uh not objecting to this proposal
when they objected to the previous
proposal thank you
thank you councillor gold
thank you uh councillor gould what i
would say is that yes it will add to the
total amount of
sewage going through
thressing field in the existing
foul
drainage
system
what i would also say is that it is
right for a planning authority to have
regard to
flood risk there is a whole section
within within the nppf that makes it
clear that flood risk is a material
planning
consideration
what i'm suggesting
here is that because of the surface
water being taken away from freshing
field it will not add to the problems
that exist
through
excess surface water being put into the
foul system
but
i'm not trying to deny that the 18 units
will not be adding their own foul sewage
to the existing foul sewage
system in respect of why the
highway authority sorry madam check that
can i just i i just want to make sure
i'm i'm understanding
yeah the answer to my question
so
whilst surface water isn't adding to the
problem
uh the sewage will add to the problem
will add to the volume of material
passing through those pipes
and
therefore
will make the problem worse
it is adding to the volume
in the existing fell
system
okay thank you
in terms of
the
issues around highway authority position
it's probably best that i'd defer to
sam harvey
to
give it straight from the highway
authority's perspective
yes thank you mr pierce um
as as you said in your presentation in
the recent appeal for the three sites
together
uh the inspector determined the proposal
would not be harmful in in any effect
for the highway or petition safety
within the village
he acknowledged the concerns that we
raised for the pedestrian safety for the
for the three sites together
but he felt that it wasn't um
demonstrated and it was of little
evidence it wasn't substantial
so this is why on this application as
it's a standalone for 18 dwellings
because there is a route to the school
that is off the main route and is a safe
route we determined that this
application was acceptable with with
regards to highways
could
again madam chair i can may just clarify
uh the answer so
um
it's really are we banned by the view of
an inspector
on a
a separate application are we banned by
his or her view on that application when
considering this application
i'm happy to give a planning perspective
you are not bound by that but it clearly
is a an important
material
consideration because if if a previous
inspector felt that 24 additional units
wouldn't pose a
public highway safety
issue
you would expect
18 dwellings to
generate even less of a problem and so
the issue then is
is it a reasonable reason for a refusal
how do we evidence that at an appeal we
couldn't previously because the accident
record doesn't tell
the story that we we would need it to
present
so on that basis
i would say we're not bound by it but it
is an important consideration and it
would
be a factor
that might
suggest that we have acting unreasonably
and i know
it annoys members if i do the gun to the
head type argument what i what happens
at appeal
but i can't avoid
saying if we cannot come up with
new evidence that we weren't able to
produce last time
i'm not sure it will be supported at
appeal and could it leave us open to
a claim for costs but
you are able to have a different view
that is your entitlement as members of
the committee
yeah madam sheriff if i may sorry i've
not put my hand over them if i may join
this moment just to endorse what vincent
said is exactly what i would have said
that planning decisions by planning
inspectors aren't like
high court or court of appeal legal
judgments they're not binding precedents
but
i have in over the course of my career
once or twice i've been at a council
where we've kind of been a bit bold and
said we really think that inspector um
six months ago made the wrong decision
when we've gone to a new appeal but it's
you you need to give very careful
consideration to that kind of approach
and i i think i'm doing this case i do
endorse what vincent mr pierce has said
sorry my my problem all sorts of things
going on here um
i've got
one two three
three people have already spoken
um and i'm quite happy to come back to
them all in in the order i see them in
so councillor stringer if you would like
to
speak sure may i just add something just
something that's happening in the
meantime
just so that you're aware sorry
counselor stringer
mr paytman g and myself have been doing
some exchanges
via skype they may have been on the
screen i'm more than happy to deal with
those if if that matter yes please
yeah i'll just deal with them anyway
okay
john and i have been discussing the
whole drainage situation and the fact
that
previously the applicant did suggest a
private treatment
facility
my view is that
if
members felt that the
system issue was such that we could
condition
the drainage strategy to incorporate
exploration with anglian water of a
private treatment
system i think we could also
suggest that
as part of the drainage strategy
we explore with anglian water the idea
of increasing capacity at the pumping
station and providing some sort of flow
discharge
control
system
and i just didn't want members to be
considering these issues
and not having the benefit of that
exchange which clearly was on on the
screen as you know behind the scenes we
often try and see how we can help
members
come to a a good decision so both of
those might be technically possible if
you felt
that the foul issue was an overriding
issue so apologies for interrupting
apologies councillor stringer but i
thought it fair to
put that out there now
so that that could
factor in because clearly john and i
were having that debate and it was
it was there i have nothing
nothing to hide that i want to make that
transparent thank you chair
yeah that seems a a big
um
amendment shall we say um so if i come
back to councillor stringer who very
kindly waited um so i'll come to the and
i will come back to the ward member very
shortly i do apologize but we've got
chancellor stringer next year thank you
and yeah important to get that sewage
part of it also correct because that's a
current water use you're talking about 6
000 liters a day here so that's six
tonnes of
sewage per day coming out of these
houses don't forget this is a question
oh absolutely absolutely yes my question
is
on page 266 you very kindly before we
got into the waterworks uh we're
describing the status of the
neighborhood plan
within the development plan
and on page 206
it mentions our local plan and course
strategy as remaining the authority's
adopted development plan
it was my understanding that the
neighborhood plan was also part of the
development plan could i have that
clarified please
certainly council stringer
the neighborhood plan is part of our
development plan
and the starting point for decision
takers such as yourselves on the
planning committee is
the adopted development plan and the
reason i quoted that was because
even if parts of your adopted
development plan are out of date
clearly the neighborhood plan part isn't
out of date
but those parts that are out of date are
still
required to be your starting point for
decision taking
yeah so so to clarify then that wording
is incorrect
it should have had the word part of in
there
correct
okay thank you thank you for that
councillor stringer um and if you can
put your hand down because i've got
hands all over the place here councillor
gould you wanted to have a second go i
see please
oh sorry that that was an old hand sir
there was another question i believe yes
thank you madam chair um yes this is a
new hand um
can i ask um
the officer mr pierce to
explain his statement on page 293 of the
bundle it's paragraph 4.2.32
where it says that the um
adopted wrestling field neighbour
development plan is not as robust as it
might otherwise be
can i have some clarity on the reasons
for that
it's it's a minor point in respect of
relying on windfall sites to make up
the number
within the neighborhood plan
government advice very much is you
should try and identify
sites rather than put them down to
windfall but i think as we've
established we are talking about a small
number of properties it isn't a
a significant number within the overall
60 because we have 54
already with the benefit of planning
permission at least the 54 so it is
it's a minor point
and can i just for further clarity just
ask
the inspector who examined the freshing
field neighborhood development plan
um made no comment about the
i think described as the deficit in fact
they said that um
no further sites needed to be allocated
is that correct that is correct
thank you
thank you for that counselor melon and
now councillor hattingham you've been
very patient your turn to ask a question
um thank you i'm sorry to get back to
the unpleasant sewage situation but as
the flower water is going to be i'm
adding to that i just wanted to ask
winston and i'm not being trying to be
clever here i don't know the answer to
the question um how many times you talk
about excessive rainfall how many times
in the last two years has their back
actually flooded or has there been
flooding in low road
i'm sure that um safe if they're
speaking would want to answer that but
based on the information provided by
dr castro
it would appear it's about
four times
a year and it definitely i suppose not
unsurprisingly it coincides with the
sort of autumn
winter where you would expect rainfall
to be at its highest and perhaps most
extreme
but i do stand to be corrected by
anyone from the village who who says
otherwise but based on the information i
had on the screen it would appear about
four times a year
thank you for that councillor hattingham
right
so
we now can move
on
to the parish council and thank you
diana warn you've been waiting very
patiently um you now have three minutes
if you would like to
put your video on and we can see you or
if you're on a phone just your voice
will be fine thank you
okay i'm can you hear me very clearly
thank you and can you see me
yes indeed okay
very good um
thank you for giving us the opportunity
to speak um i've listened very carefully
to what has been said and i'm afraid i'm
going to reiterate some of it
um we objected to the original
application and as did the principal
planning officer but he changed his mind
and we haven't
we have as you say a robust ndp in place
which is um aligned with your draft
local plan
with
considerable buy-in from the parish um
i refer you to the objections from
elizabeth monero who ably counters i
feel the veracity of the balance of
judgments made about that plan by the
principal planning officer
in the ndp we have
figures for house numbers which again
echo what faith says 54 approved
in terms of the village
i really think what needs to be taken
into consideration is that the reality
of living in the village is different to
how you carry out a desktop planning um
exercise
18 more houses will need 30
or 40 more cars and there is a reliance
on cars in thressing field because there
is no public transport
the developer himself um
has quoted from a route assessment that
concluded that the proposed development
would increase traffic
and that there were restrictive measures
to mitigate against this on what is
probably the most dangerous road in the
village
we talked about that this morning
residents are fearful of walking along
the new street as it is there are have
been no serious accidents to date but
there's one waiting to happen
we also are disappointed with suffolk
highways changing their mind as well
the drainage um will be spoken about by
many others and we've already touched on
that
but the notion of this attenuation pond
is not as convincing as it might seem
it may capture surface water but at 20
centimeters in clay soil it has the
potential to be empty after year
unsightly smelly and far from being a
local wildlife amenity
we're not persuaded by the section 106
proposals
the idea of the wildlife area sold to
the parish council for
a pound would be appealing
but given that this land is
not of much use anyway to the developer
he could be very philanthropic and give
it to us anyway and we would love a
project to work on that with the
community
do not underestimate the strength of
feeling in the parish and particularly
in the village people are very crossed
at his coming to the lpa again they feel
strongly that the local voice supported
through the ndp is not recognized as it
should be
the character and nature of small rural
communities should be retained and not
urbanized because of muddled thinking
within national and local government
we strongly oppose this development and
we urge you as members of the committee
to oppose it too
thank you very much for listening
thank you for that now members do you
have any questions for diana please
counselor stringer
i'll ask i'll ask the question i
normally ask of a made neighborhood plan
if this application were to be approved
do you have any idea what the impact is
likely to be on your neighborhood plan
thank you chair
on our neighborhood plan
i'm sorry i don't know yes yes yes
the impact on the neighborhood plan yes
i'm sorry i'm not quite sure what you're
getting at
okay uh if if this if this
application were to go ahead
yeah what do you um there's a group
there's a load of volunteers that work
on a neighborhood plan and you have a
document in place do you think the
approval of this have with any impact at
all on that neighborhood plan well
certainly it would cause us to have to
be had to review where we've got to at
the moment and for us to be extremely
uh
unsettled by the fact that it hasn't
been taken into consideration as the
foundation for decision making
okay that's helpful thank you
thank you councillor stringer any other
questions for diana warren
no i can't see any there thank you very
much indeed for your contribution thank
you
thank you
so um
we have an objector elizabeth manero if
you would like to speak please you have
three minutes
thank you chair
there are three key sustainability
factors that relate to this application
the conservation area
the sewage problem and road safety
assessment of impact on the conservation
area covering most of our historic
village including new street is a legal
requirement historic england have given
traffic congestion as just one example
of harm to a conservation area but this
has not been considered
within its common ground this
application is in breach of mdp for s1
it also breaches fresh 3.1 on
infrastructure because of the defective
sewer polluting the road and back with
raw sewage which is getting more
frequent and road safeties these
deficiencies are where the home lies
sir the sewer has overflowed 12 times in
the last two years eight times since the
appeal including in july and august
off what the regulator are in detailed
discussion with anglin water about its
breach
suffolk county council on anglian water
cannot even agree whether the sewer is
foul only or combined
if it is combined angling waters
capacity calculations are wrong
because it would accommodate surface
water as well
if those currently charged are those
causing the capacity problem as was
suggested then they would already have
been identified because they get bills
but they cannot it's not impossible to
identify where the problem has come from
or indeed exactly what it is no solution
has been found
turning to road safety since the appeal
uh safe's
january 2020 survey of 104 residents
found that 84
often or always felt unsafe because of
traffic when walking in the village
citing poor visibility narrow roads and
speed
a 20 mile an hour limit will neither
stretch the road space nor improve the
visibility
three quotes from respondents show this
day-to-day reality i think you're
nearing your time
which is not accepted
i always feel unsafe in new street
because cars lorries buses farm vehicles
can come along any moment and if caught
out in one of the many spots where there
is no pavement it is very scary i have
to crisscross the road to get to the
safety of grass strips or driveways to
avoid being stuck at one of these
several blind spots
so in summary there was no public
transport the school and medical center
are at capacity with roads unable to
bear even current traffic safely so as
the already flood and pollute with no
solution in sight no analysis of the
impact of the conservation area this is
a textbook case of unsustainability the
wrong houses in the wrong place thank
you
thank you anyone any questions for
elizabeth monero
no thank you very much for your time if
you'd like to turn your video off now
thank you
we now have the agent nicole wright and
you too have three minutes to address
the committee thank you
thank you chair i am nicole wright a
chartered town planner representing the
applicant with me this afternoon is matt
here
of plandersil engineering to answer any
technical drainage questions
the importance of addressing the need
for new homes in the district is greater
than ever in these challenging times as
hopefully we are approaching the end of
the pandemic
planning law requires that applications
for planning permission
i'm sorry we seem to have lost you
i'm not sure if you can hear us but
nicole right i'm afraid we can't hear
you policy f-r-e-s-1 excuse me can you
just stop nicole we lost you there for a
little while
oh
what was the last you heard
yeah but where did we lose nicole
okay i shall start from where i think
you may have left it was only it was
only a few a few sentences
okay
planning law requires that applications
for planning permission be in accord be
determined in accordance with the
development plan unless material
considerations indicate otherwise
the officers report has discussed the
various relevant policies of the
development plan in detail policy fres1
of the neighborhood plan
provides for around 60 new dwellings
we have heard that this means that there
is a potential housing gap of 12 homes
to fill in the village based on the
neighborhood plan target
there is no other application currently
submitted
to address this gap
based on the current situation if all 18
dwellings proposed by this outline
application were permitted that would
take the total
to 66 dwellings approved in the village
this would remain around 60.
this application site is ideally
situated to address the shortfall the
case officer has shown that the site is
ideally situated with an easy reach of
services and amenities in the village on
the issue of surface and foul water
management a new flood risk assessment
and surface water management plan has
been submitted for consideration by the
council
and found to be acceptable
in addressing all flood and drainage
concerns of anglian water
the lead local flood authority and the
environment agency there are no
statutory objections to the proposal
the concern of course of local residents
which is important
as we have heard from in the summary
provided by the officer is not the
capacity of the sewage system
to take the additional foul but rather
whether the issue that persists
with surface water discharging into the
foul system
resulting in overflows would be
amplified by the development this is not
the case as we saw in the put in the
presentation earlier the site is
downstream from the system and the
surface water flows would be away from
the village
it therefore does not it does not follow
that the increased volume of sewage from
the 18 homes would lead to increased
overflows from stone water
we would therefore respectfully request
that you approve this application thank
you sorry thank you
um
yeah councillor humphreys
just one question i didn't get it
because you spoke so fast but um
the you said i think and i'm just
thinking because i could write it all
down you said that the nd ndp should be
uh acknowledged and and should should
follow through unless the material
considerations that would
otherwise override it um i didn't get
what this material um
considerations were so if you'd like to
tell me what they are please
okay um so the
the um
the officer of course has summarized
them in detail but in summary um i if i
just go through the ones that were
highlighted before um they are
the there are no highways um issues
that would result from the development
there was um there was a question asked
by one of the councillors earlier
regarding why why is the county no
longer concerned about highways impacts
and that was summarized in i think
paragraph 27 of the appeal decision
where where the inspector said the new
transport report and pedestrian route
assessment
fully fully assesses and shows that
there will be no insurmountable
increase in in an impact as a result of
highways and pedestrian movements and so
no impact on highway and pedestrian
safety would result and given that the
number of dwellings has reduced that
would of course be the same um with
regards to um this surface water and
foul situation i have um touched on that
in detail i can review any issues there
if you would like
but also just moving on the other
material consider
considerations before were considered to
be impacts on
heritage assets um and that was namely
lady-made cottage of course
we have seen that a number of dwellings
proposed have been removed and the field
adjacent to lady mid cottage has been
omitted from the development meaning
that there would be um a near impact on
lady mid cottage
so these these were the these were the
key issues raised and then of course um
thank you i think you're into the state
now i think yeah chancellor
chapter and verse there on the
element do you think councillor
humphreys yeah thank you manchester just
got it in my head um the only material
considerations you're really coming up
with there are highways issues and the
series issue
okay thank you because the lady me bit
is not relevant to this so thank you
does anyone else have any questions
um i i just have a question that i was a
bit confused about she said
uh
you said nicole that um all the flooding
issues had been resolved and i
understand from the officer's
presentation
where the pumping station would take the
surface water but i think my colleague
asked the question and the clarity was
given by the officer
that the sewage would still go in to the
current
sewage system
which is part of the problem
of overflowing is that correct
um well um the the the
well to clarify the problem of
overflowing is not the capacity of the
system it is in fact that the surface
the the stone the storm water that
enters the system but if somebody excuse
me interrupting but if somebody's
calculated that there is capacity
volume whether it's storm water or
sewage
would it not appear to be over capacity
whether it's included with something
that shouldn't be there i understand
what you're saying
no no so um so the the capacity in the
system there is sufficient to take the
the the system from the the file
emitting from the development the issue
that is existing at the moment that
would persist is one that relates to
storm water entering the system of which
we would be adding none
okay
thank you
thank you thank you very much indeed and
it doesn't look as though there's any
further questions and we now come to the
ward member if you would please
counselor hattingham if you would like
to tell us your views on this please
thank you very much as you all seen from
your papers and heard earlier this is
not the first time that a development on
this site has come before committee it
is the first time that it's come before
you
two years ago vincent recommended
refusal his reasons were four-fold
firstly the development lay outside of
the settlement boundary of thressing
field which at that time was defined as
a primary village and expected to
accommodate small-scale development to
meet local needs to quote from his
report the construction of up to 24
dwellings is considered by the council
to be a significant and inappropriate
level of development that in any event
falls outside of the settlement boundary
of the village contrary to local plan
policy cs2
this level of growth is is considered
unacceptable and inappropriate for the
reasons demonstrated and on that basis
considerable weight has afforded the
conflict posed for the development plan
where the benefits posed would not
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the harm and conflict identified nothing
has changed in this regard other than
the number of dwellings has reduced from
24 to 18.
furthermore threshingfield as you have
heard has a fully adopted neighborhood
plan which does not include this site
nor does our own joint local plan which
has also progressed further since this
last application it has also downgraded
frosting field to a hinterland village
in which development will not be
permitted within settlement with will
only be permitted within settlement
boundaries it also states that the
cumulative impact of proposals will be a
major consideration
there's already
outline permission for at least 54
dwellings in the village and another two
applications due to come to committee as
early as next month for another 48
dwellings
his second reason also concurred with
steve mary from suffolk county council
highways and that further traffic would
result in an unacceptable impact on
highway safety again to quote his report
the nature of the existing highway
network severely restricts practical
opportunities for acceptable mitigation
the measures that have been proposed are
the best solutions available within
existing constraints and fall short of
making the highway safe for pedestrians
and will increase the likelihood of
conflicts between them and vehicular
traffic an approval of the development
would increase pedestrian and or
vehicular movement through the core of
the village without the provision of
safe practical alternatives
further traffic passing along new street
and or through jubilee corner will
result in an unacceptable impact on
highway safety particularly for
vulnerable pedestrians this risk is is
considered to be unacceptable and its
own right would significantly and
demonstrably outweigh any benefits that
would arise from the proposal
a proposed development the harm to
predation pedestrian safety identified
is contrary to local planetary t-10 and
contrary to paragraph 109 of the mppf
the third reason covered the irregular
flooding of raw sewage along low road
which he refers to as the resultant
pollution is an unacceptable
environmental and public health risk
that appears unable to be reasonably
mitigated by the drainage authority
the fourth and frankly almost
unnecessary reason because when viewed
after the previous concerns was
certainly sufficient to recommend
refusal but almost as the last nail in
the coffin that it would have a less
than substantial harm on near nearby
grade two listed property lady made
the
appeal inspector focused on just one of
the reasons for refusal the one thing
that the applicant could easily change
and the applicants have done so removing
six of the closest dwellings to lady
mead does that mean that other very
compelling reasons have disappeared they
have not the inspector disregarded them
with a stroke of his pen and i'm asking
you not to do the same
i'm sure that you cannot fail to have
noticed the very strong opposition
regarding this development and the
outrage that the highly praised
neighborhood plan has been ignored not
only that but our own emerging local
plan would also be ignored if this were
to go ahead in both of these plans
housing outside of the settlement
boundary is not to be accepted what is
the point of having a settlement
boundary if it doesn't really matter
whether you're in or out
this is not simply a village getting
more housing that it feels that it
doesn't want or need this is a
hinterland village in a fairly
unsustainable location many miles from
any major roads or towns without any
public transport
um and it's only two dwelling short of
the target of 56 and our own local plan
to suggest that 18 dwellings could fit
in with the neighborhood plan as
windfalls is stretching the definition
of windfall undoubtedly to the extreme
windfalls are surely
infill developments of one two or maybe
even three they are not 18 outside of
the settlement boundary leaving two
windfalls which they have been five in
the last two years at an advantage
disadvantage sorry i urge you to refuse
this application
and i'm happy to answer questions
thank you councillor hattingham any
questions for councillor
hattingham no i can't see any questions
there thank you councillor hattingham
so i now open this up for debate
so if we start in the first and usual
fashion counselor custom
thank you very much madam chairman um
i can see
quite a few key issues but i'm just
gonna go through two of the
main key issues for me
it's um
with this um
housing need
um
so when i when i look at the housing
provider i've still got to um i've got
to stick with the um
safe
like safe says
this um
18 houses because i can only deal with
the planning permission as it stands
um it means they're very close to their
housing need in thressing field which i
think
carries more weight to the um
neighborhood plan but i think that's
something that i we need to talk about
in debate but the real
key issue here for me is the sewage
issue i am
i don't
go with this argument that because it's
not putting storm water down a sewage
pipe it's not adding to the problem
because it's storm water that some
overflow in the sewer it's um
it's that's that's complete nonsense to
me um
it's um
it's sewage going down a pipe
um that overflows
from from what the um resident said 12
times in two years sending all the
chemicals
all the um
human waste and everything into a brook
and i i find that a really serious
problem
here and i'm i'm surprised that this
hasn't been looked at in fresconfield
before
but um
it's um yes it will it will add to the
problem it will put sewage into that
system that can't handle it i think the
um the what would
it may be acceptable if it was
controlled
somehow so at peak times or when there's
flooding that wasn't released i think
that would maybe be a solution to that
problem but as it stands um
yeah i've i've got i've got some serious
worries about this application but i'm
i'll listen to the debate and
and um
make an opinion after i've listened to
that thank you
thank you for that um councillor carson
you make a very useful point there and i
wonder if um john patman g
can come in on that uh where you
mentioned about holding back sewage
during poor times
um john would you like to give us some
thoughts on that please
yes um so i've listened to everybody on
this one and it it is an interesting um
well it's an interesting situation to be
in you know we recognize that the
village has a significant problem i
think that's undeniable
um
and so and that's been you know highly
illustrated and demonstrated um
throughout this uh conversation so far
right
now
that said the applicant is also correct
in that the capacity is there for the
foul sewer it's the problem with the
surface water
that said
i would actually take it slightly
further let's yeah we can't we don't
have a solution to that it doesn't sound
there's going to be a solution to that
anytime soon so i would say there is a
material consideration here in respect
of the existing problem because
even though there's enough capacity for
the burden of this development to come
forward
that
surface water issue is still going to be
out there coming into the system at
storm times
so the additional foul water
that this produces even though the
capacity is there
will be part of the problem spilling out
and causing a problem for the the locals
now i'm not an expert in in all of this
but that's how i kind of see it so in my
head
and i
appreciate i did this to
my colleague very quickly earlier
why don't we just stop it going anywhere
near the problem and why is that not
unreasonable to do so
and i can't see a problem here because
ultimately there are two potential way
for ways forward that if we were to
approve this and it might be
based on uh the achievement to delegate
to officers to achieve
if we were to improve this
why not seek either
private sewage plants for the individual
properties or given the pumping station
that's already there
a control mechanism to be agreed
um that would essentially deal with that
um appropriately
and we think there is an answer there
and we can certainly ask members if you
were
concerned about that issue and
if we could go forward on the basis of
uh resolving that before issuing any
decision that that could be a way
forward so i i think there is certainly
a good area here for us to explore and
uh look to have a solution but
ultimately the solution to this
for the sake of the local locality is
just to avoid putting it in there in the
first place and i think that's actually
a possibility so i would suggest that is
a way forward for members
thank you for that john that that's
quite useful and it was certainly
brought up by councillor castin which
has given us food for thought
uh whether members would be inclined on
leaving that for officers to decide or
how we go forward let's just see how the
debate goes we'll sow that seed in our
memory
and um i will move on to the next
participant councillor gould please
thank you very much uh madam chair i'm
actually profoundly troubled by by this
application
particularly in
kind of reconciling
the
evidence
in in the report
with the conclusion and recommendation
uh
made by mr pierce
uh and and that's become more so as uh
the presentation's gone on uh miss
appears been very generous in
in accepting uh some of the errors in
the report uh as pointed out by uh by
safe and and and the residents
so i'm i'm i really am troubled uh by
this uh
again we've all been received a lot of
correspondence from local residents on
this application
and and and going through those i i
found
at least seven
um substantive uh
reasons or causes for concern uh with
regard to this application and we've
touched upon many of those they are
highways uh the the the drainage
um
issues uh but there are others as well
that we haven't really talked about very
much uh pressure on infrastructure uh
particularly not least the the medical
center
um
the thing also that i'm that troubles me
here uh is about the neighborhood plan
now often
as a believer in localism
when we when we look at these decisions
before us or applications before us and
we find often that we can't give the
regard to the neighborhood plan that
we'd like to because it doesn't make
adequate provision
or it's at odds with the emerging local
plan in such a way that it makes it
difficult to go with it this is not one
of those occasions there is a good uh
neighborhood plan
which has been
fully adopted is highly material uh
makes good provision
for for the housing for housing need uh
and i for one would not want to
go against uh that plan unless there
were really compelling reasons and i
don't find reasons why we should go uh
against the plan so i'm i'm minded uh
not to agree this application thank you
thank you for that councillor gould
can we hear from councillor humphreys
please
um sure i have an emergency at home and
uh if you could put me at the last bit
that'd be really appreciated and i'll
get back to you
yeah okay cheers
um counselor melon
uh thank you chair um
i think uh there are three points i
would like to add into the debate
um the
planning officer has made a case
based around um
the appeal decision and and seeking to
use
some of the arguments there as a kind of
loophole
in which this
current application can be justified
um
the the papers in the bundle um
selectively quote various paragraphs of
the appeal decision and really focus on
the
the main thrust being the the impact on
the heritage asset which i accept
this new application does not
um does not seem to be a problem
however the inspectors report paragraph
35
um
he says that i have found that the site
would not provide an appropriate
location for residential development
having regard to the development plan
and national planning policies and the
character and appearance of the area and
then he goes on to say i have also found
the proposal would harm the setting to
the grade two listed lady made so the
main thrust of the
inspector's
refusal
was
the policy front and that's where it
still stands
the the impact on the heritage
heritage asset is gone but the main
policy reason for the refusal still
stands
now secondly we have the the foul
drainage problem
and here we have to look at the reality
on the ground anglian water is patently
wrong
when it says
that there is not a problem because
the theoretical capacity may be there
but the functional capacity
is not the bland reassurance
that this can be dealt with it just
seems to be completely unacceptable
um
even
however even
if all these new houses were fitted out
with the latest composting toilets
so that no foul drainage went into the
sewer
we still are left with the main plank
of an argument against it which is the
adopted
pressing field
neighborhood development plan
i don't think we can easily set this
document aside
and it seems to me that in trying to do
so
the the officer employs a very torturous
logic
to say that it should be set aside
there's mention of paragraph 11 of the
mppf the tilted balance
but paragraph 12 of the mppf says
where a planning application conflicts
with an up-to-date development plan
permission should not usually be granted
and that's where i find myself at this
stage of the debate thank you
thank you councillor mellon um very good
points there and very interesting thank
you
um we now come to councillor norris
please
thank you madam chairman uh well
councilman marlon's already covered
quite a number of the points that uh are
of concern to me
uh we've had a lot of discussion about
uh sewage egress and what will result
from adding another 18 dwellings onto
the existing sewage system
um neighbourhood plan
uh not
identified within the neighborhood plan
as a site for development outside the
settlement area
is there a
proven local need for this proposed
development
highways issues
reliance on the motor car question is
this an unsustainable location
uh hazards for pedestrians lack of
pavements in some parts of streets for
pedestrians who have to walk in the road
at the present time i am
inclined not to support this application
but i will listen to the rest of the
debate
thank you
thank you councillor norris councillor
stringer
uh
thank you chair uh i start
my uh
my rounding up of this issue from
the appeal inspector
uh and and he rounded up in conclusion
and said i conclude the site is not a
suitable location for new housing
having regard to the development plan
and national planning policies
i'm not going to re-rehearse national
planning policies
but i think the most important part of
that sentence is the development plan
and for this particular application
you have the most up-to-date
neighborhood plan
it's been very recently through
inspection so it's been through with a
fine-tooth comb and approved by our
council it is the primary document we
should be using when determining this
application
and and and that's where
i i begin and end all this
the issue about the sewage
is
outrageous what's going on in this
village it's utterly outrageous and that
needs to be sorted out it's it's a quirk
of how we deal with our water and we
cannot fix that here uh no matter what
we do
talks of deferring and perhaps looking
at private treatment works they don't
work for this multiple of houses so some
yeah
it should have been done already but of
course we have a plan in place to sort
this out it is the neighborhood plan now
these neighborhood plans are also
reviewed in this case on an annual basis
of report goes to the parish council to
say are we on track
and there's been talks of whether there
is a deficit in the neighborhood plan or
not hang on a minute the neighborhood
plan is less than two years in
to delivering all the housing numbers
and there's talk of whether it's eight
short or six short hang on we've got 20
odd years to go
to make up this this shortfall if indeed
there is one and the way to if the if
the neighborhood plans aren't delivering
the housing numbers
then the neighborhood plans are reviewed
and
the position could change and that is
where a proposal such as this should be
cited it should be coming up as a
potential site to be reviewed if
a very important if the current
neighborhood plan is not delivering and
of course this one
is delivering
it's a material consideration as is
damage to it the mppf clearly says and
there's
loads of case history about being
premature and damaging neighborhood
plants uh and and as it clearly says you
know if something is contrary to the
neighborhood plan it should generally be
refused uh which is where i think this
one should be
uh
i think that's basically all i've got
other than to say if we're worried about
windfall there's another class use
coming into windfall and that is class q
thing where you can have up to four
dwellings uh an old agricultural
building
those are coming through in in quite
large numbers so i have absolutely no
doubt that threshing field will hit its
number uh and like i say and i will i
would determine this completely in line
with its neighborhood plan which is the
primary document uh and that's basically
where i sit thank you chair
may i come in at this point chair
hello
sorry chair i believe you're on mute
still
oh
sorry um yeah sorry councillor boys if
we can just let john come in and um i
apologize to you i think he's got a
relevant point to make thank you
we need to be very careful about the
treatment of the neighborhood plan and
especially when we say it's a primary
document um
it's gonna i'm gonna have to probably
read this out and forward because i
think it's about the best way to uh
be clear and make sure that we don't end
up with a judicial review risk here um
so i'm i'm gonna it's gonna sound like
i'm reading this because i am reading it
in part but i think it'd be useful
uh to uh sum this up in in a an
appropriate way and ian i i will
appreciate any help you have with this
um i'm here john yes well i'm gonna
start from the beginning and and put
this into context because members do
need to demonstrate they've considered
this as a matter of law
so while the council can
as a district council demonstrate a
five-year housing supply
the nppf also requires that its
development plan policies
which are the most important for the
determination of an application are not
out of date as defined in paragraph 11.
so essentially
if we if it isn't the case we have what
is called the tilted balance
in this case the tilted balance is
engaged because
of taking in the round the most
important policy determination are out
of date in the local plan this is cs1
cs2 h7
they've been found out of date
by various appeals uh including those
dealt by a public inquiry
so
members are accordingly advised that
paragraph 11d of the mppf and its effect
is a material consideration which your
in your office's opinion indicates that
a decision should be made otherwise in
accordance with the mentioned plans the
tilted balance directs that are planning
for me should be granted
unless there are significant and
demonstrational harm
the neighborhood plan
is a part
of the development plan and therefore
also within the scope of sections 38 of
the act
now
accordingly the decision should be made
in accordance with that unless material
considerations indicate otherwise
the material consideration being the
nppf and the mppf that requires all
parts of the development plan to be at
in date
all parts of your net development plan
are not in date are not they are one
part is out of date
now i appreciate the local plan is old
and i appreciate it's been going for
some time and
ultimately
you know we are desperately trying to
get to the point where we have a new
local plan it's almost like a
replacement part that we've just been
waiting for for some time and we could
give that limited weight
and it's an emerging document but it
isn't here now
we unfortunately at the moment have
various elements that make up the
development plan
but one of them is out to date and it
doesn't matter how in date the
neighborhood plan is and how up-to-date
and recent it is
it doesn't negate the issue that we have
an out-of-date element still part of our
policy consideration
and i think we need to be very careful
here
there's no such thing as a primary
document the document is all of the
documents that form the development plan
that is your consideration by law
um i was going to try and explain it in
a different way but i think i'm going to
leave it there at this moment in time um
the interpretation of the policy is a
matter of law we've got to be very
careful of that
and that includes the placement of the
local plan and the neighborhood plan as
part of the development plan you can't
set one aside for another
the weight to be attached to particular
material considerations though is for
the decision maker exercising reasonable
judgment on its planning merits and
there's variations of that that includes
the appeal and that includes
you know the appeal was for more houses
so you know you've got to be very clear
if we're using the appeal as a start
point of what the material
considerations there apply to this
actual proposal in front of you today
i think i'll leave it there before i go
on thank you
right thank you very much for that
um
coming back thank you that was
interesting council of war boys i think
you wanted to speak next if you would
please thank you
yeah i'm just trying to absorb
everything that mr payment geez
has just told us um
the way i say i think there are three
main issues here which
all
for me make it very difficult to support
this
planning
application
the first is i i think as as we've
already
aired at some length is the completely
unacceptable business of the
sewage being discharged into the street
anglia waters sitting on a profit of 68
million pounds
to 2019 and that and in effect it seems
to have washed its hands of the problem
and turned it into a
potential profit-making situation where
it can charge people for discharging
surface water
the existing far water system is clearly
inadequate
and it'd be difficult to support a plan
and application that added to that
problem
the second issue is the
the traffic
um
again i'm a bit surprised that the 20
mile per hour traffic scheme
is linked to this development there's
money from central government available
for improving pedestrian and cyclists
safely uh and this should be
seen as a priority
to cope with existing
problems
um and further development will only
make the situation worse
um
and finally the the neighbourhood plan
this is
this has a v
has a vision for
freshing field
um
it has
set a target for by 2036
it is almost reaching that target
in terms of
leap for development
and as council stringer says that
there's
over the next 16 years it's extremely
likely that
um
the odd number of houses will come
forward
to meet the the targeting in full
um
this is this a great deal of commitment
has gone into producing this main
neighborhood plan 88
support by the locality
and they recognized that there was a
need for development
and
identified an appropriate target
for my mind that that
document
should
hold sufficient weight together with
the
infrastructure problems to be able to
refuse
this planning application
thank you for that cass the war boys now
councillor humphreys have you been
listening to us um i i know you sort of
shot off but i'm not quite sure what
you're saying
the same same room so i did shoot off
but dealt with now so excuse there's any
noise in the background but um my
grandson had an incident uh so just
dealt with that
um there he goes so um some debate side
of it uh first glance um looking at it
in a different way this is a logical
place to develop even though it is
outside the settlement boundary it just
seems the right place for the right
right development um
and the fact that lady mead now that has
been mitigated against is no longer part
of this issue again that takes away that
whole debate about um about the uh grade
two listed building so like i say uh
looking at it objectively from space you
think you know what that's not a bad
place to put it however it is outside
the settlement boundary
and it could be argued um
there's no no need for any extra local
housing here especially when you
consider the neighborhood development
plan
well established and has significant
weight
they've already allocated um up to well
it depends it got a little bit confusing
on numbers before between 51 and 54
houses or dwellings that have been
approved already or highlighted this 18
houses would take it over that level
considerably my view and therefore
shouldn't happen
um that neighborhood development plan
has significant weight and we shouldn't
take that away that significant weight
without shallow down a lot of effort was
put into that in this adoption it's
writing and basically what it is now
um it's already identified areas of
development within the settlements area
which is fantastic um so they've done
their best to actually
say you know what we're not opposed to
development but there's a level that we
can go to and they've said 60 houses
over the lifetime of the neighborhood
development plan well this as i said
before we'll take them over that and i
think it's excessive and not required
um
i realized that obviously housing
doesn't have a ceiling or a maximum seal
excuse depend on that but we still need
to take the neighborhood development
plan into consideration because it's
significant weight if you go back to the
original appeal decision on this site
and i know it's slightly bigger and it's
for more houses some of the points that
the inspector brought her and some of
the reasons actually it went there are
still valid and it's all building
outside of the settlement area it's
madness you just don't get this
um
if you think about the agent's point
when i asked them about uh they said
well we need to basically deal with the
neighborhood development plan absolutely
unless material
the consideration is a great set and
they just talked about the um the
highways and the drainage well i don't
think the drainage has been satisfied at
all
in the slightest and i think that
actually having listened to everybody
else in the debate and the officers and
everybody else has spoken that is still
a major issue
that is only going to get worse and i
just can't i can't accept that we'd
allow that to happen
um
i just don't get it even with mr payment
g's uh solution to some of the drainage
issues it's still not right okay it's
still not right it's outside of the
supplement area and it's against their
neighbourhood development plan and so my
major concern is the total number of
houses or dwellings that can be created
in this area which against the
neighborhood development plan
well in excess of 60. i think they've
done their very best to accommodate um
development in that area i think you
know enough's enough this is too much
i just think this is a time when we
really need to listen and read what's in
the neighborhood development plans and
try and adhere to it whenever possible
and secondly i think this is a time when
we really do need to listen to the
number of objectives which i think has
been unprecedented on this um and their
concerns because they're all valid this
isn't an emotional argument their
argument is fairly factual i think we
should listen to it um i'm not a fan of
this i've got to be honest with you um
but we'll see where we go thank you
thank you for that and with the
encouraging noises of your grandson in
the background i don't think he is
either
um
yeah my turn
i think i agree with councillor
humphreys um in his opening gambit is
when you look at it in the initial
stages that looks pretty good you know
the road's already in there and so on
and so forth we often have cases coming
to us that are outside the settlement
boundaries but they don't always have a
neighborhood plan
mr paytman g has
bothered me somewhat
um by suggesting that
because our joint local plan
is out of date it's only gone through
for reg19 oh it's gone out for
consultation
the tilted balance kicks in
and i wonder where we sit with that
many many people have written and
objected very sound objections and i
find it appalling that angley water
and
the many previous people have been
trying to resolve
the issue of flooding and sewage
and i'm uncomfortable that sewage from
this
development should it be approved
would add to the problem i don't care
what anyone says it would add to the
problem
i also heard from
mr patemanji who said ah well we might
be able to solve that we could do
individual sewage things
so there's an awful lot of um
not very good points here
sam unfortunately had to leave and the
highways issue
there always conflict of highways and
it's difficult to put more danger in
place if you like but that's not for me
to say what's dangerous and what isn't
i wonder
for
concern of the
the the
the neighborhood plan and the reason for
it
and our joint local plan
whether we should defer this
and i the reason i say this is we can
get
council's advice
because we need to know
on this business of a neighborhood plan
does it trump
an application
and if because our policies are out of
date the tilted balance comes in place
then we're in danger
of being overturned
i
i very much
don't want to say i agree with this
application
i don't
but i just wonder if deferring it just
to get all those because i wouldn't be
prepared to put this through and say oh
yes well we'll let the officers sort
this out and the officers sort that out
because highways have said this
we've got an awful lot of people who've
taken time to write into us and we owe
it to them and their neighbourhood plan
so i wonder whether there's any mileage
in that for anybody to think about
so i've sown that seed and we'll go
round again because this is a very very
upsetting application
so with your good grace would anybody
else like to comment um a second time
please
counselor stringer
all along well for months since we've
had neighborhood plans
there is a growing
and
noticeable conflict between that many of
them and national and some of our local
policies in where they do sit where they
don't sit
there's been a very for me an
uncomfortable trend
of
sometimes neighborhood plans appearing
to be inconvenient
to to swift decision making which is why
i'm always very twitchy about how
they're written about
and even in the papers today we found a
number of
omissions where you know
where it could have been more clarified
for us
i personally don't have i wouldn't want
to defer this application
we have enough information here
to actually make a determination i feel
and actually
if if this is i mean in the end what
we're trying to do is
lawfully determine an application and
see how it fits with local
district and national legislation
for me
this particular one is quite unique
because we've got a
you know
the biggest
the document with the most noise for me
within all the suite of documents is how
this document links with the national
planning policy framework and it bolts
on beautifully
and for me it says
that this application should be refused
uh because of
the housing provision of this hinterland
village with very very sparse
connectivity and that community has
looked at that sparse connectivity
actually when
the officer put up the
the footpath mapping i thought that was
brilliant because what that demonstrated
was how difficult the connectivity of
this site would be and why the parish
the why the the the neighborhood plan
had allocated the sites it allocated it
pointed out to me why that neighborhood
plan had been well thought through so
for me i would have no qualms in
refusing this application as it stands
on a number of grams
including it being against
the uh f-e-r-e-s one
in the neighborhood plan
and if that applicant the applicant then
has two choices they either appeal that
situation
and then the government whose will
via the mppf can then be tested by the
government
and or they can work with the
neighborhood plan group as bringing in
this upper site in the future as part of
any review that's all i have to say
chair thank you
that's me again sorry about that um
i think we need to be careful the um
joint local plan is advising hinterland
it hasn't gone through yet
and that's where i'm getting nervous
about it all
um
so um
we'll carry on just going around
listening to everybody else and then
i think if anybody wants to um make a
proposal they need to demonstrate the
harm
um so if you can be thinking on that i'd
be grateful and counsellor mellon you
wish to speak thank you
uh thank you chair yes just to comment
briefly uh um i'm really i think in in
general agreement with councillor
stringer i i would find it hard to
support a deferral
um i believe there's enough
um
i hate to use the word material because
that's been used in various senses but
there we have enough arguments
against this proposal
um
to
to put a case together for refusal
and that's one i think i would support
okay thank you for that
anyone else wish to speak or would
anybody like to put forward their
proposals please
well actually i'm going to come in
before anyone pushes this further
forward
yeah
okay um i'm listening to what
everybody's saying and i i get that
there's a lot of
feeling of looking towards possibly even
a refusal here
um
i need to be a defendable position for
the council
i need to understand
what is the demonstrationable
harm
and i think we we need to get very clear
on this
the requirement of a tilted balance
ultimately
is to uh direct that we can you know we
should be granting permission unless
there is significant and demonstratable
harm
and i'm going to be blunt about this
a few extra houses above a limit that
within a neighbor plan is not enough in
my opinion to be demonstrating harm
if we have a cap on development
which we we were we've failed to defend
before as a council
um
we are gonna we then nppf doesn't say
there should be a cap on development you
know you can have more
what we need to work out though is if
that more results in harm and so far in
the debate
all i've heard
is the sewage system
is the harmful element
fine i've got one harmful element what
else is harm
and it's is it significant harm
that i can demonstrate and defend at an
appeal
so please
we need to go through that
far more if we are going down a refusal
route as the impression i'm beginning to
get
councillor stringer you've got something
yeah
there's two two bits of harm that i've
listed
first bit of harm is actually to the
neighborhood plan itself and that is
actually a material consideration within
the guidance the other bit of harm was
identified by the original appeal
inspector
it was harm to the character and
appearance of the area
he wasn't just talking about the
historic building
he was talking about the entire site
so there is harm to the character and
appearance of the area and there is harm
to the neighborhood plan and there is
harm to the existing infrastructure
because everyone recognizes that this is
the not the most safely connected
village you'll ever see because of the
narrowness and the design of the streets
so
there are three clear ident identifiers
of harm
just there thank you chair
now i come back on that please
um yes
you're saying
you're the character in appearance
remains uh despite the reduction since
the appeal because you feel the
remainder of the site that is now put
forward today
uh is still harmful in terms of the
character and appearance of the area
okay and you are saying there are
insufficient connections um and the
infrastructure there in in terms of
footpaths and by ways and so on to
support uh the growth of this
development i don't understand how it
harms the neighbourhood plan
right
well okay uh
it's difficult to explain but it isn't
difficult to explain because
i've been involved with one uh and there
are sorry i'll put the video on as well
there are hundreds and hundreds of
volunteer hours go into this
and what is highly likely if you get an
application which is deemed premature
they are immediately going to have to
review their neighborhood plan
which means it's suddenly going to be
out of killer with
every other plan
or what is likely to happen is everyone
will consider that the whole
neighborhood planning process was a
complete waste of time and everybody
give up and that is harm
how i'm i'm sorry i don't agree i can't
i can't put that in planning terms
that i would have very i'd have a lot of
difficulty in trying to put that into
planning terms um
i appreciate it the mpps very helpful
because it says we're a made
neighborhood plan
where there is a current five-year land
supply it says applications that are
outside of that should normally be
refused
okay but where is this normally be
refused that's true but we are in the
situation that that is part of a
development plan and the tilted balance
is engaged
so i i've got to weigh that into the
account and that's probably where
further advice possibly from counsel
might be needed if we were to go down
that road and that might be a reason why
you would want to defer it for us to get
that advice
can i just say that sounds a reasonable
alternative to ensure that councillor
stringer's
comments are
um defensible
would you agree councillor stringer yeah
they're not just my comments i have to
say that they're what's in the policy
if we want to get that opinion please do
to get opinion on where a maid
neighborhood plan is inc and when the
tilted balance or should or should not
be invoked is possibly a good thing and
and that's and that's where i would be
coming from but i wonder if in doing so
we could put councillor stringer's
points
as the reason for deferral if members
might be minded to then might not
but to get clarity on that very point uh
councillor stringer because as you say
this has happened before and we need
clarity
and i mean once the once the joint local
plan is in place
we're on the home street
which is why i suspect we're witnessing
the timings of applications that we are
at the moment but yeah absolutely
yeah
but um cancer string if you just hold
that one in the balance for the matter i
will
because i'm wondering if you could take
that as a proposal and i see other
people have put their hands up and i'll
let me just hear how they feel about
that's that scenario counselor gould
hey sir
i think actually councillor humphreys uh
was was before me
sorry i'm looking on the list
councillor humphreys sorry you wanted to
speak i beg your pardon
council humphreys
yeah manchester sorry button problems
there so background noise aside um i get
a lot of what counselor string is saying
i also get what um mr paint and jeez is
saying as well um blind i'm sort of
signing towards your view of a
so that we can get some of this
information that is going to be
important for us to make a decision um
and part of that would be in my opinion
is part of the inspector's report
because
as far as i could
can read it 288
they're pretty much a summary of what
you said i'd like to see a little bit
more detail as to why it's refused
because that might be relevant to what
we're doing now even though it's a
bigger site even though it's two fields
i think some of the reasons for that um
for that loss of appeal are still
relevant and would be very very useful
for our debate and our decision making
um so i i understand the reason for a
possible deferral
because i think there's still a few more
questions that need to be asked
and indeed um the the issue over the
sewage i mean it it you know it needs to
be looked at properly doesn't it
councillor gould you were going to speak
as well thank you very much from chair
um i'd
a few minutes ago i was uh
minded to go against deferral because
like cancer stringer i thought uh
this was a clear enough matter to be
able us
for us to determine it
now
um however i'm i'm
you know i found two parts of our role
in conflict here one one is the
democratic role in terms of judging
planning matters and the other is the
duty to act in a responsible way and and
not put um public resources and so on at
risk and it's how we reconcile those two
things so i'm
minded now that we we do seek um
cancel or other expert
uh advice on this but i'd i'd like that
to be on the basis of how we support uh
a refusal uh decision to refuse
rather than
the legitimation of some other planning
perspective if you get my drift thank
you
i do indeed counsellor gould which is
why i said to councillor stringer hold
your thoughts on the the refusal aspect
of it while we look at a deferral aspect
so i absolutely agree with you
um
so um who have we got yeah so councillor
stringer do you want to come back and
and make a formal proposal on that way
um you know i've considered this a
little bit
uh and you know i'm not i tell you for
why
because when you go and get council's
opinion what they'll do they'll go and
look back at previous appeal cases and
cases have been through judicial review
and i then ask myself if this council
doesn't have
the goal and the backbone to back a
neighborhood plan
to make part of that council law that
case law what is a council for if it's
not to support a community that's put in
all of the hard work
to produce an exemplar neighborhood plan
frankly if that costs this authority
some money in defending it
then that's what we should do on behalf
of our citizens if not all we're going
to be doing is getting case law on other
people's decisions
so frankly i wouldn't still vote to
defer now i've considered it i think
what we should do is uphold this
neighborhood plan and get that tested
well i've got another idea
how about if we go for minded to refuse
but get further information that we seek
further information so that that's then
in the box
uh
chair i don't see how that helps because
if
the council's opinion comes back and
says i think you i think you've not got
a strong case what what do we then do it
comes back
well if we haven't got a strong case
then then the point has been proved but
well no it hasn't i think but i think
we've got a lot we'll go ahead and prove
it or will somebody please come up with
a proposal of something and then we can
have a vote on it and we'll either vote
vote it down to help you chair i will
move refusal on the basis of the
fretting field neighborhood plan
happy to second that yeah
and that's and that's the reason for
refusal is it
yep yes chair
okay
um chair if i may i would also want to
put in the the sewage situation as a
material consideration
uh
in favor of refusal
so that's actually the infrastructure is
also in the freshing field neighbourhood
plan
chancellor humphries
yeah manchester sorry just obviously
without a proposal secondly there just
for my own sanity and awareness i can
vote on it what the actual reasons the
physical actual reasons
lay them down and then
it just says the neighborhood plan
and that is planned policy
uh hang on let me get the number correct
uh
uh there we go that would be it's just
disappeared it's the
it's number one which is the f
f n
p
o one i believe
let me have scroll
through the it's being particularly
annoying today here we go it's very good
yeah
hs1
and fres3
which is the infrastructure
so
okay
um
sorry are we waiting for you councillor
stringer
oh i thought i thought i was wait sorry
i thought i was waiting for someone
else's chair uh oh well no i thought i
thought you were gonna give us some
reasons
i've been advised that we can't use or
shouldn't use anything beginning with a
c because that's out of date or with an
h because they're all out of date
the local plan
so that is what i'm left with
and the national planning policy
framework is not a policy so i can't
quote that
sorry councillor string it's vincent
pierce
in your list um were you thinking fars
15 transport and highway safety or
or did you feel that
the position as established following
the last appeal wasn't a good reason for
refusal just for the sake of absolute
clarity 15 there is an issue on uh
transport because of the connectivity
because but that links into our f r e s
one doesn't it it's the way they chose
it didn't use it in the first place uh
so uh yeah
counselor norris wanted to say something
thank you madam chair yes um
i
had pretty well sort of formulated the
idea
of
recommending refusal but i've been
listening to what's just been said
recently
i
tend to see merit in your suggestion of
a deferral on a minded to refuse basis
but that gives us time to get more
information on our position so i can
very much see the value of that
that's all i wanted to say thank you
well
that is helpful because i haven't
have i had a second to run this one i'm
not sure
um councillor gould
it's munchau i'd be um
happy to second uh that that proposal
that uh
we have reminded to refuse but seek
further advice that seems to me to be
the responsible and uh
way ahead though to say again i am um
opposed to
to this application but want to see the
council's position safeguarded
indeed
um robert carmichael thank you for that
councillor girl robert carmichael you've
put your hand up for something
thank you chair sorry to just interrupt
we do have a substantive proposal on the
table i couldn't jump in quick enough
there i'm afraid
from councillor stringer seconded by
councillor mellon so in the normal line
of things we do have to take that
formally before we can
go to any other proposal to any other
proposal to vote upon
um but can i um just take legal advice
for a moment can we just uh pause for
advice well yeah yes madam chair that mr
carmichael is quite right and unless the
if we have
unless the proposer and second of the
refusal motion choose to withdraw it we
must vote on that resolution before we
consider anything else
it i mean
it's so my understanding is it was
proposed and it was second is that right
that's what i was questioning
um
[Music]
i think we had we had we did have
councillor stringer making a proposal
although he was in the process of
formulating his reasons for it
i believe that had been done
i'm happy for it to go to a vote and
yeah well hang on i'm not sure i've got
a second yet can we just do it one at a
time um
[Music]
was it seconded by councillor mellon
andrew cancer andrew mellon is that
right that is correct mr president yeah
i thought so yes okay so if we just
before we go to the vote can i just have
a timeout for a quick legal conversation
that would be quite wise chairman i'm
very happy to give you you advice that
we we've done it in the council train
when you've gone outside the room
there's nothing wrong in it so we can do
it so can we just do that for a moment
please if you would please ladies and
gentlemen
live stream and i will set up a separate
meeting
yeah yourself chair mr president well i
can i can make a phone call can i not
yeah if you wish to cheer if that's if
that's thank you
i'm now exercising my discretionary
powers as chairman
and i will send the matter to referrals
um the reason being is that rob i want
to be absolutely clear that the
constitution says i can do that
because i'm mindful of the strong advice
from the officers
of the relative weakness of the reasons
for our refusal
so rob can you confirm that i am
entitled to do that at this point thank
you
thank you chair so
i will be referring forth reference to
the council's constitution under the
planning referrals so this is part three
c
demand control a b and planning
referrals
within the subsection regarding to that
at point
under the planning referral section part
one
i'll just read it out for clarity if
that's okay chair just so that all
members are aware of what i'm referring
to
thank you um so all aspects of the
planning and development control refer
to committee for determination
in accordance with the protocol for the
use of planning officer delegations upon
which the delegations the development
control committee fails to agree the
recommendation of the chief planning
officer and where the chairman is of the
opinion that the decision would not be
in court in accordance with the overall
policies and procedures approved by the
council as defined within the protocol
for the use of planning officer
delegations
nation there is a there is on this point
there is ambiguity
as is not uncommon within a constitution
but i would
i would advise with mr duprey's comments
as well
that if
where there is ambiguity in the
constitution the chair's interpretation
is always final so i would advise that
because it does not say at a certain
point that you have to make a decision
by that that you can use your righteous
of your power as chair to send it to the
planning referrals at this point
mr duprey any comments will be greatly
received
that that is much because
thank you very much for that mr
carmichael i'm just wondering sorry i
know this is elongating a very tedious
meeting but i'm sorry no it's not
tedious it's an important democratic
meeting it's
what what because i i was struggling to
get hold of
i was advising the chairman just now
privately and i was struggling to get
hold of the wording of the constitution
i'm very glad you have i was relying on
memory
would you mind awfully just
reading that out again just so i can
fully get my head around it and make
sure i'm satisfied i've given the right
advice
yes of course mr dubray so this to
exercise the general role is to exercise
the council's powers as a local planning
authority in respect of all aspects
planning and development control
referred
to committee for determination in
accordance with the protocol for using
the planning officer delegations upon
which the development control committee
fails to agree with the recommendation
of the chief planning officer and where
the chairman is of the opinion that the
decision would not be in accordance with
the overall policies and procedures
approved by council as defined within
the protocol for the use of planning
officer delegations
right well i'm just i'm just thinking
this through now i mean
fails to agree
the the committee at this minute has not
actually made a formal decision so what
would you say that means if
we i do recall i was saying to the
chairman we both she and i both recall
incense a couple of years ago where
there was a resident there was a
proposal to grant permission in
accordance with officer recommendation
but which fell so there was no authority
to refuse but there was a perfectly
proper and lawful decision made then
to refer it to take it to referrals
committee
um yeah i agree that there's ambiguity
the issue is whether
i mean if if the resolution
to refuse was passed was passed the the
chairman
could but i think no i think actually
having so i'm debating with myself out
loud but i think i think i yeah i i
think common sense says that if
that the chair has got the discretion at
this point
and um
yeah yes i i i have taken that view now
i agree with you
[Music]
and that madam chairman that is you that
is your decision having received our
advice that you and you wish to
intend to
you are
taking the matter to referrals committee
yes
could i then ask for a point of order
could could could i ask what decision it
is that we've taken
well i can make it i can i can make
the decision as advised by the legal
officers so um
that's my decision
right now i'm sorry sorry
my understanding of the constitution is
that referrals commit the chairman has
the ability to send something to
referral committee when
the committee has come to a decision
we have not yet come to a decision
um
well
there is a proposal on the table that
may or may not
get a majority if my proposal falls
would that change your decision
well
the the example i referred to a minute
ago that there was a failure of a
resolution to approve
that but that meant that the
the committee by negatively as it were
was indicating its disagreement with the
advice of the chief planning officer so
that point it was lawful for the the
chair
i mean yeah well
councillor string has made the point as
to what why i was debating with myself
about this point but if i suppose
council stringer is saying that well
okay if my resolution to refuse is
his pass that that would be seen
normally as an instruction to the
officers by the committee to issue a
notice of refusal but the chair under
the southern mid-suffolk constitution
the chair then has discretion to take it
to referrals committee
i mean maybe i think for the sake of
being conscious that one doesn't wish to
interfere one wishes to interfere as
little as possible mr carmichael i'm
bringing you in again if i may we i
think what council stringer is
suggesting is that we ought to take the
votes
and then if if the refusal is positively
passed then the chair still may still
choose to take it to referrals committee
sorry thank you mr dupree
um yes i completely i see the point made
by councillor stringer completely
um i think it's a very valid point to be
here
um
as such as i i would
i'd i would retract part of my earlier
um
advice then on that point if i could
yeah i'd be bearing that in mind and
thank you council australia for pointing
that point out in that respect
um and i would um
i would advise that such as um we've
said yesterday
um that is based on the decision um
taken if it does go to that point that
then
you could um still use that power then
chair if the if it was a pre with the if
a refusal did go through
i have to say that was the point i
brought up when i did have a discussion
a minute ago with the legal officer
however i was advised otherwise so what
are you now telling me as a legal person
no i think the point is i mean i when mr
carmichael reader read it out i did
take note of the word decision i
i think my
initial interpretation was it would be
reasonable for you to say i'm reading
the mood of the meeting and i'm making
the decision now i think i think we oh
yes on balance we ought to we ought to
go ahead and vote on council stringer
and councilman mel's resolution and then
you decide what to do madam chairman
okay cheer can i i'm sorry it's vincent
can i suggest that seeing this is such a
tricky point rather than mr dupree
base his advice on
mr carmichael reading the text can mr
carmichael send a copy of the docu that
piece of the document to mr calm
to mr duprey and we actually have the
benefit of mr depray's opinion having
read it for himself and perhaps with a
minute or two's calm reflection
because i'm just a bit worried that
we're we're going one way and the other
one way and the other and actually mr
duprey hasn't read it for himself
struggling to get hold of the
constitution online and keep the
this this other thing going at the same
time so it was just that
we've all been having technical problems
today
um
if
well if we take five minutes then while
mr duprey gets hold of a copy of this
but um i was given the advice and i've
acted on the advice
indeed madam chairman that's no
criticism there of you at all um
i will
well if i if i can go out
right okay thank you very much it's on
thank you
i'm just it's a link that i'm trying to
open and it's
i don't know if it's the same problem i
have that there i
because i'm in one system i can't read
something else on another
[Music]
hmm
c
uh
chair uh in in the instance of brevity
and not bringing the council uh in
an i.t into disrepute
can i suggest a way forward that i
withdraw my motion
and that i back your motion under the
understanding that you'll get that legal
advice in the meantime
hello sorry is he in depre here sorry
i've i just
the system was being very slow loading i
was i was in the constitution but every
page was downloading itself in in slow
motion
so
ian can you just hold on a minute
councillor stringer do you want to hear
what ian has to say first before you
post
i think i i do we do owe you an answer
council stringer i'm sure
well i just don't i don't it's it's not
a good look is it and and you know
we want efficient debate and efficient
decision making and and if we can't get
it then you know but
yeah
okay
i'm not sure that that ian heard your
comment councillor stringer okay well i
think i heard council stringer offering
to withdraw his
uh proposal and accept he i think yes i
did hear what he said all right
okay
so
i think i think that's the only way
we're gonna you know break this deadlock
i think is oh we're going to end up
there anyway i think so if if i could
have the clear understanding that we
will go and get some count sales opinion
on the status of neighborhood plans
vis-a-vis mppf and whether the tilted
balance is invoked or not
uh
then i will i will reluctantly back that
deferral
but as i said to you that's very not
only magnanimous of you it's very
sensible because it gets us out of yep
future issues
we we owe this to the hundreds of hours
that have gone involuntarily absolutely
and that was why my difficulty was
coming in in the first place yes i
understand so i will make i will
withdraw that magnanimously or do you
want someone else to make the proposal
cancel a stringer well i'll withdraw
mine but you understand why i put it and
why i would go into the wire and we
should be testing this system but i will
you know
in the pursuit of brevity and getting my
life back i will withdraw that on that
clear understanding we will get
council's opinion on this
and councillor humphreys was that what
you were about to
agree to
string i think it's the right move uh
and therefore because of that i would
like to propose with the conditions that
you've applied and uh and discussed
there that we move forward
for the status of neighborhood plans v
nppf and the tilted balance yes
if i may
interrupt if we i understand counselor
has graciously withdrawn his his
proposal are we
is that the new proposal is that we take
council's advice but
but and the decision to be made by sorry
by which committee when
well that would then come back to
committee b again wouldn't it third
isn't it yeah
back to us
well yes that would be that is that that
is a logical
thing to do indeed yeah i'm grateful to
council stringer
so sorry
sorry to add to this but in view of the
delicacy of this
do you think it would be appropriate for
us to share our brief to the barrister
with members
so that you so that you so you all
understood that we were actually asking
for the advice on the basis that
councillor stringer had asked us to do
it on
yeah well i don't think that's a problem
i i don't know
can we
i
i'm in in legal and and um
the committee officer's advice on that
one and john patman g i mean
well i'm it's it will be me or a
colleague of mine who write the brief to
counsel i mean i'm it would not be
perfectly proper for it to be shared
with senior members
right
so we have a proposal do i have a
seconder for that particular motion
uh councillor castin
yes happy to second councillor humphreys
proposal
so
so we can be clear on that
right so robert would you like to take a
vote on that particular item please
thank you chair
so
if members could please respond with
four against or abstain came to
councillor james carsten
four
house of peter gould
four
how's the kathy guthrie
four
council for barry humphries
four councillor andrew mellon
um i'm sorry chair i'm i'm not entirely
convinced what we're voting on is it
deferral or referral
no no deferral with um the status of the
neighborhood plans versus the nppf and
the tilted balance
and
council's advice on it
and it's going it was clarified the
intentions it goes to another ordinary
committee presumably this committee be
okay i'm happy to vote for that proposal
thank you councillor councillor mike
norris
four
councillor andrew stringer
four
and castle rolling wall boys
paul
thank you chair that is carried
unanimously and i'm very grateful for
everybody's input there because we want
to get clarity and everything
accurate so thank you to everybody
um what i would do now um is that um it
has been suggested to me that we are
running on
um we have one final matter to debate
um
i don't
need a proposer and a seconder but a
show of hands will do me are we able to
carry on or do people want to
stop
madam chair i've got a chairman's
briefing that was 15 30 now goes 1600 so
i am going to another meeting
madam chair that also i've been putting
off a meeting that i should have been in
at three o'clock um but they're waiting
for me so i would have to leave as well
i'm happy to carry on here
so same for me uh madam chair
what do you mean saying for you what i i
have to leave now oh you have to leave
um
i think are we going to be cool at still
or not
how many have we got left
i can't carry on we've lost two members
madam chair uh we've lost we're losing
counselling three
are members quite happy to carry on or
do they do they want um
um
get the final one out of the way one way
or the other
just to confirm and share the um quorum
of the meeting is three
just a question in case there is any um
questions regarding that
right okay
uh please accept my apologies i'm
leaving for another meeting yeah sure
thanks barry thank you bye everybody
i'm staying thank you
thank you very much madam chairman
thank you for your forbearance
right
who's presenting the last one
that's me
oh you've been very patient in the
background i think i wrote on on my
papers here this is quite exciting
prospects very interesting
interesting case
i hope so um can everybody see the
powerpoint presentation
yep
excellent i'll
make a start so yeah so this is
application dc twenty zero one six nine
seven
um it's at barley brick farm laksfield
road stradbroke and it is for the
sighting of a heat array and exchange
container
um
[Music]
let's go here so um here's the aerial
map um for members
um
to the west is stradbroke
and in the center of the image
hopefully you can all see my mouse
um
there's the existing um facilities at
barley brig
this aerial map is slightly old
um it doesn't quite show everything here
or it doesn't show the anaerobic
digester plants
um
here and it doesn't show the second bomb
it's now been built
here the application
in terms of the heat array
that's proposed to run
in this section
up here within ducting
to bring it to the barn
down here the heat exchanger itself i'll
point out but in terms of its
relationship to the anaerobic digester
plant it's fairly small scale um
compared to those buildings it's sort of
like a shipping container next to those
enormous domes
um
so if you come slightly further out
we can get an appreciation for the rural
character of the area
again this map is just the same as the
old one um slightly further out and as
we go forward
if we come to a more
recent aerial map provided by uh google
we can see the scale of the the site at
the moment
so you have the honorable digester plant
here we have a number of agricultural
buildings over here we have the second
barn next to the original that we saw
before here and then the heat array will
be proposed
the heat array is is
in this section of this field
here
so if we go forward we see the site
location plan very similar to
what we've seen previously
and if we look at the constraints map we
have a small area of flood zone 2 and 3
affecting the site of the heat array
so if we come on to the array areas and
services plan
access to the heat array and
it needs to be made along the normal
access to the site
we then have the heat array outlined in
yellow
cable routing proposed um underground
beside the heat array to run around
behind the anaerobic digester plant
that little black spot that my mouse is
pointing at is the proposed location of
the heat exchanger
and this is then
proposed to run ducting again
around to the bond structures
with regards to the heat exchanger it
looks very similar to a shipping
container it should be noted by members
that the container is to be painted
juniper green to better blend with the
the surroundings it's not intended to be
blue at all
what this is proposed to do is to take
the heat generated by the underground
heat array
and also waste heat provided by the
other digester plant is currently vented
and direct that towards barns within the
site that are
proposed to be used
for the drying of crop and other
material to be fed into the anaerobic
digester
uh a strawberry parish council provided
some images now
these images
relate to the second barn
proposed on the site and the barn that
would be connected up via ducting to the
heat array and the heat exchanger
now the footprint of these barns is
that of a barn that was approved by the
council in 2017
and this barn
was implemented this summer
with regards to that 2017
application this barn is to be for
storage only
um and it's not to have
um any drying undertaken within it
this is the aerial photo
of the barn as well so members can have
some appreciation there
um
with regards to this aspect of the
application there would need to be a
rationalization of
um
this application with the 2017
application
to remove conditions on that application
that prevent the use of the barn for
drying
alternatively what could be brought
forward on site
is a separate application for another
barn which could
[Music]
purpose built for the drying of crop and
other goods to go into another digester
[Music]
and
it should also be noted that barley brig
is large enough that it has access to
permit development rights that might
allow
construction of a barn
subject to prior approval rather than
the need for full planning commission
i will pass things over to members at
this point if there are any questions or
or matters of clarity to be brought up
as regards the
report and presentation as it stands
thank you members
thank you very much
indeed um so
where are we
we are we don't have councillor custom
we don't have council gold we don't have
catholic humphreys so we'll go on to
councillor merlin do you have any
questions for the officer please
um thank you chair um
yeah i'm just trying to still get my
head around this one sorry
so there is an existing ad plan on site
and
the heat exchanger would be used to dry
material
that is going into that aed unit is that
is that right
that's my understanding yes
yeah and um
is that solely from this farm or is
there other
um
produce from other farms coming here as
well to be dried
um with regards to this application the
only thing we're looking at is the heat
array and the exchanger itself
um
if they were if the applicant wanted to
utilize
um the existing barn on-site that would
require a further planning application
to allow the drying of goods
um within that barn full stop
if the applicants wish to utilize
another barn that might either then
require a further planning application
or prior approval process either of
which the council could have regard to
and could then look to condition
issues around
where
goods to be dried within the barn
are to come from
okay i mean my concern here and to be
frank is is
is this a
viable
thing or is it farming the subsidies but
i don't think that's part of the rumor
that was committed to the slide
um so no further questions thank you
chad
thank you for that um council norris any
questions
thank you madam chair um
in a way almost related to the question
that uh councillor mellon
raised i knew it's on page 432 within
the straight book parish council
comments
uh
mentions further objections noted on
ecological and land use grounds
given concerns the operations of the
heater road may give rise to significant
vehicle movements to and from the site
as well as the possibility that the
incorrect use of the heat array will not
allow for agricultural uses of the site
well surely this is purely designed for
agricultural use isn't it
and would other farms be bringing
material in to be dried on this site do
we know
no i mean again
that's not the scope of the application
before as unfortunately councillor we
are only looking at whether or not the
installation of the heat array and heat
exchanger are acceptable on their own
terms
um
at presence
i see okay the the the barn that is on
site
is not is is prevented in planning terms
from being used for drying
so the approval or refusal of this
application wouldn't have any bearing on
um vehicle movements to or from site to
bring in materials to either dry or
removing materials that have been dried
so
sorry sorry it's purely then on
the ground of the purpose of the use of
the barn is that right
so the application before us is purely
on the installation of the heat array
and the heat exchanger
there would need to be a further
application
to either regularize the use of the barn
that's been built out which to my mind
is 2017 barn which does not allow for
the drying of goods within it
or there would need to be a subsequent
application
for the erection of a barn to allow
drying of goods to go on on the site
my suggestion to members would be that
if there are concerns about
vehicle movements to and from the site
and use of the barn to dry materials
from
[Music]
other farms in the area that that would
be the relevant point when we have that
application before us to look to impose
conditions to either limit vehicle
movements to and from the barn
or to impose restriction on the type of
goods that may be dried in the barn or
to impose restrictions on where those
goods may come from
[Music]
thank you daniel that's very helpful
just following on from councillor
norris's point there so they could be if
members were minded they could grant a
planning permission now but then be
restricted in the operation that they
wish to use it for at a later date if it
doesn't satisfy the council's
planning conditions is that right
correct there would need to be a further
application um and at that point we
could look to impose those conditions
so so they're taking a risk then as it
were effectively yes yeah okay thank you
for that sorry to have interrupted but
you brought a very good point up
councillor boris
councillor stringer
yeah uh
i would say this one declared the
interest of being a county councillor
and normally the county council looks at
planning applications that surround
waste and minerals
so the original permission for the
let me try and get this right the
original permission for the digester
was was determined by the county council
is am i correct
and and that is allowed to import
material from
here there and everywhere
so what we're asked being asked is can
just this farm have a drying area that
won't be drying stuff that comes from
far and away
are we being asked that this is not at
all linked to the waste site
so in terms of
jurisdiction for determining
applications um scc's
waste and minerals team are clear that
they believe that this is a district
matter and this is the correct forum for
determining this application
the application does not affect the
function
of the anaerobic digester on site it
merely takes a waste product that is
otherwise vented into the atmosphere
through waste heat
and utilizes that along with the heat
generated by the heating array for the
drying of crop
um
further to
um
your point account for the stringer it's
noted that there is currently an
application with
scc um regarding the conditions applied
to the digester um to allow for changes
to be made to the amount of goods that
are allowed to be processed within the
digester within a given year
but can i just um
just interrupt there a little bit there
councillor stringer we've discussed this
at briefing
no don't go away you may want to come
back
sorry we did discuss this at briefing
and this is separate from what's under
the county council guys is which you
know aware of yeah i i understand that
i'm just i'm just
being mindful that
are we
it's almost like you've got to ignore
the digester for this but frankly you
can't ignore it because what would stop
people importing stuff into this dryer
that's very wet that might then be
processed in the digester then suddenly
that's a different use and that's not
what we're approving
do you understand what i'm saying
and all the associated vehicle movements
with that
okay now i think we need to be very
clear here ultimately if i may
this is purely and simply
a
ground source heat array and it is the
relevant container exchange container
that gets connected to it
that's it that is what this proposal is
and that we need to be extremely careful
that we don't try and make it out to be
anything more than that or connected to
anything else this is
simply done on its own individual
planning modes i appreciate it's
difficult to extract from everything
else that may be going on this site but
we have to because that is exactly the
application before us and we can only
determine the application before us
i totally get that it's just that this
is quite a unique situation because we
don't see this type of drawing unit a
lot in and around mid-suffolk so
it's it's that consequence we need to be
very very clear about
well let's hope suffolk county council
are as good and clear as we are well
done andrew thank you for that
um council of war boys
any questions for yeah yes the concerns
are being raised about vehicle movements
i was just trying to find the right page
of the document but i've got papers
everywhere
it mentions it mentions two vehicle
movements a day
somewhere in one of the cup but then in
your conclusion
you uh to the planning balance you say
that there's uh only during the build-up
will be the
um
[Music]
extra traffic so
i found there's a contradiction there
so
yeah so in terms of day-to-day use of
the heat array and the exchanger there
are no vehicle movements associated with
their operation
other than
um
those to and from site for
routine inspection and maintenance of
the heat exchanger in the heat array so
it's not the case that this application
in and of itself would lead to an
increase in hgv movement to and from the
site
um i think the um
[Music]
the point that the parish council would
want to make on this
is that they have concerns over
what would come next in terms of
connecting this to a barn
or other structure for the drying of
goods and crops
and whether that
would lead to increases in vehicle
movements to and from the site
okay
thank you
and
councillor flatman do you have any
questions
for the officer at all
mrs councillor thank you chair thank you
i'm here
has she left the building no i haven't
and i've been here all day actually
quite interesting um okay
so um daniel
um
on the pages with the um report from
the um
andy ruston edwards
environmental health
and there's quite a few from him saying
that he's um i am still unable to see
satisfactory acoustic report as
requested and he said this on quite a
few pages and it's very funny that the
date on the last one
was i think the
19th the 18th of may
and then in above him came his superior
and he's got he's got lots of these
letters and then the next day
there and there you go i have no
objection or comment to make
and that was his
the management officer now that seems
strange to me
so
so there's lots and lots from him every
time he says i still want um
i would still like to um
see satisfactory acoustic report and he
said it over and over and over again
sorry julie could you give us an
indication of the page numbers
yeah um page four seven six
and
four seven seven
four seven eight
that's quite a lot from him
four seven nine
daniel can you respond to that please
yeah of course i was just
waiting in case
four seven
seven or so um
so in terms of comments from the
environmental health team there's always
been quite a lot of back and forth
between the applicant and themselves um
in terms of um existing levels of noise
on the site there is already a condition
attached to the suffolk county council
decision for the anaerobic digester that
limits noise outputs
from the anaerobic digester
in terms of comments received from mr
rutsen edwards
there's been some back and forth but
the final
round of comments received were that
actually using those conditions as a
basis
he was content that there was sufficient
scope
um
to address this issue via condition
that he has suggested in his response of
the 7th of october and it's my
recommendation to committing that should
this application be approved those
conditions are attached yeah he does
actually say if you'll excuse me on page
475
noise from the existing a.d plant
combined with the heat exchanger both
running at full capacity and then it
goes on there and then in the
recommendation it does say noise control
scheme should be enacted
is that where you're coming from daniel
yes
yeah um
yes okay i just want to make a point
there thank you chair oh no i think
that's a very good point and it needs
clearing up making sure everybody
understands it were there any other
points you wanted to ask daniel
you're muted but we'll we'll accept that
as a no
right um so
now ask the parish council if um
what
i can't read the writing it's odile vlad
on oh thank you very much indeed i do
apologize me is it my glasses are on my
head i'm sorry all my life don't worry
about it
i can't keep them up here and i can't
read thank you so much if you'd like to
have your three minutes thank you
i'm not sure i need three minutes but
i'll take what i need
the application for review today is for
a ground source heat array and the
siting of a heat exchange container the
heat exchange container will be sited on
land within the boundary of the adjacent
anaerobic digester plant
the ground source seat heat array will
need to connect to a building to be able
to operate application 1837-17
is for an agricultural building that has
was granted approval in 2017 there are a
number of conditions attached to the
grant of planning condition 10 is
particularly relevant to this planning
application before councillors today
specific restriction on development
restriction on changes of use the
building hereby permitted shall only be
used for storing of grain straw and farm
equipment stroke machinery no grain draw
drying or straw burning equipment shall
be installed reason to enable the local
planning authority to retain control
over the development in the interests of
amenity
the planning office of states in his
report at point 2.2 given the
application 1837
17 has been implemented on site further
applications will be required before any
connection to the heat exchanger and
heat array can be made to allow a barn
on site to function as a drying barn
conditioned conditions attached to
1.837.17
explicitly prevent this use within the
barn currently built out on site
given this the parish council suggests
it would be premature for this
application being considered today to be
granted as any decision could be seen as
pre-determining the outcome of any
future applications for the building
which has been built out on site or will
be built in the future
to which it is proposed this heating
array is connected thank you
now do members if they want to put their
hands up have any questions please
yes councillor stringer yeah i i
actually have a question now for the
officer actually to to comment on
does that that
condition retaining control to protect
amenity is that protection now not
needed or does approving this prejudice
that that immediately being protected
so to my mind
sorry john
i don't know if you've got the answer go
for it i'll come back okay
um so uh thank you councillor stringer
thank you john and if you want to jump
in at any point john and just confirm my
thinking that's fine as well
my mind
no the the approval of this
application does not prejudice
the decision that the council may want
to make on a future application
um the fact that we have
allowed the sighting of the heat array
and the heat exchanger
does not necessarily then mean that we
would be in a position where we are
um
we have fettered our own discretion
um on a subsequent section 73 on the
existing barn looking at condition 10
or um for determining
a future application for a fresh
barn on the site um i think that the
council would then be able to look at a
wider range of material planning
considerations including vehicle
movements including things that other
members have raised
including you know impacts of noise
impacts of whether or not goods from
outside of barley brick farm would be
dried on site
i think those are all things that will
be considered by that future application
which we don't yet have before us
thanks thank you
okay any further questions
thank you very much indeed
right so
um
may i just quickly ask a quick question
if i may daniel um just do confirm i'm
just trying to get through the paperwork
as quick as i can this end but um
this proposal before us does not
include a connection to the building and
therefore would not be in breach of
condition 10 in any shape or form
so in terms of the application it shows
ducting runs to the location of that
barn but because to my mind because
condition 10 exists
on that barn which appears to be built
out on site it would not be possible
without breaching planning control to
make that connection and utilize that
bond for the drying of goods i think if
that were the case we would then be um
looking to discuss things with
colleagues and enforcement and to take
action um in order to prevent that use
from going ahead
as things stand at present
thank you so they are very clearly
separate in the purposes of planning
merit and consideration and the
consideration that can come later thank
you
thank you for that
um i think counselor stringer you'll
have to use yours in debate later no i'm
sorry we you you've had your question
time um
unless it's for the parish council do
you have a question for the parish
council and the lady has no no afraid
not afraid not no um so we now have um
stephen bainbridge for three minutes
who
is
the agent please
hello councillors my name is stephen
bainbridge principal planning consultant
chartered member of the rtpi i like your
planning offices and i've been a baba
planning officer in my time
i was the agent to the 2015 application
for the biogas plant and also the recent
applications for the drying barns
thank you officer for his report to
committee and unsurprisingly agree with
his recommendation
on that basis i simply offer the
following clarifications for your
benefit
this development is supported
financially by ofgem planning commission
has been granted for the grain drying
building and plans showed the heat
exchanges and pumps inside the building
this proposal provides the heat source
for the grain drying the development
will consist of underground heat
transfer pipes like underfloor heating
but in reverse they have been thrust
board or trenched in so there are no
waste soils all works undertaken within
the existing arable fields which have
already been returned to agricultural
production and you have the juniper
green rectangular 20-foot heat exchanger
which will sit on an existing concrete
pad at the ad plant
the heat exchange container receives
heat energy from the field array and the
exhaust heat from the ad plant dryers
feeds this to the grain dryer building
we have had a similar proposal approved
by west suffolk in the summer uh details
of which were sent to your officer
the parish council has claimed this
planning application should have been
under the jurisdiction of the county
council as discussed with your planning
officers it was not a waste planning
development is therefore not a county
matter
to be honest it didn't matter to the
applicant which council processed the
application because as an agricultural
diversification and green energy scheme
it would have complied with both local
plans anyway
the parish council also seemed to think
the heat array can somehow overheat and
cook the ground this is not possible the
heat exchanger is simply not dealing
with that level of heat the temperature
gradient is not very high it doesn't
need to be for a ground source heat
system to operate
but there can be a lot of heat energy
stored in the large area even if the
temperatures are only a few degrees
apart
paris council is confusing heat and
energy
there are no objections from ecology and
highways reflecting those points
archaeology i know there's a suggestion
of a planning condition for a scheme of
archaeological investigation
but please understand that the field
investigation happened in the summer and
the council has the findings so that
condition isn't necessary
on noise as you've heard there's been a
lot of to throw with the environmental
health officer
but bearing in mind my long history with
the biogas plant and the work that was
undertaken there i'm glad that the eho
accepted the idea of a planning
condition to complement the one on the
biogas plant
uh to allay
any concerns that he had about noise
30 seconds left
please do not hesitate to ask
well done within within the time well
done thank you
right um so
counselor melon or anybody do you want
to put your hands up if you have any
questions for mr bainbridge
councilmellon yes indeed thank you
uh yeah thank you chair um
um
mr bamaji i've just um sort of wanted to
still understand the
what this scheme is about um
i'm a farmer myself and i understand
that grain drying is a seasonal activity
it's not a year-round activity you know
crops are harvested in july and august
they get dried they get stored and sold
so
there's considerable
uh
investment going in here to ask a
question
yeah i'm coming to a question sorry chad
um
it's been a long day
yeah uh can you
can you tell me is this just going to be
used on a seasonal basis for for drying
the crops from
the farm itself
uh so i
got the planning statement out for the
grain drying bond the reference being
1901673
and there wasn't any detail in there
about whether or not it would be
seasonal or 365 days of the year i think
the assumption was that it would be 365
some of the crops and there are
quite a lot of tonnages mentioned um
back then
um are stored elsewhere and brought in
in stages so i guess the the there's
capability there for it to be three six
five but even if it isn't um well if the
heat is being vented into an empty bomb
um i don't see a planning problem with
that
does that answer your question counselor
melon yeah i understand what this is now
yeah yeah okay thank you councillor
stringer
yeah um
well i think well there is a planning
reason why just venting
hot air using energy to generate heat
and just pushing in a barn is his you
know energy and resource retention is
and good use of energy is is a material
consideration
just just to clarify so
this is where i think a lot of the
confusions coming in so what we're being
asked to approve today is basically a
sort of giant heat pump and heat
exchanger that does not connect to
anything
so just what we're approving today won't
work will it
it you could you could put all this kit
in but there won't be a space in which
it's actually drying anything i think
that's what i just want to be clear
about um
and i don't if not i'm not really sure
why we've not got the whole it's rather
like being asked to approve a central
heating system
for you ask the question okay thank you
for it thank you
can you answer that mr bainbridge is it
that it's just the the facility and that
it won't actually be active is that
correct uh yeah i can answer that the
the red line plans for the heat array
allowed for the ducting to go
all the way up to the building which was
given permission under
20
um on the photo that you saw the parish
council kindly took
you'll have seen
um if i describe it two-thirds of a
building complete that is the building
that had the 2020 permission and then
one third of a building which is not
complete um i say that the one-third
that is incomplete
um well if you wanted to point to
anything you might say it is part of the
building that was approved in 2017 so
this planning application has a red line
producting going right up to the wall of
the barn that has planning permission to
be used for grain drying and has been
built out that part was built out
actually before the the third that
appeared incomplete
on the photo so that connection
is there
so par perhaps our officers could
clarify that
and what conditions are put on that
yeah
so um
stephen my understanding is that the
bond has been built out on site is that
approved in 2017
what you seem to be saying therefore
is
that part of that building is the barn
approved under dc 1901673
and the remainder
is part that was approved under dc
uh
i can't remember the number on my head
it's in the report for in 2017
is that correct
uh i think that probably the best way to
look at this danny is the barn that had
permission the 01673
barn
was built out and finished
and then an extension to it has been
built it matches the footprint of the
2017 one how you and i end up dealing
with that extra bit um we'll deal with
that in due course and in fact um we
have discussed
figuring out how the the multiple
permissions on site for different barns
with different expectations of them gets
dealt with
whether that be a new application or
removal of conditions or variation or
whatever and to be fair and to be honest
that would have been submitted by now
because this application has been
running since april so that is delayed
um the expectation being that we will
deal with the barns um
once this application has been
fingers crossed approved
but from my point of view the crop
drying bomb 01673
was built out implemented
and there is something else sitting
there um whether we deal with that as an
addition to
a1673 or part implementation of
183 717
i think we're yet to have that
conversation but as far as this
application is concerned um for the
field array
the red line takes it up to the wall of
the barn that is sitting there
so
excuse me interrupting i think we're
going into a long debate here which is a
planning officer i'm sure you'll enjoy
um but um what you're saying here is
then you look as though you've got to do
a retrospective application for a bit
that was tacked on is that
correct um
possibly
possibly yeah um well that'll be for
discussion with the officers but uh
possibly um
members need to understand what's there
and what isn't there
so thank you for that i think andrew
you've fleshed that out a little bit for
us yeah i think that is is there a
reason why that couldn't have all been
tidied up with this one
can we do that in debate andrew let's
let's let's just sorry
yeah you know let's just sort of go with
the questions at the moment and log that
one and you can bring it up very shortly
so thank you for that any more questions
for
the agent
no
right julie we move on to you would you
like to give us your thoughts on this
matter
thank you very much chair perhaps i can
um
thank you members as a farmer's daughter
i am absolutely supportive of farming
and the rural economy providing local
food which does not have a large carbon
footprint
you have heard the worries from the
stradbroke parish
council father clark planning rules are
put in place to protect our communities
and our countryside the application is
not straightforward and i would urge the
committee to take
on board the detailed report from the
parish
a closer look needs to be taken at what
has been built out under which planning
application to make sure we have met all
due diligence
with the application and if we need to
defer then so be it the site i would
suggest is slightly more technical and
industrial than most farm sites and
needs expert analysis
i think that if the applicant
and agent were to be upfront with the
parish council on aims and ambitions of
what actually the site intends to
achieve in growth
this would provide transparency and a
more fruitful outcome
instead looks as if it looks as if there
could be
some floating of planning rules
i am no expert and i will leave it with
you the committee to decide if you need
more clarity and maybe a site visit
covert considered it's actually in the
open air and could be achieved in the
new year
and just to quote
the aerial photo i have here taken in
2020 shows building built out is that
granted under the 1837
stroke 17 and not dc 1901673
1837 stroke 17 condition 10 states no
grain drying or straw burning equipment
shall be installed i am believing there
should be some retrospective planning
permission going on here thank you chair
oh just one more thing
it
thank you andrew for bringing that up
county and district had a little bit of
a um
shall we say a debate over this and
legal on both sides were involved
thank you
thank you julie i i think i did sort of
allude to the fact it looks as though
there needs to be retrospective planning
permission on this
can i help possibly
you might be able to
okay so condition 10 let's be very
specific about what it actually says um
so with respect to that building it says
the building hereby permitted shall only
be used for storage to grain straw and
farm equipment machinery no grain drying
or straw burning equipment shall be
installed so we're dealing with the
building the internal part of the
building in fact in terms of its use and
its
you know ability to
dry grain or not
this proposal does not alter that
condition
this proposal is not this building or
internal to this building this proposal
is a heating array external
and whether you have
any connection to the wall of the
building or not
ultimately
any future permission would need to be
needed to change this condition or
separately deal with this condition
that is not what this application does
this application does not alter
this
proposal that's been built and the
condition that's attached to it
so they are clearly separate matters
now the point though in terms of what
we're proposing and what's in front of
members today is that there is an
argument to say
what is it for
because that is true we're not entirely
sure what it's for because if it's not
for the drying of crops and so on in
this building what is it for um
what we haven't got though is that in
front of us i think that's what makes
this whole debate quite difficult we're
not sure what it's for we can probably
guess what it's for but there's a risk
but that's a risk for a future
application to undertake
um
what we're dealing with is the
physicality of does this cause harm in
the countryside does this cause harm in
any other way does it cause traffic in
its own right whether the drying of
crops in the building causes traffic or
not is a different issue
but does this facility in its own right
cause traffic does it cause landscape
harm does it cause any other harm in
planning terms
i still feel given what i've heard we
still have
too cl and i appreciate planning is a
pig in this respect you know there's
common sense and there's what planning
can do in terms of divvying up into
separate applications
but there's still a very clear line
between the two aspects we need to be
mindful of it
thank you for that john you say there's
a clear line but there's a chicken and
an egg situation here that seems to have
arisen
um i completely agree with you yeah and
that is the point of the trouble is we
are dealing with beyond you can say it's
the chicken or we're dealing with the
egg but unfortunately we can't deal with
the chicken and egg at the same time
well maybe we should defer
right any questions for counselor
flatman from my good colleagues on the
committee who have
stuck with it today please
no
okay
well we open it for debate and i can
start with counselor melon please
thank you chair
you don't store wet grain
and move it around
when you've got drying facilities ready
um
grain comes into a grain store is dried
stored and then sold
so
there's the sort of proposed
justification
or maybe not even propose justification
for this um
it is a struggle to understand in in in
purely farming terms
i'm very aware though that there are
schemes
um promoted by the government which
supports this kind of technology
um which give incentives to this kind of
technology
and sometimes those incentives are
perverse
they cause people to do things they
wouldn't normally do
in order to
benefit
from
rhi or various other payments and we
know very well from media reports that
in places like northern ireland people
got into a lot of bother about this
farmers were heating their barns to a
tremendous extent
in order to farm the subsidies
and i suspect that that's
where this
is going
and now as a green council i would
normally be in support of this kind of
technology i would much rather that we
use
ground source heating to dry grain than
we use diesel or gas
or even burning straw
however i'm not sure that's what's going
on here i i'm struggling to understand
what is going on here we have
an a.d plant which would produce excess
heat we have a straw burner which i
think has previously been approved which
could produce heat
and now we have this heat array before
us um
so i'm struggling to understand what is
really an incomplete picture of
of this application
are we
if we were to prove this are we
basically facilitating the use of a
loophole in the rhi legislation
um for this business to make money
um i would much rather that we deferred
if one application was going to be
deferred today this should be the one so
that we can get a better picture
of
what
in entirety
um the applicant intends for this site
um
so that's where i am at the moment um
confused to some extent
thank you councillor melan i think we've
got to be very careful about um
what we um
think
is going on we need to know what is
going on
and you made that point very clear thank
you
councillor norris
thank you madam chair uh i take mr
pokemon g's comments that
we should be assessing the application
that is before us which is purely
relating to the installation
of this heat array and sighting of a
heat exchange container at the same time
i don't think we're getting the full
picture here
um i would be
tended to agree that we should defer
this to be quite honest to clarify
exactly what the purpose of the
application is for
thank you
thank you for that councillor norris
and now councillor stringer
yeah
interesting one i'm sort of
i'm almost at the point where you think
well you're gonna have to approve this
because what's being asked for in terms
of development you're being asked for a
heat pump and a
load of piping and a heat exchanger and
all that
and it and that's brilliant technology
wonderful stuff what a great idea
brilliant
and you think
but where's what is he going to end up
it could end up in a manifold going into
a district heating system
but it probably isn't
um but we we don't know
um
i'm thinking
do we differ what are we going to learn
if we defer because if we defer on this
application what we actually want is a
bigger application on what actually is
going on with this heat because actually
what technically what we could be
approving here is an awful lot of energy
use
and a load of heat going up in the air
because that's basically what we're
being asked to approve isn't it there's
there's two manifolds there's two
there's pipes going into there with the
heat that can't technically go into a
building so if this is implemented
as to what we're approving what we've
basically got is something that will
take electricity convert it into heat
and then throw it up in the air
uh
i i really don't know i'm i'm tempted to
suggest we should possibly approve it
with an advisory note to say
or do we just defer it and they could
then the applicant can hear what we're
saying to say look you know what
you can't expect a community
to to gather trust with what you're
doing if you if you're just giving them
little bits of information
piecemeal
you know i i mean i feel like i'm being
treated like an idiot
and occasionally i am and i don't mind
admitting it but i i really don't feel
we're being
being dealt with quite fairly with this
application because on the basis of it
you're being asked to approve something
in development in terms is acceptable so
long as there's an end product but we
don't know what the end product is
so at the moment we've been asked to
approve something that will take energy
and take heat
and chuck it somewhere
for whatever purpose we don't know and
we don't know where
that is a very bizarre thing to be asked
so
i i really don't know
i could easily approve it because
actually what's the harm in approving
this the harm will come depending on the
consequences and the consequences we
don't know
so i understand why john payment g is
really cautious about this but frankly
what would help us is a proper
application showing actually what's
happening here and tidy this whole thing
up thank you chair
thank you for that council stringer
council of war boys
thank you madam chair
i wish i could shed some light on this i
i i'm very confused i i i picked up on
one word in the the the document synergy
and you've got three
um
sites basically that are
obviously appear to be related
generating heat moving use needing heat
and yet they're not connected up
and we can have no clear picture of what
traffic movements will be because
um we don't really know what the future
use of the buildings is going to be if
it's used for
if you have a lot more heat available so
you can drive more crops there will be
more traffic movements um
i do feel we're
it's it's a bit like when you when the
five blind men are asked to describe an
elephant
and one touches his
legs and says it's like a tree one
touches the trunk and says it's like a
snake and so on
um there's no clear picture of what it
is i rather wish the planning
application had been for a whole
site which showed how the
the structures
are related
um otherwise it's like a conceptual art
project we've been asked to approve
where the outcome is heat
and that's it
as as councillor stringer says
um
i i would like i would support deferral
to get
a more
obvious um planning application with a
more obvious input and output
of the of the system like i can't see a
way a very clear way forward at the
moment
thank you very much for that council of
war boys well i think we're all
struggling on this one um and um i think
we're all on the same page really is um
we could all approve it
great but what's it going to be doing
so
if somebody wants to make a proposal
from the floor about deferral i don't
think it's unreasonable
care i'll i'll help if you like uh
i i'll propose we defer this
and ask the officer to investigate
uh the energy use of this thing because
we do have energy use retention policies
uh and and and so
let's see what the energy use is and
what use it's going to be put to because
at the moment we've actually got the
officers describing something different
to the applicant and while we've got
that conflict even in the room today
uh i mean
the applicant seems to think they can
yeah it would just be connected to this
building fine let's come forward and
let's get it sorted out because i think
you know uh and i i really don't want to
be yeah i don't want to stand in the way
of what could be a sustainable
development but at the moment i really
don't know what i'm doing and i feel
exactly brilliant metaphor by the way i
feel like one of those blind men
and i'm pretty certain i know which end
of the elephant i'm at
yeah well thank you for that so that's a
proposal for deferral for some more
information um
how do you want to just word your
proposal for deferral if you wouldn't
mind please cancel the string of the
yeah
so that our officer can be comfortable i
think i think
we're within our right to defer this for
the officers to investigate the actual
energy use and production yeah the
energy usage and what it's going towards
i think that's a perfectly legitimate
thing to ask okay
i think that's very reasonable okay
thank you
councillor norris i think you had your
hand up next
uh yes thank you madam chair uh happy to
second the uh recommendation for
deferral
and john did you want to come in on
anything that we've um put forward there
or are you happy with that
uh was that me or yes sorry i'm sorry
yeah there isn't another genre no i
wasn't sure for a second it's been a
long day
i appreciate that i'm i'm more than
happy with that uh deferful offers to
explore both energy use and its
application and i would have suggested
that's in accordance with your wants to
make sure that uh the needs of the
countryside are justified and it's
essential for the needs of the
countryside
is that fined by the proposer and
secondary
uh i think so because it's to uphold
those you're trying to uphold those
previous conditions regarding
residential immunity etcetera yeah
that's fine yeah lovely in that case i
have a proposer and the seconder would
um the officer like to take a call
starting with there's only five of us so
go for it
thank you chair
so if members could please respond with
four against or abstain so counselor
kathy guthrie
oh
council andrew melton
yeah four deferral yeah yeah
councilman mike norris
four
councillor andrew stringer
four
and council rolling war boys four
thank you chair that is unanimously
carried confirmed by the legal officer
yes
thank you very much indeed and thank you
very much to everybody it's now pitch
black out there i couldn't believe it um
thank you for your staying power
everybody um but we i think we it was
good that we got to the end of this so
thank you very much indeed i now close
the meeting thank you
well
you